THIS HEARING OF THE SENATE
BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER THREE AND
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES -- WE
HAVE TWO PARTS THE HEARING --
PART A OF THE HEARING -- WILL BE
DEALING WITH -- SEVERAL ITEMS
RELATE TO THE MAY REVISE --
INCLUDING THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AENCY THAT
PART PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT
STATE HOSPITALS -- AND THEN I
GUESS A COLLECTION OF OTHER
DEPARTMENTS -- TOGETHER AND ALL
THE ITEMSIN PART A WILL BE.
HELD OPEN SO FOR DISCUSSION
BEING HELD OPEN.
AND THEN WE HAVE IN PART BE WE
DO HAVE A THE ONLY CALENDAR --
AND THEN WE WILL ALSO HAVE
SEVERAL ITEMS FOR DISCUSSION
INCLUDING THE PART OF AGING
REHABILITATION CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES TO OUR SOCIAL SERVICES.
AS WELL AND MOST OF THOSE ITEMS
WILL BE -- I THINK THOSE ITEMS
ALSO ARE GOING TO BE HELD OPEN
FOR DISCUSSION SO THIS AFTER TO
VOTE ON THE CALENDAR.
I WOULD ALSO MAKE NOTE THAT --
BEFORE WE BEGIN THAT -- WE WILL
BE OUR RECESSING AT AROUND
ELEVEN FIFTY TWO ELEVEN FIFTY
FIVE BECAUSE THESE WE HAVE
CAUCUS AND THEN WILL BE
RECONVENING -- AFTER THE
CONCLUSION OF THAT CAUCUS WHICH
IS PRIDE THE APPROXIMATELY ONE
THIRTY PM ALTHOUGH IT MAY BE
EARLIER DEPENDING.
AND IT'S FOR THE RECORDS OF
PEOPLE -- NO OKAY AND WITH THAT --
LET'S GO AHEAD AND BRING UP THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY -- WE HAVE
BELIEVE WE HAVE THE PART
HEALTHCARE SERVICES DEPART
SOCIAL SERVICES PART OF THE
STATE VERIFICATION HOW PLANNING
ACTIVITIES.
AS PEOPLE ARE COMING UP -- BUT
ALSO MENTION THAT -- FOR THE
ITEMS FOR DISCUSSION -- WILL BE
ASKING THE AGENCY ADMINISTRATION
TO PRESENT WE GET COMMENTS FROM
EARLY ON THE PART FINANCE.
AND THEN WE WILL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENTS WILL ASK THAT FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT PEOPLE CAN
RESTRICTOR.
COMMENTS TO A MINUTE OR LESS AND
IF -- IF SOMEONE ELSE IS READY
SAID WHAT YOU FOR PLAYING THE
SAY SAYING THAT I AGREE WITH
THAT PERSON ARE THE SAME THING
THAT WORKS.
TOO SO -- WITH THAT -- A WELCOME
AND ACTUALLY WHEN WE FIRST HAVE
EVERYONE INTRODUCE THEMSELVES
FOR THE RECORD.
EARNING CHAIRMAN PAN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS MATT SURE I'M THE CIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR WITH THE OFFICES
SYSTEMS INTEGRATION.
THANK YOU. TO ENTER PAN AND AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS RON ROBINETTE
FROM DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY
THANK YOU L. L..
BRENT METZ CARRILLO FINANCE ARE
WOODS FINANCE THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT SO WE'LL GO HEAD BEGIN
WITH.
A WELL GO AHEAD BEGIN WITH THE
STATE VERIFICATION HELP PLANNING
ACTIVITIES.
SO THIS PROPOSAL IS AN EFFORT --
TO BOTH STREAMLINE AND MODERNIZE
THE VERIFICATION PROCESS ACROSS
A VARIETY.
OF HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES --
PROGRAMS PUBLIC ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS.
THE PLANNING EFFORT IS IN ITS
INITIAL STAGES AND IT'S COMPOSED
OF IT A COUPLE OF DIFFERENT
PIECES THE FIRST BEING.
POLICY ALIGNMENT AND OPERATIONAL
AND MEANT.
TO TRY AND GET TO MORE
STANDARDIZE VERIFICATION
PRACTICE ACROSS THESE PROGRAMS
AND THEN THE SECOND PIECE IS A
TECHNOLOGICAL SOLUTION AND
THAT'S WHERE THE OFFICES SYSTEMS
INTEGRATION IS GOING TO BE
INVOLVED IN THE PLANNING.
AND THE STATE VERIFICATION HUB
ITSELF IS ENVISIONED AS A
SOLUTION TO MOVE AWAY FROM
HAVING TO VERIFY.
WITH PAPER.
AND HAVE INCREASED ABILITY TO
BOTH CONSOLIDATE AND FACILITATE
VERIFICATION DATA -- RESULTING
IN BETTER OUTCOMES FOR CLIENTS
THERE'S QUITE A FEW PROGRAMMATIC
BENEFITS BUT ULTIMATELY WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO.
IS GET MORE TIMELY AND ACCURATE
VERIFICATIONS FOR ELIGIBILITY
DETERMINATIONS.
SO THE CLIENTS HAVE THAT EASE OF
ACCESS AND A BETTER EXPERIENCE.
WE'VE SUBMITTED A STAGE ONE
BUSINESS ANALYSIS IT OUTLINES
THE BUSINESS NEED. TO DEPARTMENT
OF TECHNOLOGY AND LET WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
PLANNING WORK ON THIS EFFORT.
AS YOU CAN SEE WE'RE ASKING FOR
ONE POSITION AND CONSULTANT
RESOURCES TO MANAGE THE PLANNING
FOR THE TECHNOLOGICAL PIECE AT
THE OFFICES SYSTEMS INTEGRATION.
AND THEN AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES THEY'RE
ASKING FOR A POSITION AND
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT OUR EFFORT.
AND THEN TWO POSITIONS AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES IN
ORDER TO DO THE PLANNING THAT
THEY'RE RESPONSIBLE.
FOR I CAN TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
IT -- ANY COMES FROM DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY WHEN WE REVIEWED THE
STATE ONE BUSINESS ANALYSIS AND
THE RESOURCES REQUESTED LOOK
APPROPRIATE FOR THE SIZE OF THIS
PROJECT SO FAR.
I THANK YOU ALEJO.
ARE WE REVIEW THE PROPOSAL AND
HAVE NO CONCERNS OKAY FINANCE.
ALL RIGHT QUESTIONS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
ALL RIGHT A A PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THIS ITEM.
OKAY SEEN NONE MICROPHONE --
SELF CERTAINLY APPRECIATE --
THAT WE'RE GONNA TRY TO
STREAMLINE THINGS TOGETHER SO --
THAT WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THIS
ITEM OPENED SO THANKS VERY MUCH
PRESENTATION COULD VERY MUCH
OKAY.
RIGHT NEXT UP WE HAVE THE PART
OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH.
THE AIDS DRUG ASSISTANCE --
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM EIGHT APP MAY
REVISION ESTIMATE ADJUSTMENTS.
IN THE BERMAN CAN.
INTRODUCED THEMSELVES FOR THE
RECORD SEVEN GIFTS AT THE BORDER
[inaudible]
YOUR BROTHER.
THIS.
SECTION CHIEF WITH THE OFFICE OF
AIDS -- JOHN FROM THE DEPARTMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH.
SONYA PETTITTE KALLIO.
NEEDS.
THE NUMBERS TELL FINANCE.
WE ARE ALMOST FINANCE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD BEGAN
ON THE MAY REVISION UPDATE.
ABSOLUTELY SO -- I'M I'M HAPPY
TO SAY THAT WE DON'T HAVE -- ANY
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES IN TERMS OF
MEDICATION EXPENDITURES ARE
CASELOAD -- SO FOR FISCAL YEAR.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
THAT TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
TWENTY GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDED EIGHT UP LOCAL SYSTEMS
FUNDING -- FOUR HUNDRED AND
SEVEN POINT NINE MILLION I WOULD
KNOW GENERAL FUND APPROPRIATION.
THE REVISED CURRENT YEAR TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
BUDGET IS FOUR HUNDRED AND SEVEN
POINT FIVE MILLION WHICH IS A
DECREASE OF THREE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY TWO THOUSAND OR POINT 1%.
I WHEN COMPARED TO THE TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET.
I'M AN AND THE NET DECREASES
PRIMARILY DUE TO A DECREASE IN
PROJECTED MEDICATION SENATORS.
FOR FISCAL YEAR -- NINETEEN
TWENTY THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET --
INCLUDED EIGHT OUT LOCAL SYSTEMS
FUNDING OF FOUR HUNDRED AND
FORTY NINE POINT YOU KNOW THE
EXCUSE ME. EIGHT MILLION WITH
KNOWS -- GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATION.
THE REVISED NINETEEN TWENTY
BUDGET IS FOUR HUNDRED AND FORTY
NINE POINT FIVE MILLION WHICH IS
AGAIN A DECREASE OF AROUND THREE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THOUSAND OR
POINT 1%.
IN TERMS OF CASELOAD
EXPENDITURES. FOR FISCAL PER
CASELOAD -- PROJECTIONS RATHER
FOR FISCAL YEAR -- EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN WE'RE PROJECTING THREE
THOUSAND OR 310-009-0080 FOUR
CLIENTS WHICH IS AN INCREASE OF
APPROXIMATELY FOUR HUNDRED FORTY
THREE CLIENTS COMPARED TO
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
AND FOR FISCAL YEAR -- NINETEEN
TWENTY WE'RE PROJECTING A
CASELOAD OF 340-006-0020 EIGHT
CLIENTS WHICH IS AN INCREASE OF
ONE THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY
ONE CLIENTS COMPARED TO
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET [inaudible]
PREFER RELEASED.
THANK YOU L. L. OWNS FINANCE.
MAKE ME QUESTION COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
A PUBLIC COMMENT.
SCENE NINE WELL IT'S A BIG THREE
SMALL ADJUSTMENTS SO GOOD GOOD
PROJECTIONS.
THANKS VERY MUCH OKAY THANK YOU.
TURTLE THIS ITEM OPEN.
NEXT ISSUE.
IS -- HIV CARE PROGRAM FOR THE
FINANCIAL ELIGIBILITY TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE BECAUSE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE.
YES WE ARE THANK YOU.
SO THIS A STATUTORY CHANGE
PROPOSAL WOULD ALLOW THE OFFICE
OF AIDS TO ADOPT THE FINANCIAL
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENT AS USED
BY THE AIDS DRUG ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM NOT TO EXCEED 5100% --
FOR THE WRAPAROUND SERVICES.
ONLY THE HIV CARE PROGRAM SERVES
ABOUT THIRTEEN THOUSAND PEOPLE
IN ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES. FOR
A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT ALLOWABLE
SERVICES CASE MANAGEMENT.
TRANSPORTATION ETCETERA.
THE PROPOSED CHANGE WILL SATISFY
HER SO REQUIREMENT FROM AN AUDIT
THEY DID A COUPLE YEARS BACK TO
STANDARDIZE -- THE ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENT ACROSS THE STATE AND
WE PLAN TO IMPLEMENTED IF
APPROVED IN APRIL.
TWENTY TWENTY OKAY THANK YOU LA
YOU.
SENATE PARTICULARLY -- THIS
APPEARS TO BE A LARGELY
TECHNICAL -- CHANGE TO THE
PROGRAM ARE ONE QUESTION WOULD
BE OW THE DEPARTMENT INTENDS TO
HANDLE THE CLIENTS.
WHO WOULD NO LONGER BE ELIGIBLE
BECAUSE THEIR INCOMES ARE TOO
HIGH?
SB.
THE QUESTION.
WELL I SEE FINANCE ANY COMMENTS
ALL RIGHT WHAT YOU GO AND IT'S A
QUESTION AND SO IT'S IT'S A GOOD
QUESTION AND WE'VE ESTIMATED
THERE'S ABOUT NINETY ONE CLIENTS
THAT WOULD NO LONGER BE ELIGIBLE
LOT OF THE THIRTEEN THOUSAND
THAT WE CURRENTLY SERVE AND WE
ARE GOING TO BE.
WORKING WITH THEIR ENROLLMENT
WORKERS TO ENSURE THAT THEY GET
ENROLLED AND COVER CALIFORNIA OR
SOME OTHER INSURANCE.
ELIGIBILITY OKAY DID YOU HAVE
ANY.
I GUESS IF CONCERT ANY CONCERNS
THAT THEY MAY NOT BE ELIGIBLE
FOR THE SOME OF THE EXISTING
PROGRAMS WE DON'T BASED ON WHAT
WE'VE BEEN TOLD THEM WHAT WE
UNDERSTAND OKAY.
I THANK YOU A QUESTIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY ANY PUBLIC COMMENT.
OKAY ALRIGHT WELL THANKS FOR
MUCH SHALL WE WILL HOLD THIS
ITEM OPEN AND PRESENTATIONS WELL
OKAY.
YES THE NEXT OES INFECTIOUS
DISEASE PREVENTION CONTROL THANK
YOU [inaudible]
ACTUALLY [inaudible]
ALASKA.
YOU CAN INTRODUCE YOURSELF FOR
THE RECORD FIRST.
STE GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
JAMES WHAT I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH THANK YOU.
SO WE ARE PROPOSING A FORTY
MILLION DOLLAR -- INCREASE HER
ONE TIME ALLOCATION OF GENERAL
FUNDS TO BE EXPENDED OVER FOUR
YEARS FOR THE PREVENTION AND
CONTROL OF INFECTIOUS DISEASES.
THIRTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS WOULD
BE AND LOCAL ASSISTANCE TO GO TO
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS IN
TRIBAL COMMUNITIES TO SUPPORT
THEIR ACTIVITIES -- IN RESPONSE-TO INFECTIOUS DISEASES IN EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS -- WOULD BE FOR
STATE OPERATIONS AND THAT WOULD
INCLUDE FOR POSITIONS -- TO TO
THE ADMINISTRATIVE.
DISTRIBUTION FUNDS IN OVERSIGHT
OF THIS -- THIS FUNDING PROGRAM
AS WELL AS A CONTRACT WITH A THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA TO
PROVIDE -- TO HAVE SOME
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
PROVIDE EXPERT SUPPORT. FOR IN A
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS IN
TRIBAL COMMUNITIES AS THEY
RESPOND TO THESE INFECTIOUS
DISEASE ISSUES [inaudible]
BELIAU.
SENATE PARTICULARLY -- YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA IS EXPERIENCING A
WELL DOCUMENTED HEALTH CRISIS
WHEN IT COMES TO THE RISE OF
STDS AND THE DEPARTMENTS ALSO
RESPONSIBLE FOR RESPONDING TO
INFECTIOUS DISEASE OUTBREAKS SO
IN GENERAL WE SEE THE MERIT IN
THIS PROPOSAL WE JUST HAD A
COUPLE QUESTIONS THAT -- THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO ASK OF
THE DEPARTMENT INCLUDING --
WHETHER THE AMOUNT FOR STATE
OPERATIONS IS APPROPRIATE IT'S
20% TYPICALLY THAT'S IN A HIGHER
SHARE THAN.
SORRY THAT'S A HIGHER SHARE THAN
WHAT IS TYPICAL AND WONDERING IF
THOSE FUNDS MIGHT BE BETTER
UTILIZED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL --
ADDITIONALLY WE HAD A QUESTION
ABOUT WHETHER -- THE FUNDS WOULD
BE FLEXIBLE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
IN OTHER WORDS WHAT THEY GET A
ONE TIME GRANT ALLOCATION WAS
SOME FLEXIBILITY ABOUT HOW TO
SPEND THOSE.
FUNDS OVER THE FOUR YEARS -- AND
THEN FINALLY WE HAD A QUESTION
ABOUT HOW THE DEPARTMENT
SPECIFICALLY INTENDS TO WORK
WITH AND COORDINATE WITH A
TRIBAL COMMUNITIES. TO ENSURE
THAT THEY'RE GETTING THE
APPROPRIATE APPROPRIATE AMOUNT
OF FUNDING AND SERVICES IN THIS
AREA.
THANK YOU FINANCE.
WE ARE ALMOST FINANCE -- I THINK
WE CAN ADDRESS THE THE QUESTION
WHETHER THE FUNDING ARE FLEXIBLE
ARE NOT.
AS RARE AND THE PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE ALLOW FOR EITHER A ONE
TIME GRANT A LOCATION TWO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ARE TROUBLE
COMMUNITIES TO BE SPENT OVER
FOUR YEAR PERIOD OR ANNUAL
GRANTS -- THAT'S SOMETHING THE
DEPARTMENT WILL BE WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS ON TO DETERMINE
WHAT WOULD BE.
MORE PREFERABLE FOR OF ALL
STAKEHOLDERS.
AND THEN I THINK MY COLLEAGUES
MIGHT ON THE PITCH I CAN ANSWER
THEIR MINOR THE QUESTIONS.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS COMMITTEE MEMBERS OKAY
WELL I WILL.
YOU CAN PLEASE -- ANSWER THE
QUESTIONS ARE RAISED BY -- THE
LA -- I I WOULD I WOULD JUST
BEFORE WE DO THAT AND FOR
EXAMPLE -- THE 20% -- GOING TO
THE FIRST STATE OPERATIONS -- SO
I REALIZE YOU'RE STILL TALKING
TO STAKEHOLDERS -- SO I NOTE
THAT YOU MENTIONED THERE'S A UC
CONTRACT.
FOR A SOUNDS LIKE SOME KIND OF
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE -- BY THE
END I HAVEN'T TALKED TO THE
HEALTH OFFICERS ABOUT THAT --
THEY SEEM TO RETAIN A LOT OF
EXPERTISE ABOUT.
INFECTIOUS DISEASES SIN GIVEN
THE SUM OF MONEY -- NOT SURE I
MEAN IF THEY'RE ASKING FOR MORE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE I GUESS
THAT MAKES SENSE I JUST SORT OF
FEEL LIKE I'M.
NOW I THINK THE PROBLEM IS
PRETTY EVIDENCE -- IT.
THE END AND THEY HAVE THE SKILL
SETS BUT YOU KNOW WE CAN YOU CAN
TELL ME IF YOU HER DIFFERENTLY.
AND THEN -- NO.
FOR THAT AGAIN THE OLD LEVEL
OVERSIGHT -- I MEAN.
CERTAINLY WE WANT TO BE SURE
THERE'S OVER SAY THE MONEY IS
USED WISELY -- BUT I'M NOT SURE
WE NEED TO SPEND 20% OF THE
FUNDS DOING THAT SO I SO I THINK
YOU KNOW I THINK.
CLARIFICATION ON THAT THIS CAN
BE REALLY IMPORTANT -- IN TERMS
OF HOW IT THE FRANKLY FOR GIVEN
THE SIZE OF THE THAT'S THE
OPERATE WHAT WE'VE ALREADY HEARD
IN THIS COMMITTEE FOR SO I WON
IT APPRECIATED THANK INDUSTRY
FOR PUTTING THIS MONEY IN HERE
SO THIS IS IMPORTANT FIRST STEP.
BUT I'M ALSO CONCERNED AT THEM
SOME IS RELATIVELY SMALL GIVEN
THE SIZE OF THE PROBLEM THAT
WE'RE DEALING WITH AND THAT
CERTAINLY WE WANT TO MAKE ONE IS
MOST EFFECTIVE USE THAT I KNOW
YOU DO.
TOO THE FIVE THE FIVE FUNDS THE
GOVERNOR IS PROPOSING AND WHAT
BY ENTERTAIN THINKING ABOUT IS
THIS.
THE RIGHT AMOUNT THEY'RE
SUFFICIENT AMOUNT -- GIVEN THIS
THE CARD ACTUALLY THE OTHER
COSTS THAT WILL GO THROUGH THE
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM THAT THE
STATE ALSO PAYS.
FOR IT WE DON'T HAVE IF WE DON'T
STRENGTH OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE BUT MUCH GO AHEAD
AND ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS ALEJO
WITH PERHAPS MY COMMENTS ADDED
ON TOP.
SURE THANK YOU -- SO FOR
INFECTIOUS DISEASE CONTROL I
THINK IS IS DIFFERENT THAN SOME
OF OUR OTHER LOCAL SEND
SUBSTANCE -- PROGRAMS IN THE
DEPARTMENT HE IN EACH ONE HAS
ITS OWN CONSTRAINTS BUT WITH
INFECTIOUS DISEASE CONTROL IT'S
REALLY A PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH AT THE
STATE LEVEL AND LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS.
AND NO I WAS ACTUALLY TESTIFYING
HERE WITH DOCTOR LOVE WHO THE
HEALTH OFFICER FROM SANTA CLARA
HER FROM SANTA CRUZ COUNTY.
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT HEPATITIS
A OUTBREAK IN ONE OF THE THINGS
HE SAID WAS THAT HE REALLY
APPRECIATED THE SUPPORT THAT --
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH
PROVIDED HIM AND THAT HE HOPED
THAT THAT WOULD WE BE ABLE TO
STRENGTHEN THAT AND THAT'S PART
OF WHAT WE'RE AIMING FOR HERE WE
HAVE STAFF -- WHO ARE ON THE
PHONE OVER THE WEEKEND TALKING
ABOUT MEASLES CASES?
AND AND PART OF THE CHALLENGES
THAT WE CERTAINLY HAVE LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS IN THE STATE
THAT HAVE A LOT OF CAPACITY.
AND CAPABILITIES BUT WE ALSO
HAVE OTHER JURISDICTIONS THAT
ARE SMALLER AND HAVE FEWER
RESOURCES AND WE NEED TO BE
PREPARED TO STEP UP AND SUPPORT
THEM -- WHEN THE NEED ARISES?
SO THAT'S THE THE REASON FOR THE
SCOPE OF OF THE PROPOSAL -- FOR
FOR LOCAL SYSTEMS.
YOUR SOME OTHER QUESTIONS LIKE
TRAVELS IN YEAH SURE.
SO -- WE PARTNER WITH -- SOME
AGENCIES WHEN WE WORK WITH
TRAVEL COMMUNITIES WE WORK WITH
OTHER AGENCIES PARTICULARLY THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL INDIAN HEALTH
BOARD AND SO -- THAT WOULD BE A
REALLY IMPORTANT -- ENTITY FOR
US TO REACH OUT TO IN TERMS OF
UNDERSTANDING WHY -- TRIBAL
NEEDS ARE AND WHAT THE INPUT
FROM OUR TRIBAL COMMUNITIES
WOULD BE IN TERMS OF THESE
RESOURCES SO OUR PLAN WOULD BE.
TO REACH OUT TO THEM AND TO GET
INPUT AS TO HOW WE COULD PASSED
ME TO LEAVE MEET THE NEEDS OF OF
TRAVEL COMMUNITIES [inaudible]
OKAY.
THE MORE DETAIL WOULD PROBABLY
BE IS C..
V. HELPFUL -- SO SO IT'S WANT TO
CLARIFY THE 20% FOR STATE
OPERATIONS BECAUSE WHAT WAS
INITIALLY PRESENTED AS THIS IS
OVERSIGHT OVER THESE FUNDS.
SO THAT'S A LITTLE DIFFERENT
THAN SAYING THAT WELL.
BUT I'M SURE YOU ALSO SAY SO
THAT'S WHY I WANT TO BE CLEAR
ABOUT BECAUSE I THINK WHATEVER
LANGUAGE WE END UP.
TRAILER BILL WHATEVER ELSE THAT
GOES WITH THIS MONEY.
I I CERTAINLY CAN UNDERSTAND
SAYING WELL ACTUALLY WE NEED TO
STRENGTHEN BECAUSE IT IS A
PARTNERSHIP RIGHT WE FIRST YEAR
IT'S A PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE
STATE AND LOCALS AND REWRITE
DIFFERENT COUNTIES HAVE
DIFFERENT CAPACITIES SO.
IF YOU'RE TELLING ME THAT WELL
WHAT WE'RE DOING IS WE'RE
PUTTING 20% FOR STATE OPERATIONS
SO THAT WE CAN PROVIDE.
NOT JUST TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
BUT ALSO YOU KNOW DIRECT
ASSISTANCE TO COUNTY SPECIALLY
SMALLER COUNTIES THAT HAVE THE
CAPACITY RIGHT WE NEED TO BUILD.
SO THAT WE HAVE THAT FLEXIBLE
AND WE'RE GONNA BASE THAT AT THE
STATE.
THAT'S A LITTLE DIFFERENT THEN
I'M GONNA HIGHER FOR PEOPLE WHO
ARE GONNA LIKE GO AND BE SURE
EVERYONE DID ALL THEIR COUNTING
RIGHT ON THESE GRANTS RATE SO
THE OVER SAID GRANT SO I WANT TO
CLARIFY.
IS INTENTION OF THE STATE
OPERATIONS THEY REALIZE THERE'S
SOME STAFF TIME HAS GOT THE USED
TO BE SURE THAT THE GRANTS OR
YOU KNOW AT THAT THE MONEY WAS
SENT TO THE MONEY WAS SPENT
APPROPRIATELY AND NOW WHATEVER
REPORTS AT CETERA BUT I'M HOPING
WE'RE NOT SPENDING 20% DOING.
THAT AND THAT PERHAPS WERE
SPENDING MAYBE 5% DOING THAT
HUNTER HAS THE 15% ACTUALLY
PROVIDING ASSISTANCE FOR
INFECTION CONTROL THAT IS THE
OUTDOOR STAFFING UP FOR THAT
THAT'S WHO ARE HIRING ARE NOT
HIRING PEOPLE JUST TO DO.
CREATE REVIEW ARE SET AND SO
FORTH SO MAYBE FINANCE ONCE
ADDRESS THAT.
YES SO OF THE EIGHT MILLION%
THAT'S FOR STATE OPERATIONS
ABOUT ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION
WOULD BE FOUR FOUR STAFF
POSITIONS AT THE STATE LEVEL
THAT WOULD BE MORE.
FOR A DURING THE TRADITIONAL
GRANT OVERSIGHT ACTIVITIES THE
REMAINDER OF THE ONE POINT HOW
MUCH ABOUT ONE POINT EIGHT
MILLION.
OKAY -- THAT'S OVER THE FOUR
YEARS.
THAT'S CORRECT.
AND THE REMAINDER OF THE FUNDING
WOULD BE.
USED FOR INTER AGENCY AGREEMENT.
TO BUY THEIR CONTRACT WITH AS AN
EXAMPLE A UC EURYSTHEUS YOU
ENTITY TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL AND MORE DIRECT
SERVICES AT THE LOCAL LEVEL ON
INCLUDING SURVEILLANCE
ASSISTANCE -- I'D ADDING A
TRAINING MATERIALS AND OTHER
THINGS THAT WOULD HELP THE
LOCALS A DURING AN OUTBREAK OF
INFECTIOUS DISEASES OR ANYTHING
ELSE OF THAT NATURE THAT.
WOULD HELP THE SMALLER ENTITIES
THAT DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE THAT
CAPACITY AT THE LOCAL LEVEL SO
SO MANY JUST CLARIFY THOUGH.
SO YOU WANT YOU SEE TO DO THAT
OR THE STATE I MEAN THE I'M
HEARING A CONTRACT WITH YOU SEE.
THE RATIONALE FOR YEAH VERSES
THE STATE HEALTH DEPARTMENT I
MEAN I USED TO BE BACK IN THERE
YOU SEE SO I HAVE A LOT OF
RESPECT FOR YOU SEE HIM BUT
THEY'RE NOT A PUBLIC HEALTH
AGENCY IMMEDIATE PEOPLE FOR A
DAY OF SCHOOLS OF PUBLIC HEALTH
THE TEACH PUBLIC.
HEALTH I MEAN I'M NOT SAYING
PEOPLE THOUGH THERE'S SOME SOME
CAPACITY THERE BUT USUALLY
THAT'S NOT THERE.
TRADITIONAL ROLE IS TO SO I MEAN
I GUESS THEY CAN DEVELOP
MATERIALS AND SO FORTH BUT YEAH
WE HAVE A LOT OF EXPERIENCE
WORKING WITH THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA TO PROVIDE -- SPEECH
AT TO IDENTIFY STAFF THAT CAN
HELP US WORK WITH LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS AND THEY HAVE
TECHNICAL EXPERTISE WE WORK
CLOSELY WITH THEM -- USING THOSE
RESOURCES TO PROVIDE A PUBLIC
HEALTH SERVICE SO THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE CURRENTLY DO
AND AND WOOD PLANT AT YOU WITH
THIS WITH THIS PROJECT OKAY WELL
I I GUESS WHAT I'D SAY IS IS
THAT AT LEAST WHAT I'VE BEEN HER
HEARING INVOLVED AGE SIXTY SO
INSTEAD.
OF A PUBLIC COMMENT IS THAT.
I'VE HEARD MORE FROM LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS THAT THEY
NEED.
PEOPLE ON THE GROUND LIKE WE
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH STAFF OF
THERE'S AN OUTBREAK I HEAR ABOUT
YOU KNOW LAB RESOURCES OF FORCE --
NOT TO SAY THAT SOME OF THEM
COULDN'T USE LIKE TECHNO SYSTEMS
TRAINING MATERIALS AND STUFF
LIKE THAT BUT A..
N. D. AGAIN I DON'T THINK DOWN
OF SAME AS ADULT OFFICERS HERE
THEY CAN SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES
BUT I I JUST WANNA BE SURE WERE
EFFECTIVELY USING THE I MEAN
THAT THIS IS AN ALL AUTUMN
BALLOTS THIS WAS A IT'S NOT A
WHOLE LOT OF MONEY GIVEN THE
SCALE.
OF THE PROBLEM AND I AND SO.
IF YOU KNOW I JUST WANT TO BE
SURE THAT THE THAT EVEN EVEN THE
WHOLE FORTY BILL WITH FORTY
MILLION OVER FOUR YEARS I MEAN
THERE'S ONLY.
ME STAFF THE HIGHER IT'S AT WITH
THAT AND SO I JUST WANNA BE SURE
WE'RE PROVIDING THE COULD RIGHT
KIND OF ASSISTANCE TO OUR HEALTH
OFFICERS THAT ARE ACTUALLY AND
IN THE MOST EFFECTIVE.
DOING THAT YOU KNOW YOU I KNOW
REAL I REALIZE THAT YOU KNOW YOU
YOU WORK WITH THE MORE CLOSELY
THAN I DO SO -- BUT WHAT I'VE
BEEN HEARING IS MORE ABOUT WE
NEED PEOPLE ON THE GROUND I AND
THAT -- IT'S NOT AS MUCH
TRAINING MATERIALS NOT SAYING
THAT THEY CAN USE TRAINING BUT
IT'S MORE ABOUT YOU KNOW WE NEED
MANY PEOPLE HEALTH HAS TO STUFF
AND WERE HAVING A HARD TIME ON
RUBIO GETTING GETTING THE PEOPLE.
STILL HAVE MONEY RIGHT ARE OF
SUCH AS IT WERE CUT OVER THE
RECESSION SO FORTH AND THE
COUNTIES.
YEAH AND DAT INTERESTED TO
RESPOND TO THAT.
WE ENVISION THAT THE SOME OF
THESE RESOURCES THE PLEASE
TECHNICAL RESOURCES WOULD BE
AVAILABLE TO HELP LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS IN A SEARCH
SITUATION SO PEOPLE WHO CAN HELP
WITH DATA MANAGEMENT.
FOR THERE'S A LARGE EXPOSURE TO
MEANS ALL OF IT -- YOU KNOW.
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS NO YOU
SEE WHAT ACTUALLY TO HELP THEM
DO THE DATA MANAGER DIRECTLY
IT'S NOT JUST LIKE FOR WRITING
IT VICE AND HOW TO DO IT EXACTLY
ESPECIALLY WHEN THERE WAS
MULTIPLE OUT ON X. AT THE SAME
TIME WHEN YOU SAW MEASLES AND
USE OUR CONTRACTS IF.
WAS IN USE I MEAN YOU NEED PUTS
ON THE GROUND WHICH ALSO NAY
RISK COMMUNICATION UNIT AT B.
SURVEILLANCE ON A LOT OF
TEACHERS SECTIONS JUST DON'T
HAVE THAT CAPACITY.
SO THEY CERTAINLY TURNED TO US
TO ACTUALLY TRY TO HELP THEM IN
THAT REGARD WE SAW THAT OVER THE
PAST COUPLE YEARS WITH SOME OF
THESE OUTBREAKS.
ESPECIALLY ONES THAT WERE
HAPPENING AT THE SAME TIME.
OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL THERE'S NO
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COULD YOU
WANT TO TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AND
SURE MEMBERS RAND MARTIN HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION.
IF THIS IS THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL A DEAL IN AT LEAST IN
PART WITH THE ESCALATING LCD
EPIDEMIC.
THIS PROPOSAL IS WHOLLY
INADEQUATE -- FIRST OFFICE ONE
TIME -- ONE TIME ONLY FUNDING
FORTY MILLION OVER FOUR YEARS WE
WOULD WE'VE BEEN DOWN THIS PATH
BEFORE WHEN YOU APPROPRIATED
FIVE MILLION IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
THAT WAS EXPENDED OVER THREE
YEARS DPH SO THEY COULD NOT
SPEND IT ON THE THINGS THAT WERE
NEEDED.
LIKE WHICH WHICH AS YOU
MENTIONED WAS BOOTS ON THE
GROUND -- AND FOUR FORTY MILLION
OVER FOUR YEARS DOES NOT GIVEN
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BUY IT PAY
FOR THE NGOING COST.
IT'S TOO SMALL AMOUNT OF MONEY
FORTY MILLION TO DEAL WITH ALL
INFECTIOUS DISEASES STDS -- HIS
HAS BEEN HOSTILE OR KLAY
UNDERFUNDED -- AND NEEDS
ADDITIONAL MONEY -- THERE IS --
NO FURTHER DIRECTION TO THE
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
ON HOW TO DEAL WITH THE STDS YOU
HAVE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE I
HOPE YOU'RE GOING TO CONSIDER --
IN A LEAVE IT WITH THAT THANK
YOU [inaudible]
YOU.
WELCOME.
MICHELLE GIVENS OF THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION A
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS A WE DO
SUPPORT THE ADMINISTRATION'S ME
REVISION PROPOSAL FOR AT TO
PROVIDE FUNDING FOR INFECTIOUS
DISEASES.
A FEW THINGS THAT I WOULD JUST
HIGHLIGHT THOUGH GIVEN THE
LIMITED AMOUNT OF FUNDING AND OF
COURSE WE HAVE BEEN ADVOCATING --
FOR MUCH MORE GIVEN THE NEED A
WE WOULD ASK THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ENSURE THAT THE
FUNDS ARE MAXIMIZED AND AND MADE
AVAILABLE TO THE LOCAL LEVEL FOR
BOOTS ON THE GROUND PURPOSES.
I'M IN ADDITION I JUST WOULD
RECOMMEND AB FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE HIS TESTIMONY THERE
WAS TWO WAYS THAT THIS FUNDING
COULD BE DISPERSED IT COULD BE
DONE IN ANNUAL ALLOCATION OF TEN
MILLION OR IT COULD BE DONE UP
FRONT.
WE WOULD ENCOURAGE AND SUPPORT
ADD THE LEGISLATURE LOOKING AT
UP FRONT ALLOCATION SO THAT
FOLKS COULD MAXIMIZE THAT
FUNDING AND DO SOME PLANNING
OVER THE COURSE OF THE FOUR
YEARS SO HAVING THE MONEY
PROVIDED UP FRONT.
WITH FOR YOUR EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY IS IS MUCH HELP MORE
HELPFUL FOR US WE ENCOURAGE THAT
THE LEGISLATURE TO MAINTAIN THE
FLEXIBILITY SO IT'S NOT DISEASE
FOCUS BUT ALSO JUST BROAD IN
TERMS OF INFECTIOUS DISEASE
CONTROL IN GENERAL.
AND WE ALSO WITH ASAT AD SHE
IRAQ AND SEE SEE LATE SHOW BE --
PARTNERS AT THE TABLE AND BE
REQUIRED ADD THAT THE STATE BE
REQUIRED TO CONSULT WITH US IN
CREATING AN ALLOCATION
METHODOLOGY THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU A CAT TO BURKE WITH
THE HEALTH OFFICER'S ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF THIS
PROPOSAL -- LIKE OUR COLLEAGUES
AT GEAC OF WE APPRECIATE THE
BROAD NATURE THAT NON DISEASE
SPECIFIC FUNDING WHICH HAS
GOTTEN US INTO TROUBLE IN THE
PAST.
AND WE ALSO ECHOED THE SENTIMENT
THAT WE NEED TO GET AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE TO THE LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WELCOME KELLY BROOKS I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA ON THE BOARDS OF
SUPERVISORS OF VENTURE --
RIVERSIDE AND SANTA CRUZ COUNTY
IS -- IN SUPPORT OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL WE
APPRECIATE THE RECOGNITION -- OF
THE DIRE NEED FOR INVESTMENT IN
PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE IN
THE STATE I'M AND I WOULD --
ECHO MANY OF THE COMMENTS MADE
BY -- CC LA JOH AND SHE ACT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS COURTNEY
MAHER PEARSON I'M HERE FROM THE
SAN FRANCISCO AIDS FOUNDATION
ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ATV ALLIANCE.
I'M NOT SURE IF THIS IS THE
RIGHT PLACE TO PUT THIS COMMENT
BUT I'M GONNA TRY -- SO WE
SUPPORT THAT -- INVESTMENT IN
PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE AND
RECOGNIZE THE NEED TO ADDRESS
INFECTIOUS DISEASES BUT
MAINTAINED THAT THERE NEEDS TO
BE -- ADDITIONAL FUNDING
ALLOCATED TO ADDRESS THE UNIQUE --
NEEDS OF PEOPLE LIVING WITH ARE
PREVENTING HIV H. C. F.
HEPATITIS C. N. STDS AND WE
CONTINUE TO CALL ON THE GOVERNOR
AND LEGISLATURE TO ALLOCATE TWO
MILLION DOLLARS TO CONVENE -- AS
STATEWIDE ENDING EPIDEMICS TASK
FORCE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
OKAY THE OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY SO AGAIN I I DO WANT TO
THANK THE GOVERNOR FOR PUTTING
THIS PROPOSAL FORWARD I THINK
YOU KNOW WE HAVEN'T SEEN
SOMETHING LIKE THIS FOR A WHILE --
I AM.
DEL I AM CONCERNED THAT WHETHER
DISS SUFFICIENT I REALIZE THAT
THE COUNTIES INNER ONCE SAID YOU
KNOW OBVIOUSLY THEY'RE HAPPY TO
SEE SOMETHING LIKE THIS -- GIVEN
WHAT WE'VE HEARD BEFORE -- AND A
AT BECAUSE I DO THINK WE NEED TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO BUILD MORE
CAPACITY ON THE GROUND I
CERTAINLY SEE THE NEED ALSO.
EVEN WE PUT IN A MORE MONEY
WE'RE STILL GONNA HAVE COUNTIES
ARE SMALLER WHO NEED MORE HELP
SO I APPRECIATE THAT.
I HOPE THE ALSO WERE CLEAR AND I
APPRECIATE CLEAR FILIATION FROM
FINANCE THAT WERE THAT WE'RE NOT
GONNA BE SPENDING 20% DOING
GRANT OVERSIGHT OKAY I MEAN IT'S
WHAT WE WANT TO DO IS BE SURE WE
BUILD CAPACITY RATE.
AND FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN BUILD
AND THEN MAINTAIN THAT CAPACITY
SO I APPRECIATE NOW I UNDERSTAND
ONE TIME FUNDS VERSES ON GOING
IT CETERA BUT HOPING THAT WE
MAYBE CAN DO A LITTLE MORE
BECAUSE WE ARE.
WE ARE WE HAVE THE BIGGEST TV
OPERATE GOING ON RIGHT NOW I
MEAN IT'S NOT WHAT'S MAKING THE
NEWS YOU KNOW MEASLES MAKING THE
NEWS.
TRY TO DEAL WITH THAT TOO BUT
AND THERE'S RIGHT YOU HAVE
SIMULTANEOUS EVENTS AND SO FORTH
BUT WE HAVE MEASLES I MEAN WE
HAVE.
STDS WE HAVE SOMETHING ELSE SO
COME OVER THE RISE AND WE WON'T
GUESTS OF COURSE WE STILL HAVE
VALLEY FEVER YOU KNOW WEST NILE
VIRUS.
NO AND WHO KNOWS WHAT THE NEXT
FLU WILL BE LIKE NEXT FLU SEASON
SO -- APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
LEADERSHIP THE PUTTING THIS
INVESTMENT FOR A THINK THERE'S
SOME MORE DETAILS THAT NEED TO
BE FILLED IN -- AND I'M HOPING
THAT MAYBE WE COULD ALSO
CONSIDER -- SOMETHING A LITTLE
LARGER THAN THIS I THINK THE TO
GET MORE BOOTS ON THE GROUND --
BECAUSE I THINK WE'RE STILL
BEHIND BUT CREATE THE
PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN
THANK YOU.
PROGRAM ANALYSTS AND YOUR
ACCOUNTING.
I GUESS.
THREE OKAY GENETIC DISEASE
SCREEN PROGRAM A REVISIONIST
MANAGEMENT'S WELCOME YOU CAN
INTRODUCE YOURSELF FOR THE
RECORD FIRST I'M LESLIE GAFFNEY
THAT -- ASSISTANT DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE CENTER FOR
FAMILY HEALTH OKAY ANYTHING WHEN
YOU PERSONAL FINANCE HERE YES
HONEY BECAUSE EVEN FINANCE THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THESE PERCENT.
SO YOU HAVE ASKED FOR AN UPDATE
ON CASELOAD AND EXPENDITURES
STRANGEST -- CASELOAD WITH
NEWBORN SCREENING AND PRENATAL
SCREENING IN.
YOUR AND BUDGET YEAR IS DROPPING --
ACROSS THE BOARD VERY SIMILARLY --
FOR FOR BOTH PROGRAMS BETWEEN
ONE POINT SIX AND ONE POINT 8%
AND THAT'S A DIRECTLY
ATTRIBUTABLE TO THE CONTINUED
DROP IN THE BIRTHRATE -- CURRENT
YEAR EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY
THERE'S A REDUCTION IN A OF TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS WHICH AGAIN IS
TIED TO CASELOAD.
IN BUDGET YEAR.
NEWBORN SCREENING IS ASKING FOR
AN AN ADDITIONAL ESTIMATED
INCREASE IN EXPENDITURES OF TWO
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS AND
THIS IS ATTRIBUTED.
TO INCREASES IN THE CONTRACTED
RATES FOR BOTH THREE AGENTS AND
FOLLOW UP CONTRACTS.
AND THEN PNS IS ADJUSTING --
THEIR EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY DOWN
BY FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND THAT'S
ATTRIBUTED TO THE DROP IN CASE
LET.
IT'S PRETTY SIMPLE.
OKAY THANK YOU ALEJO COMMENTS
FINANCE.
THE MEMBERS ARE A PUBLIC COMMENT.
ARE IN THIS.
ALRIGHT WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I GUESS IT'S ALL.
HANDS ON BIRTHRATE RIGHT.
WELL THANKS FOR YOU DO.
AND APPRECIATE -- KNOWING.
HOW MANY LIVES WERE WERE SAVING
BY PICKING UP DISEASES EARLY ON
SELF THREE IMPORTANT THANK YOU?
ALL RIGHTS THAT'S MOVE ON WE
HAVE THE LOOK AT PROGRAM MAY
REVISION ESTIMATE.
THE MORNING I'M CHRISTINA OLSEN
CHIEF OF THE WEAK DIVISION AND
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
I'LL GIVE A BRIEF -- UPDATE WE
DO WITH ADJUSTED THE CASELOAD
ESTIMATES FOR THE MAY REVISION
AS LESLIE HAD MENTIONED --
THERE'S A BEEN A THE CONTINUED
DECLINE IN THE BIRTHRATE.
AND SO WE HAVE A VERY SMALL
ADJUSTMENT AND BOTH IN THE CASE
LOAD FOR CURRENT AND BUDGET YEAR.
WE'VE ALSO ADJUSTED THE FOOD
EXPENDITURES FOR CURRENT AND
BUDGET YEAR LESS THAN A 2%
ADJUSTMENT ON BOTH OF THOSE
ITEMS.
WE DO HAVE SOME NEW FUNDING THAT
WE'RE EXCITED ABOUT ON OUR LOCAL
SYSTEM SIDE TO SUPPORT OUR
TRANSITION TO THE WEIGHT CARD
AND REPLACEMENT OF OUR COMPUTER
SYSTEM.
WE RECEIVED A ONE TIME GRANT
FROM THE U. S. TA THAT COVERS
CURRENT YEAR AND BUDGET YEAR SO
YOU'LL SEE AN INCREASE IN OUR
OVERALL EXPENSE AND A REVENUE
THERE AS WELL.
THANK YOU WILLIAM COMMENTS
FINANCE COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC COMMENTS.
OKAY.
RIGHT WELL THANKS VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE UPDATE
[inaudible]
OKAY.
BECAUSE WE WANT TO ISSUE NUMBER
SIX CALIFORNIA VISITING BLACK
INFANT HEALTH PROGRAMS FEDERAL
MATCHING FUNDS [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING LESLIE CHOLESKY AND
C. H. DIVISION -- AS YOU
REMEMBER WE REQUESTED THIRTY
POINT FIVE MILLION IN STATE
GENERAL FUND TO EXPAND OUR
CALIFORNIA VISITING A BLACKENED
AND HEALTH PROGRAM.
AND AFTER GOING BACK AND RE
CALCULATING HOW WE CAN USE THE
STATE GENERAL FENCER DRAWDOWN
TITLE NINETEEN FEDERAL DOLLARS
WE ARE HERE TO REQUEST
REIMBURSEMENT EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF THIRTY FOUR POINT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS TO DRIVE
DOWN ADDITIONAL TITLE NINETEEN
FEDERAL FUNDING TO REALLY.
MEET THE NEEDS OF OUR MOMS AND
BABIES AT THE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
WE WANT TO REMIND YOU THAT ONLY
STATE GENERAL FUNDS AND LOCAL
DOLLARS CAN BE USED TO DRIVE
DOWN TITLE NINETEEN DOLLARS
THEREFORE THERE IS NO ADDITIONAL
COST TO THE STATE FOR THIS
REQUEST.
THANK YOU VALUE.
FINANCE.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS [inaudible]
NO.
A PUBLIC COMMENT.
WELCOME TO THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA HERE TO SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL THANK
YOU.
OKAY WELL APPRECIATE DEPARTMENT
WORKING HARD TO FIND FEDERAL
MATCHING MONEY.
THANK YOU THESE RICH.
OKAY NEXT UP IS ISSUE NUMBER.
SEVEN I PROPOSITION NINETY NINE
ADJUSTMENTS
.
WOULD IT BE A MORNING MONICA
MORALIS CENTER FOR HEALTHY
COMMUNITIES AT C. P. H..
SO -- DUE TO THE JUST MISSIN
PROPOSITION NINETY NINE REVENUE
CITY PH IS REQUESTING
APPROPRIATION INCREASE IN OUR
HEALTH EDUCATION ACCOUNT.
SPECIFICALLY FOR COMPETITIVE
GRANT SUPPORT OF NINE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS.
AND LOCAL ASSISTANCE OF A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS THESE
EFFORTS WILL SUPPORT THE
ADOPTION.
AND INFLATION OF IMPLEMENTATION
OF TOBACCO PRODUCTS WASTE POLICY
AS WELL AS OUR WORK WITH THE
MILITARY.
COMMUNITY AND SUPPORT THE GAY
LESBIAN BISEXUAL TRANSGENDER AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER POPULATION
ACTIVITIES TAKING PLACE.
IN ADDITION WERE ALSO REQUESTED
AN INCREASE IN THE RESEARCH
ACCOUNT -- AGAIN SPECIFICALLY
FOR STATE ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT
OF A HUNDRED AND TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
AND FOR EXTERNAL CONTRACTS OF
FOUR HUNDRED ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS THIS SUPPORTS OUR WORK
PERTAINING TO CANCER TRACKING
INCIDENTS AS WELL AS OF THE
AUTOMATION OF OUR CANCER.
DATA ACTIVITIES.
AND THEN FINALLY WERE HERE --
SKEWS ME SPECIFICALLY TO THE
UNALLOCATED ACCOUNT.
AND THIS IS READY TO SUPPORT --
FOR ABOUT TWENTY NINE THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO SUPPORT OUR WORK
PERTAINING TO THE PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKFORCE.
BOTH AT THE LOCAL AND STATE
LEVEL AND THIS IS AROUND
TRAINING -- AROUND
STANDARDIZATION OF DATA
COLLECTION COMMUNICATION AND THE
PROGRAM ALIGNMENT.
THANK YOU LA -- COMMENTS FINANCE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY PUBLIC COMMENTS OKAY AND
JUST TO CLARIFY SO THE
RESEARCHER CAN YOU MENTIONED AS
PART OF THIS GOING FOR THE UP.
CANCER DATABASE CORRECT YES OKAY
CELLS SO THE STATE MAINTAINS A
DATABASE OF ALL.
OUR CANCER REGISTRY CORRECT
CORRECT WE WORK WITH -- THREE
THE REGISTRIES IN RIGHT AND
THERE'S NO ISSUE WITH PRIVACY
CONCERNS WITH THAT RIGHT IT'S
ALWAYS BEEN SECURE OUR ACT OKAY
I'M GLAD TO KNOW THE PART OF THE
HEALTH.
KNOWS HOW TO HANDLE HEALTH
INFORMATION SECURELY THANK YOU
RIGHT IMAGE.
OKAY ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT TO THE
USE OF MARIJUANA ACT CARE OF THE
SURVEILLANCE AND EDUCATION.
WELCOME YOU HAVE INTRODUCED
CELLS FOR THE RECORD FIRST.
THAT AFTERNOON SAYS ABOUT CHIEF
DEPUTY FOR PUBLIC HEALTH.
THE MORNING A TRICIA BLOCKER
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH.
SUE THIS PROPOSAL -- IS TWELVE
MILLION DOLLARS OF THE TAX
ACCOUNT THAT OF THE 60% OF THE
TEXT FROM THAT GOES TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO BE ALLOCATED FOR
YOUTH EDUCATION PREVENTION.
AND WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING TO DO
IT THESE DOLLARS IS TO SET UP A
SURVEILLANCE SYSTEM.
SO THAT WE REALLY KNOW THE
IMPACT OF THE LEGALIZATION OF
CANNABIS AND YOU HAVE IN THE
CAMINO IT'S SORT OF THE
BREAKDOWN OF HOW WE CHOOSE TO
SPEND THE FUNDS.
WHAT WE'LL DO WITH THAT IS IN
THE FIRST YEAR BUILD THE
SURVEILLANCE SYSTEMS OF THE
DOLLARS ARE EXPENSIVE TO BRING
NEW DATA SETS ON TO BUILD OUT
SURVEYS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE --
BUILDING THAT NETWORK THAT
STRUCTURE BOTH ON THE I. T. SIDE
AS MONTHLY ANALYTICS SIDE -- AND
THEN WE WILL BE CONTINUING THE
EFFORT WITH THE LET'S TALK
CANNABIS CAMPAIGN -- WILL BE
DOING A BASELINE DATA REPORT AND
THEN BUILDING THE ALL OF THE
INFORMATION WE'RE COLLECTING
INTO BETTER PUBLIC EDUCATION AND
WHAT ARE THE RISKS AROUND
CANNABIS AND SO WE'RE EXCITED TO
HAVE SOME FUNDING WE HAD ONE
TIME FUNDING WHERE WE PUT
TOGETHER IN A VERY SHORT TIME
LINE -- AND THAT LET'S TALK
CANNABIS CAMPAIGN WE DID SOME
FORMATIVE RESEARCH BUT WE REALLY
WANT TO BUILD ON THAT AND
CONTINUE THAT EFFORT AND MAKE
SURE THAT WE BRING TO GATHER.
DATA FROM.
THE AND LAW ENFORCEMENT FROM
HEALTH CARE UTILIZATION FROM EMS
KIND OF ALL REAL TIME DATA AND
I'M MORE QUICKLY WE CAN BUILD
THAT DATA INTO A SYSTEM AND
THAT'S REAL TIME.
THE BETTER WE CAN TARGET ANY
INTERVENTIONS THAT WE WOULD NEED
TO DO TO REDUCE THE RISK BUT
ALSO TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
KNOW THAT FOR PREGNANT WOMEN FOR
USE.
THAT THEY REALLY DO UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE ARE RISKS ASSOCIATED
WITH US.
THANK YOU LA A SENATE
PARTICULARLY -- AS YOU KNOW IN
GENERAL ARE OFFICE IT HAD SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS WHEN IT COMES TO
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE USE
ACCOUNT FUNDS OVERALL AND
SETTING UP SORT OF A FRAMEWORK
FOR HOW TO SPEND THOSE FUNDS
WISELY -- SITTING UP SORT OF A
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT FRAMEWORK --
REGARDING THIS -- SPECIFIC
PROPOSAL I GUESS THE ONE
QUESTION THAT OUR OFFICE WOULD
HAVE IS JUST HOW THE DATA
INTERFACING WOULD INCLUDE.
THIS IS SPECIFIC TO CANNABIS USE
BUT HOW IT WOULD INCLUDE OTHER
FORMS OF SUBSTANCE USE ISSUES SO
THAT YOU CAN DO SOME COMPARATIVE
ANALYSIS ACROSS ALCOHOL OPIOIDS.
YOU KNOW THE OTHER TYPES OF
ISSUES FACING YOUTH.
ANY COMMENTS OKAY QUESTION
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
YES CENTER SOME THANK YOU MISTER --
WHAT THE?
TYPES OF COMMUNICATIONS ARE YOU
CONSIDERING PROVIDING PUBLIC
SERVICE ANNOUNCEMENTS TO TRY TO
CURB.
VIEWS UTILIZATION OF MARIJUANA.
SO WE WOULD DO WHAT WE DID WITH
THE LET'S TALK CANNABIS CAMPAIGN
AS WE DID EXACTLY THAT -- PUBLIC
SERVICE ANNOUNCEMENTS WE HAVE
FOR PREGNANT WOMEN FOR USE FOR
PARENTS -- M. AS WE GET BETTER
DATA WE WOULD LIKE TO MAKE THOSE
MORE IMPACTFUL -- AND WE WOULD
CONTINUE DOWN THAT PATH WE'D
ALSO DO YOU MORE SOCIAL MEDIA --
THE PSAS ARE ONE AVENUE BUT WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THE WAY THAT
YOU'VE GOT INFORMATION IS
DIFFERENT THAN IT USED TO BE.
AND SO THE MORE WE CAN ADVERTISE
ON SOCIAL MEDIA AND USE
DIFFERENT AVENUES SO THAT WE
ACTUALLY GOT PEOPLE WHERE THEY
LEARN THE MOST YEAH AND I SEE IS
A PART OF THOSE THREE MILLION
DOLLARS GOING TO THE C. H. P. TO
THAT BETTER PROTOCOLS TO
IDENTIFY THOSE THAT.
MIGHT BE INTOXICATED I'M
WONDERING IF THROUGH PUBLIC
SERVICE ANNOUNCEMENTS WE CAN
MAKE THE ANALOGY TO DRIVING
UNDER THE INFLUENCE OF ALCOHOL
THE DRIVING UNDER THE INFLUENCE
OF OF MARIJUANA -- COULD GET YOU
ARRESTED IT CAN CAUSE SEVERE
ACCIDENTS AND MORBIDITY AND AND
DEATH -- BECAUSE BELIEVE OR NOT
A LOT OF USE DOESN'T UNDERSTAND
THAT -- UTILIZING -- ONE OR EVEN
OUR CONTACTS IF YOU'RE DRIVING
IN -- INTOXICATED DOES MATTER
WITHIN TOXICANT IS -- YOU CAN BE
CITED AND SO -- I MIGHT JUST
SUGGESTED MAYBE LOOK INTO WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
OFFICE OF TRAFFIC SAFETY AND HER
DH CS TO ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES AS
WELL THAT'S GREAT.
THANK YOU FOR FOR THAT.
CERTIFICATE FOR TEENS TO
INTRODUCE SORT OF SORRY THESE
YEAH HI YES -- AND YOU KNOW ONE
OTHER THING WILL BE ENGAGING IN
THIS FORMATIVE RESEARCH WHICH IS
REALLY GETTING OUT AND TALKING
TO DIFFERENT GROUPS ON
CALIFORNIA TO UNDERSTAND THEIR
ATTITUDES AND BELIEFS AROUND IT
AND FORMING.
OUR OWN MESSAGES AROUND THAT.
AND ALSO JUST TO FOLLOW UP ON
THE LA AS QUESTION ABOUT HOW
THESE ACTIVITIES ACCORDING WITH
OTHER -- SUBSTANCE USE -- DATA
COLLECTION ACTIVITIES AND
PROGRAMS AND WE ABSOLUTELY AGREE
WITH YOU AND WE ARE BUILDING
WHAT WE'RE CALLING THE ECOSYSTEM
OF DATA WHICH IS A HUB THAT
BASICALLY BRINGS IN ALL OF THOSE
DIFFERENT DATA SOURCES SO THAT
WE CAN DO MORE PREDICTIVE
ANALYTICS AND LOOKING.
ACROSS THOSE DATA SETS WE WERE
FORTUNATE TO GET SOME OPIOID USE
REDUCTION MONEY FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WE'RE BUILDING THAT
INTO OUR DATA SETS SORATHER
THAN DUPLICATE WILL USE THESE
DOLLARS TO MAKE SURE THAT WHEN
WE ARE GETTING A DATA SET THAT
WE ARE.
GETTINGTHE DATE OF SAY FROM
MEDICAL RECORD THAT WOULD
INCLUDE OPIOIDS BUT WHEN INCLUDE
CANNABIS WOULD INCLUDE WHATEVER
OTHER KINDS OF THINGS WITH IT SO
WE'RE NOT BUILDING THINGS
MULTIPLE TIMES.
REALLY ARE LOOKING AT BUILDING
HAVING TRULY IN THE END ONE DATA
SAID THE COVERS ALL ACT
SUBSTANCE USE THAT RIGHT SO
EVERYTHING COMES INTO A HUB THE
DATA MAY LIVE SOMEWHERE ELSE BUT
EVERYTHING CAN COME INTO ONE
SYSTEM.
OKAY.
RIGHT REPUBLICAN IT.
I'LL GET INTO THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION A
CALIFORNIA WE ARE PLEASED TO SEE --
SOME INVESTMENT FOR SURVEILLANCE
FOR CANNABIS SIMILAR TO TOBACCO
SURVEILLANCE WE KNOW THAT THAT
INFORMATION HELPS TO INFORM OUR
APPROACHES IN OUR MESSAGING IN
OR OUT REGION INTERVENTIONS.
AND SO WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE
SAME STRUCTURE HAPPENING FOR
CANNABIS AND WE APPLAUD THE
GOVERNOR FOR INCLUDING IT THANK
YOU.
HI ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OKAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
DEPARTMENT STATE HOSPITALS.
SEVEN START OFF WITH ISSUE
NUMBER ONE WHICH IS THE MAY
REVISION ADJUSTMENTS.
THE SETS WERE A NEW DEPARTMENT
WILL GO INTO THE ROUND ROBIN OF
INTRODUCTIONS.
PLEASE INTRODUCE YOURSELVES
FIRST.
GOOD AFTERNOON STEPHANIE CLINTON
AN ACTING DIRECTOR FOR THE
DEPARTMENT STATE HOSPITALS.
AND GOOD AFTERNOON GEORGE
MAYNARD -- MINISTRY TO SERVICES
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR DEPARTMENT
SAY HOSPITALS THANK YOU HELLO
FUNNY PARTICULARLY -- BY IT'S
ANNOYING DIFFERENT FINANCE THANK
YOU ARE AND WHAT YOU KILL IT
BEGAN A REVISION.
THANK YOU I'M ISSUE NUMBER ONE
AND I'LL PROVIDE AN UPDATE ON
THIRTEEN ITEMS ALL TOUCHED ON
THEM BRIEFLY AND PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO ASKING QUESTIONS LIKE.
SO STARTING WITH -- PATIENT
DRIVEN MOVIE ANY AT GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET WE REQUESTED TEN POINT
FIVE MILLION BUDGET YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO ESTABLISH A METHODOLOGY
FOR FUNDING PATIENT DRIVEN
OPERATING COSTS.
AND PROVIDE FUNDING FOR CURRENT
ESTIMATED PATIENT POPULATION AT
MAY REVISION WE'RE REQUESTING TO
JUSTICE MOUNT MY AN ADDITIONAL
FIVE HUNDRED FORTY SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS BASED ON
UPDATED PATIENT CASELOAD -- THE
SECOND.
ISSUE IS MANAGEMENT HAS INTEREST
SHORT POPULATION SERVICES
ADJUSTMENT AT GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
WE HAD REQUESTED AN INCREASE IN
OUR REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY OF
SIX HUNDRED AND SIX THOUSAND TO
REFLECT ESTIMATED REIMBURSEMENT
FROM THE COUNTIES FOR THE CARE
AND TREATMENT OF INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE COMMITTED TO S. AS LPS --
THAT MAY REVISION REQUESTING
ADDITIONAL TWO POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN REIMBURSEMENT
ASSIST REFLECT UPDATED ESTIMATED --
ESTIMATES FOR COLLECTION OF
REIMBURSEMENTS.
AS FOR THE TWO THOUSAND AND
FOURTEEN SOUTH NAPA EARTHQUAKE
WE REPAIRS AMBER REFLECTING ONE
TIME SAVINGS AT ONE POINT ONE
MILLION IN CURRENT YEAR AND SIX
HUNDRED AND EIGHT THOUSAND AND
BUDGET YEAR ASSOCIATED WITH
PROJECT NUMBER.
THREE OF THE NAPA EARTHQUAKE
REPAIR PROJECT -- JUST AS A KIND
OF A LITTLE BIT BACK ON THAT
WHEN WE RECEIVE GRANT FUNDING --
TO MAKE REPAIRS AND NAPPING
CONDUCT IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE
TEAM A GRANT OF THE WORK WAS
BEGUN ACROSS THREE PROJECTS ON
THE THIRD PROJECT WAS PRIMARY
COSMETIC REPAIRS -- PLASTER AND
PAINT REPAIRS AND DUE TO
DIFFICULTY AND HIRING IN THE
REGION AFTER THE OUTLETS TUBS
FIRES AND I'M AS WELL AS I'M
CHALLENGES OF SWING SPACE OUR
FACILITIES.
AND RECENT STORMS I'M WHERE
WE'VE HAD SOME LEAKY ROOFS THAT
HAVE.
DAMAGE SOME OF THE REPAIRS THAT
WE ALREADY MADE UNDER THIS
pMAKES I'M BETTER SENSE FOR US TO
GO AHEAD AND DISCONTINUE THIS
PROJECT AT THIS TIME AND THEN.
I RE EVALUATED AS PART OF OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE MASTER PLANNING
PROCESS.
AND THE DISCONTINUATION DOT
PROJECT WILL NOT IMPACT PROJECTS
WENT INTO.
AS FOR THE ENHANCE TREATMENT
PROGRAM STAFFING WE'VE BEEN
AUTHORIZED UNDER AB THIRTEEN
FORTY TWO PILOT ENHANCE
TREATMENT UNITS TO TREAT
PATIENTS ARE AT THE HIGHEST RISK
OF VIOLENCE.
AND WE RECEIVE FUNDING IN PRIOR
YEARS FOR THE CONSTRUCTION AND
STAFFING FOR FOUR UNITS A TOTAL
OF FORTY NINE BEDS ACROSS TWO OF
OUR FACILITIES.
I GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WE HAD
ANTICIPATED AT ONE POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS AND THE SAVINGS
IN -- BUDGET YEAR FOR ESTIMATED
DELAYS OF OUR A PATTON UNIT.
AND MAY REVISION UPDATES THE
SAVINGS BY AN ADDITIONAL TWO
POINT SIX MILLION CURRENT YEAR
AND FIVE HUNDRED SEVENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND AND BUDGET YEAR AND THE
STARS IS TO REFLECT THE UPDATED
CONSTRUCTION TIME MIGHT FOR ALL
FOUR UNITS.
ON THEIR BEEN DELAYS TO VARIOUS
CHALLENGES -- BUT PRIMARILY
THEY'RE DRIVEN BY EXISTING SITE
CONDITIONS THAT WERE
ENCOUNTERING WHEN THEY
CONSTRUCTION STARTS AND THE
MITIGATING STEPS THAT WE NEED TO
TAKE.
AND THIS ALSO INCLUDED A
PROPOSAL TO RE DIRECT A HUNDRED
AND THIRTY NINE THOUSAND INTO
SAVINGS TO ADDRESS CRITICAL
NEEDS FOR THE PATENT ENHANCE
TREATMENT PROGRAM UNIT.
THAT WERE NOT IDENTIFIED
ORIGINALLY AS PART OF THE
CONSTRUCTION PROJECT THIS
INCLUDES COURTYARD IMPROVEMENTS
AND THE FENCE SECURITY UPGRADES
CONVERTING AN EXISTING SHOWER
ROOM TO HOUSE CAN CLAP
HOUSEKEEPING CLOSET AND
CONVERSION OF SOME ROOMS TO SOME
CLINICAL TREATMENT SPACE AND
STAFF OFFICES.
THE NEXT ITEM IS THE
METROPOLITAN INCREASE SECURE BUT
PACKED CAPACITY PROJECT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WE HAD
REQUESTED A HUNDRED THIRTY
POSITIONS AND TWENTY POINT ONE
MILLION ON GOING.
FOR THE STAFFING NEEDED FOR
UNITS FOR TWELVE AND FOUR
FOURTEEN AS PART OF THIS PROJECT
WE RECEIVED FUNDING AND PRIOR
BUDGET AXE FOR THE FIRST THREE
UNITS AND SO WHEN ALL FIVE
MINUTES WOULD ARE ACTIVATED
IT'LL PROVIDE TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SIX ADDITIONAL BEDS FOR
THE TREATMENT OF FORENSIC.
PATIENTS IN OUR HOSPITALS
PARTICULARLY -- THIS IS KEEN FOR
US I MEAN MEETING THE ON GOING
DEMAND FOR INCOMPETENT TO STAND
TRIAL PATIENTS -- BEING REFERRED
TO US.
AS OF THE MAY REVISION THE
SAVINGS -- THAT WE IT IS BEING
ADJUSTED FOR CURRENT YEAR OF
THREE POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
AND TWENTY TWO POINT FIVE
POSITIONS BUDGET YOU MERE IS
THREE MILLION FIFTY FIVE
THOUSAND AND TWENTY POINT ONE
POSITIONS.
AND THOSE ARE -- BUDGET YEAR AND
CURRENT YEAR BUDGET YOUR
ADJUSTMENTS ARE DUE TO DELAY OF
TWO MONTHS I'M IN THE COMPLETION
OF THE CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS.
THAT'S THAT WERE YOU
ANTICIPATING -- THE PUSH OUT OF
ALL OF THE ACTIVATION OF THE
FOLLOWING UNITS AND THEN THE
TWENTY AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE
WHERE IF I SCORED A SAVINGS OF
NINETEEN MILLION EIGHT HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY EIGHT POINT FIVE
POSITIONS.
AND THIS IS JUST CORRECTING AN
ERROR IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET --
FOR THE NEXT ITEM IS TELL THE
PSYCHIATRY RESOURCES THE MAY
REVISION THIS IS A NEW ITEM IN
MAY REVISION -- FOR ELEVEN
POSITIONS AND TWO POINT TWO
MILLION AND BUDGET YEAR TWENTY
ONE POSITIONS AND THREE POINT
SEVEN MILLION IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND THREE MILLION SEVENTY
ONE THOUSAND ON GOING.
AND THIS IS TO INCREASE THE USE
OF TELL US LIKE HIGH TREE TO
PROVIDE PSYCHIATRIC TREATMENT
REMOTELY TO OUR PATIENTS IDEAS
H. COALINGA ATASCADERO NAPA
WHERE WE HAVE THE GREATEST
CHALLENGES IN RECRUITING
PSYCHIATRISTS AND THIS HAS THREE
COMPOUND PRIMARY COMPONENTS THIS
PROPOSAL WHICH INCLUDES A SENIOR
PSYCHIATRIST SUPERVISOR.
EIGHTEEN SITE TAX TO SERVICE
TELL PSYCHIATRY COORDINATORS ON
THE RECEIVING END WHERE THE
PATIENTS ARE AND THEN TO
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATE
POSITIONS AND FUNDING FOR THE IT
EQUIPMENT AND OFFICE SUPPLIES --
THERE ARE -- TWO ADJUSTMENTS FOR
CONDITIONAL RELEASE PROGRAMS
ALSO INCLUDED THE FIRST ONE IS
FOR OUR CONDITIONAL RELEASE
PROGRAM FOR AND SEXUALLY VIOLENT
PREDATORS.
A GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WE HAD --
IDENTIFIED AN INCREASE OF SEVEN
HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT THOUSAND
CURRENT YEAR TWO MILLION SIXTY
EIGHT THOUSAND BUDGET YEAR ON ON
GOING AND THIS WAS BASED ON AN
ANTICIPATED CASELOAD -- INCREASE
IN THE CONDITIONAL RELEASE
PROGRAM.
AS A MAY REVISION WE'RE REDUCING
THAT REQUEST BY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR EACH YEAR AND THIS
IS REFLECTED UPDATED BECAUSE
CASELOAD OF EIGHTEEN PATIENTS IN
CONRAD BY THE END OF CURRENT
YEAR AN ADDITIONAL THREE SB PEAS.
TO BE RELEASED IN BUDGET YEAR
FOR A TOTAL OF TWENTY ONE
SEXUALLY VIOLENT PREDATOR
CLIENTS IN THE CONRAD BY JUNE
THIRTIETH.
OF TWENTY NINETEEN ACTUALLY
THAT'S TWENTY TWENTY AND THEN --
THE CONDITIONAL RELEASE PROGRAM --
WE HAVE THE CONTINUUM OF CARE
FOR THE STEP DOWN TRANSITION
PROGRAM.
THIS IS A MAY REVISION PROPOSAL
APPOINT A FIVE POINT. SIX FIVE
MILLION SIX HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT
THOUSAND BUDGET YEAR ELEVEN
MILLION FIVE HUNDRED AND FIVE
HUNDRED FORTY FIVE THOUSAND ON
GOING.
AN ASSIST A CONTRACT FOR SEVENTY
EIGHT BED BENDER OPERATED
COMMUNITY STEP DOWN PROGRAM AND
THIS IS TO SERVE THEM DO A
MENTALLY DISORDERED OFFENDERS
AND NOT GUILTY BY REASON OF
INSANITY PATIENTS WERE PREPARING
FOR CONDITIONAL RELEASE FROM THE
STATE HOSPITALS AND INTO A
COMMUNITY.
PROGRAM WITHIN EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY FOUR MONTHS THIS IS SEEMS
THAT THERE WILL BE START ACT AT
START UP ACTIVITIES WITH THE
MENTOR OF SEVEN TO NINE MONTHS
INCLUDING SOME PHYSICAL SPACE
MODIFICATIONS TO ENSURE THE
SAFETY AND SECURITY OF THE
PATIENTS THIS IS ABOUT. ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION OF THE
FUNDING AND THEN ASSUMES
ACTIVATIONS ABOUT STARTING IN
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN FEBRUARY AND
APRIL OF TWENTY TWENTY AND WE
ANTICIPATE ABOUT FOUR MONTHS TO
FULLY FILL THE BEDS.
THEY ALSO INCLUDES EXPANDING OUR
EXISTING CONTRACT WITH SOMEWHERE
HEALTH AND REHABILITATION CENTER
BY FOUR BEDS TO A TOTAL OF
TWENTY FOUR BEDS AND THIS
EXISTING PROGRAM PROVIDE
SERVICES FOR IN GI PATIENTS WHO
ARE IMMINENTLY READY FOR
TRANSITION TO CONRAD.
OR ENJOY CLIENTS ARE CURRENTLY
IN CONRAD AND THAT MAY REQUIRE
TREATMENT IN A HIGHER LEVEL OF
CARE ON A TEMPORARY BASIS RATHER
THAN BEING RETURNED TO THE STATE
HOSPITAL. TO THE GOAL OF THESE
PROGRAMS IS -- TO HELPED
PATIENTS PREPARE FOR SUCCESSFUL
TRANSITION INTO THE COMMUNITY.
AND IT ALSO ALLOWS US TO BACK
FILL OUR STATE HOSPITAL BEDS
ONCE THE TRANSITION IN THIS NEW
PROGRAM WITH -- INDIVIDUALS ARE
CURRENTLY UNDER WAY LAST.
AND THEN WE HAVE -- TO ITEMS FOR
THE JOB IS COMPETENCY TREATMENT
PROGRAM THE FIRST ONE IS
EXISTING PROGRAM COSTS DECREASES
AND WE IDENTIFIED SAVINGS FOR
EXISTING PROGRAMS OF KERR AND
CURRENT EUROPE TURNED FIFTY
THREE THOUSAND GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
AND AN ADDITIONAL ONE MILLION
NINETY THREE AND BUDGET YEAR.
AND ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION ON
GOING TO SUPPORT COST INCREASES
TO THE EXISTING PROGRAMS.
AT MAY REVISION WE AND
INCREASING THE CURRENT YOUR
SAVINGS BY SEVEN HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND REDUCING
THE BUDGET YOU'RE AN ONGOING
REQUEST BY HUNDRED AND SIXTY
EIGHT THOUSAND AND THIS IS DUE
TO UPDATED ACTIVATION TIME LINES
AND CHANGES IN PROGRAM CAPACITY.
OF FOUR FIVE OF OUR PROGRAMS AT
CINEMA MENDOCINO MONTEREY SAN
JOAQUIN STANISLAUS.
AND THEN WE ARE HAVE AN
ADJUSTMENT TO THE NEW PROGRAMS
AS WELL -- WE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
WE HAD PROPOSED TEN POINT NINE
MILLION IN BUDGET YEAR AND
ELEVEN POINT AND FOUR MILLION ON
GOING FOR ACTIVATION OF FIVE NEW
GBC T. PROGRAMS TOTALING SEVENTY
FOUR DISTAL BEDS.
AT MAY REVISION WE REDUCE THIS
BY FIVE MILLION SEVEN HUNDRED
TWENTY THOUSAND IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND BY NINE THOUSAND I'M
GOING AND THIS IS BASED ON THE
CURRENT OF DISCUSSIONS IN
CONTRACT NEGOTIATIONS
ANTICIPATED ACTIVATION TIME
LINES FOR THOSE PROGRAMS.
THAT IS ALL THE ODD THESE JEWS
IN MIND.
OKAY ALEJO COMMENTS FINANCE.
QUESTION COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
NOW FIVE PUBLIC COMMENT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS CONNIE DELGADO ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA BE THAT COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION AND THEY ARE IN
SUPPORT.
OF INCREASING REIMBURSEMENT AND
FORTY SO THAT THE STATE
HOSPITALS CAN CONTINUE TO ACCEPT
PATIENTS THAT ARE IN.
NEED OF THIS HIGH LEVEL OF
INTENSIVE CARE FOR COUNTIES
ADDITIONALLY CB HDA IS IN
SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL TO USE
TELL US LIKE HIGH TREE WITHIN
THE STATE HOSPITAL SYSTEM.
THE USAGE OF TELL US LIKE HIGH
TREE AS AN ALTERNATIVE TO
PROVIDING IN PERSON PSYCHIATRIC
TREATMENT WITH A SHORTAGE OF
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS IN
CALIFORNIA IS CRITICAL. TO
CONTINUE THE TRIP TO TREAT
INDIVIDUALS AND PRESCRIBE THE
APPROPRIATE MEDICATIONS WE ARE
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE
HOSPITALS TO CONTRACT WITH
SEVENTY EIGHT BED FACILITY. FOR
STEP DOWN PROGRAM THROUGH THE
CONDITIONAL RELEASE PROGRAM THIS
WILL IMPROVE THE CONTINUITY OF
CARE AND ALLOW FOR EFFECTIVE
TRANSITION FOR INDIVIDUALS INTO
THE COMMUNITY.
OKAY THANK YOU.
RIGHT NOW OFFICIALLY THAT SAID I
MEAN JUST.
AGAIN I KNOW WE'VE HEARD.
THIS ITEM MORE GLOBAL A BUT I
MEAN THE EACH PATIENT'S HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS CORRECT
I MEAN OBVIOUSLY THESE ARE.
MANY OF THEM ARE YOU KNOW FAIRLY
SEVERE IS POINTED OUT
[inaudible]
SO.
KEEP IN MIND HER.
EIGHT ALRIGHT SO LET'S --
NOTHING ELSE THIS MOVE ONTO AS A
WE'RE GONNA HOLD SIDE OF OPEN --
ISSUE NUMBER TWO TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENT INTERAGENCY AGREEMENT
WITH THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY.
ALSO INCLUDED IN THIS REQUEST
SAYS -- TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENT --
FOR THE TRANSFER OF FUNDS FROM
THE THE STATE HOSPITAL TO THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY.
HISTORICALLY THE ONE POSITION
UNDER THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY HAS BEEN FUNDED
THROUGH THE THE STATE HOSPITAL
BUDGET.
AND WHAT THIS WOULD DO IS
BASICALLY -- ALIGNED A DEFINING
SOURCE WITH THE F. POSITION
AUTHORITY UNDER THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY.
THANK.
YOU HELLO COMMENTS QUESTION
MEMBERS IN WHAT POSITION IS THE
SAME SHANDIZ ASSISTANT SECRETARY.
CORRECT.
THIS IS A SECRETARY.
FOR UNDER THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES OKAY JUST TOUCH ON A
WITH THE SUB TITLE OR
DESCRIPTION OF WHAT THIS
ASSISTANT SECRETARIES ASSIGNED
TO DO.
SO -- THEY THEY BASICALLY A
PROVIDE OVERSIGHT OF THE THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS AND ALSO --
REVIEW IT AND PARTICIPATE IN THE
BUDGET PROCESS AND AS WELL AS A
POLICIES FORMULATIONS AND
WHATNOT OKAY ALL RIGHT THAT'S
OKAY I JUST CURIOUS AS TO
EXACTLY WHICH ASSISTANT
SECRETARY POSITION IS THAT I
REALIZE THAT WE'RE JUST LINING
THE FUNDS WHICH ONE IT IS SO.
THAT SERVE A GENERIC DESCRIPTION
ASSISTANT SECRETARY.
WAS WONDER THERE'S A WHICH
THERE'S A SPECIFIC THIS IS A
SECRETARY POSITION THAT THIS WAS.
FUNDED THE OTHER WAY BUT ALL
RIGHT ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS.
OKAY SEEING NONE ALL RIGHT WILL
HOLD THIS ITEM OPENED.
ALL RIGHT SHOULD NUMBER THREE
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS CALIFORNIA
LOTTERY FUND.
ON THE STATE LOTTERY -- THE
REVENUE GENERAL USE IS DISPERSED
TO THE THE PUBLIC ENTITIES FOR
EDUCATIONAL PURPOSES AND THIS IS
ALSO A TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENT --
AND STONE ANNUALLY -- AND THE
STATE HOSPITAL WAS.
RECEIVING A AN INCREASE OF SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
THEY'LL ANY COMMENTS OKAY A
QUESTION COMMITTEE MEMBERS SEC
PUBLIC COMMENTS.
OKAY ALL RIGHT THANK YOU. FOR
MOVE ON THE WHOLE SIDE OF OPEN
LAND ISSUE NUMBER -- FOUR AND
HAS BEEN ENHANCED TREATMENT UNIT
CITYWIDE.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING -- CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE --
ISSUE FOR IS OUR C. WAITING
HANDS TREATMENT PROGRAM THIS IS
A CAPITAL OUTLAY SIDE OF THE
PROGRAMS THAT -- DIRECTOR
CLINTON AND MENTIONED EARLIER
WHERE WE HAVE HAD SOME DELAYS IN
CONSTRUCTION WHICH NETTED A NET
RESULT IN SAVINGS IN PERSONNEL
COSTS.
HOWEVER -- THIS PARTICULAR
REQUEST IS FOR TWO POINT THREE
SEVEN MILLION FOUR INCREASED
COSTS FOR THE CONSTRUCTION PHASE
OF THE STATE WHEN HANDS
TREATMENT PROGRAM --
CONSTRUCTION IS CURRENTLY UNDER
WAY TO ATASCADERO AND IS ABOUT
25230% COMPLETE SO THE MAJORITY
OF THIS COST IS RELATED TO THE
PATENT STATE PROBABLY.
HOSPITAL PROJECT WHICH WILL
INCLUDE A TEN BED UNIT FOR
FEMALES AT THE PATENT SO WERE
AGAIN SEEKING TWO POINT THREE
SEVEN MILLION IN MAY REVISED.
THANK YOU EL AL COMMENTS FINANCE.
NO IF ANY MEMBER FINANCE HERE
INTRODUCE YOURSELF.
READY CATS THE PART OF FINANCE
CAP OUT OKAY THANK YOU.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THE PUBLIC
COMMENT SEEING NONE OKAY SO --
WE WILL HOLD THE SIDE OF OPEN --
AND THEN I GUESS WE'RE MOVING ON
TO DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES AND
STATE HOSPITALS -- SO WE HAVE
ISSUE NUMBER ONE RELOCATION OF
THE CLIFFORD L. ALLENBY BUILDING.
AND SOMEONE ELSE UP HERE YES
JUST CHECKING OUR DDS PARTNERS
JOINING US AS WELL AS SO.
MUCH COME UP AND INTRODUCE
YOURSELF FOR THE RECORD THAT
WILL PRESENT THIS ITEM.
AND THIS WERE WAITING FOR HI
AMERICAN.
OKAY.
OKAY ALL RIGHT ARE SERGEANTS ARE
GOOD ABOUT.
THESE I'M PAT AMERICAN DANTE I'M
THE ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR DDS
EXCELLENT ALL RIGHT WHAT'S GOING
PERCENT.
SO THANK YOU SO THIS PARTICULAR
ISSUE IS THE PHASE -- ONE THE
RELOCATION -- OF HEALTH HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY DEPARTMENT OF
ELEMENTAL SERVICES AND PART IN
THE STATE HOSPITALS TO THE
CLIFFORD ALLEN THE FAILING --
THIS B. C. P. -- INCLUDES THE
INITIAL -- COSTS FOR THIS FISCAL
YEAR -- APPROACH TO BUDGET YOUR
NINETEEN TWENTY EIGHT EIGHT
POINT THREE MILLION AND OF THE A
TWENTY THREE MILLION FOUR POINT
NINE MILLION IS THE D. S. H.
FUNDED PORTION. THREE POINT FOUR
MILLION AS THE DDS FUNDED
PORTION FOR A TOTAL OF THE EIGHT
POINT THREE MILLION -- THIS
PHASE ONE OF THE PROJECT
INCLUDES INITIAL FUNDING FOR
PURCHASES AND THEIR
CORRESPONDING ON GOING COSTA
RICA RELOCATE STAFF.
AND OPERATIONS TO THE BUILDING --
THIS PARTICULAR BUILDING IS IS
FINED BE VERY ENERGY EFFICIENT
SO WE HAVE A NUMBER OF NEW
SYSTEMS TO BE PLACED -- THAT
WILL BOTH BE ENERGY EFFICIENT
AND PROVIDE -- SOME ECONOMY OF
SCALE.
IT'S ESTIMATED THAT BY --
COMBINING MANY OF OUR SERVICES
IN OUR EQUIPMENT SERVICES WE
INTEND TO REDUCE ENERGY USAGE BY
APPROXIMATELY 75% IN THE
BUILDING AND MEET THE GOVERNOR'S
REQUIREMENTS -- FOR A A GREEN
BUILDING -- THIS ALSO INCLUDES
THE FUNDING FOR THE PHYSICAL
WORLD RELOCATION OF THOSE
CONTENTS IN THE BATES AND
BUILDING THAT WILL BE GOING OVER.
AND THE REQUIRED REMOVAL OF
SURPLUS ITEMS LIKE HIKING
TELECOMMUNICATIONS EQUIPMENT
PREPARING THE BASIN BUILDING FOR
TGS TO TAKE TO THE NEXT PHASE OF
RENOVATION.
OPEN ANY QUESTIONS [inaudible]
COMES MILLION.
SENATE PARTICULARLY -- WE JUST
HAVE A REALLY MINOR POINT ABOUT
THE PROVISIONAL BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD ACCOMPANY
THIS PROPOSAL FOR BOTH THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES.
ESSENTIALLY THE THE PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE EXEMPTS BOTH
DEPARTMENTS FROM HAVING TO WORK
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES -- FOR THE ARCHIVING
SCANNING AND DESTRUCTION OF MANY
OF THE DOCUMENTS BECAUSE DH CS --
SORRY DDS WOULD COST ABOUT TWICE
WHAT IT WOULD COST TO TO WORK
WITH A THIRD PARTY VENDOR BUT
THE PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE ALSO
EXAMS THE DEPARTMENTS FROM THE
ENTIRE PUBLIC CONTRACT CODE.
SO OUR RECOMMENDATION WOULD BE
WE UNDERSTAND WHY THEY DON'T
WANT TO WORK WITH DO YES BECAUSE
OF THE COST BUT WE DON'T THINK
THEY NEED TO BE EXEMPT FROM
OTHER PUBLIC CONTRACTING RULES.
OKAY.
OKAY YES FINANCE MAYBE CAN
COMMENT ON THAT.
TOO EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE TWENTY
SEVEN MILLION RECORDS A AND AND
ROUGHLY -- ONE AND A HALF YEARS
TO ACCOMPLISH ALL THIS AND THE
BEFORE THE MOVIE AND AND IT IS
OUR GOAL BASICALLY IS TO ACHIEVE
A TIMELY PROCESS AND AS WELL AS
IT SHOULD THE COST SAVINGS.
AND WERE HAPPY TO TO FINE TUNE
THE LANGUAGE WITH ALIENS ALL
RIGHT GOOD SO WE CAN NARROW THE
LANGUAGE THERE OKAY.
QUESTION COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
PUBLIC COMMENT.
SUCH AS A CURIOSITY -- CLIFFORD
L. ALLENBY WHOSE CLIFFORD LA
COUNTY.
CLIFFORD LA COUNTY IS A FORMER --
DIRECTOR OF DEPARTMENT STATE
HOSPITALS ALSO FORMER DIRECTOR I
BELIEVE A D. G. S. -- HIGH LEVEL --
EXECUTIVE IN PART IN FINANCE --
A LONG THE LIFE CIVIL SERVANT --
THERE WAS A ACTUALLY A
DEDICATION TO HIM A COUPLE OF
YEARS AGO UPON HIS HIS --
PASSING UNTIMELY PASSING AFTER I
THINK ABOUT.
PROBABLY FIFTY YEARS OR SO IN
PUBLIC SERVICE AND SO WE'RE
WE'RE QUITE HONORED TO HAVE I
HAVE THE BUILDING -- NAMED AFTER
HOURS MR ALLENBY.
EXCELLENT WELL I THOUGHT WE
SHOULD JUST RECALL WHO -- THAT
IS AN ESTIMATE THE BUILDINGS IN
MY DISTRICT SO I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT
PEOPLE ARE HONORING ITSELF THANK
YOU THANKS VERY MUCH.
OKAY -- SO I GUESS THEIR NEXT
ITEM IS -- MOVING ON TO SO IF
YOU FINISH WITH APARTMENTS STATE
HOUSE WELL THESE THE PART OF
THIS TOO OKAY WE HAVE EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES THIRTY FAR
PUBLIC HEALTH PHARMACY HOSPITALS
BERMAN SOCIAL SERVICES DISASTER
PREPAREDNESS RESPONSE RECOVERY.
SO HAVE A ALL RIGHT.
I SOUNDS LIKE WE ALIVE
INTRODUCTIONS TO MAKE FIRST OF
OUR PEOPLE HAVE THE TABLE HERE.
RIGHT WHO ELSE IS THE A LOT.
ANYONE ELSE UP HERE [inaudible]
OKAY.
OFFICE I'M LET'S JUST DO THE
WHOLE ROUND ROBIN SO IT IS
AROUND THE TABLE AND THEN.
THE RESPONSE FOR THE PRESENT SO
WE'LL START WITH THE AGENCIES.
HOW THEY'RE ACTING DIRECTOR
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES?
QUICK JOHNSON CHIEF SAYS MEDICAL
SERVICES DIVISION FOR EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES AUTHORITY.
THE CLINTON AN ACTING DIRECTOR
DEPARTMENT STATE HOSPITALS HE
OVER TAYLOR DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
THE EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS
OFFICE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
THANK YOU LA A A SONY PEDICLE
LEO.
GINNY BALLOT ILIO FINANCE OTHER
WORDS FINANCE.
IN DEPARTMENT FINANCE THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT SO -- WHICH ONES
[inaudible]
BEGIN.
START TO GET.
WELL I GUESS WE'LL START WILL GO
TO THE SAN SO THIS PROPOSAL IS
PART OF THE ADMINISTRATORS
LARGER DISASTER PREPAREDNESS AND
RECOVERY -- A REVISION PACKAGE
SO THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH IS REQUESTING.
A NINE HUNDRED AND FIFTY NINE
THOUSAND FOR SIX PERMANENT
POSITIONS TO SUPPORT HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES AND MASS CARE
SHELTERS EMERGENCY AND DISASTER
PREPAREDNESS RESPONSE AND
RECOVERY EFFORTS.
THE ART CENTER FOR HEALTH CARE
QUALITY IS REQUESTING -- FOUR
HUNDRED THIRTY ONE THOUSAND FROM
GENERAL FUND AND THREE HUNDRED
NINETY THOUSAND FROM THE
LICENSING AND CERTIFICATION FUND.
FOR FIVE POSITIONS TO ASSIST
FACILITIES TO DEVELOP PLANS TO
MAKE GOVERNMENTAL REQUIREMENTS
FOR EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS. TO
PROVIDE TWENTY FOUR SEVEN THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE
COMMUNICATIONS RESPONSE.
AND ALSO TO ASSIST WITH
INFECTION CONTROL EFFORTS.
IN MASS CARE SHELTERS AND
FACILITIES DURING EMERGENCIES.
AND THEN THE EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS OFFICE IS ASKING
FOR A HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT
THOUSAND IN GENERAL FUND FOR ONE
POSITION FOR ADDITIONAL -- GILLS --
GEOGRAPHIC INFORMATION
SPECIALIST TO D. G. I. S.
MAPPING.
OF HEALTH CARE FACILITIES
SHELTERS I AM AND WHERE WE ARE --
WHERE POPULATIONS ARE MOVING AND
WE ALSO MONITOR LIKE FIRES AND
SPOKE FEDERAL SO WE CAN MONITOR
WHERE PEOPLE ARE GOING? FOR THE
D. S. H. PORTION -- WE ARE
REQUESTING SIX POSITIONS AND
NINE HUNDRED NINETY SIX THOUSAND
FISCAL YEAR NINETEEN TWENTY AND
EIGHT HUNDRED AND TWENTY SIX
THOUSANDS ON GOING.
AND THIS IS A SUPPORTER NEED TO
STRENGTHEN OUR EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS AND RON RESPONSE US
EFFORTS.
AND THIS IS THE RESULT OF
LESSONS LEARNED THAT A FROM OUR
EXPERIENCES WITH ALICE TUBS FIRE --
OUT AND NAPA STATE HOSPITAL AND
THIS IT IS TO ADDRESS -- SOME
CHALLENGES THAT WE IDENTIFIED AS
WE REVISITED AND OUR LESSONS
LEARNED SO WILL PROVIDE FUNDING
FOR EMERGENCY AND AGENCY
NOTIFICATION SYSTEMS TEMPORARY
MOBILE DISASTER OPERATIONAL
FACILITIES FOR THE HOSPITAL
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS CENTERS.
INCREASE ACCESS TO SATELLITE
EMERGENCY COMMUNICATIONS AN
INCREASE INTEGRATE EXCUSE ME
CREATE INTEGRATED COMPREHENSIVE
EFFECTIVE BUSINESS CONTINUITY
PLANS TRAINING EXERCISES AND
THEN DESIGNATE SPECIFIC
PERSONNEL TO MANAGE THE
COMPLIANCE WITH.
REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS FOR
HOSPITAL EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS
ACTIVITIES COORDINATOR RESPONSE
MITIGATION PATIENT MOVEMENT AND
RECOVERY IN THE BED OF AN ACTUAL
EMERGENCY.
YES FOR THE EMS AUTHORITIES --
PORTION NMINEES FOR STATE THAT
THIS PROPOSAL IS ALSO PART OF
THE MINISTRY THE MINISTRY TO
FILE LARGER DISASTER
PREPAREDNESS RESPONSE AND
RECOVERY MAYBE VISION PACKAGE.
SO THE PROPOSAL UNDER
CONSIDERATION WILL PROVIDE THE
EMUS AUTHORITY TO POSITIONS AND
NINE HUNDRED SEVENTY NINE
THOUSAND IN GENERAL FUND IN
TWENTY NINETEEN AND TWENTY AND
THREE HUNDRED THREE THOUSAND
GENERAL FUND IN. TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND ON GOING.
ANNUALLY THERE AFTER FOR
INCREASED DISASTER MEDICAL
SERVICES INCLUDING COORDINATION
OF MOBILE MEDICAL ASSETS AND
MEDICAL VOLUNTEERS DURING
EMERGENCY RESPONSE EFFORTS.
SOURCES INCLUDE ONE TIME FINDING
OF SEVEN TWENTY THREE THOUSAND
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY NINETEEN
AND TWENTY WITH THE PURCHASE OF
REPLACEMENT OF EQUIPMENT IN
PREPARATION FOR DISASTER
RESPONSE.
AN FIFTY FOUR THOUSAND GENERAL
FUND ON GOING FOR EQUIPMENT
MAINTENANCE.
THE REQUESTED TO POSITIONS AND
ONGOING FUNDING WILL SUPPORT
PREPAREDNESS RESPONSE AND
RECOVERY MEDICAL SERVICES
OPERATIONS.
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO THE
FOLLOWING FOR DAY TO DAY
ACTIVITIES. TO DEVELOP A CONDUCT
TRAINING AND EXERCISES FOR
MEDICAL TEAM MEMBERS. TO SUPPORT
CASH INVENTORY MANAGEMENT
INCLUDING INCLUDING THE
MAINTENANCE AND RESUPPLY. FOR
ONGOING COLLABORATION WITH
MEDICAL HELP PARTNERS FOR
PLANNING AND INTEGRATION. TO
CONTINUE THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSISTANT TEAM PROGRAM
DEVELOPMENT AND IMPROVEMENTS TO
RECRUITMENT AND DEPLOYMENT
PROCESS SEES. FOR RESPONSE
ACTIVITIES.
TECHNICAL STAFF TO DEPLOY IN
SUPPORT TREATMENT SITES AND
MOBILE MEDICAL SHELTERS BOOTS ON
THE GROUND.
PROVIDE JUST IN TIME TRAINING TO
DEPLOYED MEDICAL TEAMS.
ON SITE COMMUNICATIONS AND
INFORMATION SHARING.
AND PROVIDE THAT PHIL LIAISON
PERFORMING SITE ASSESSMENTS AND
RESOURCE NEEDS.
THE ONE TIME TWENTY BE REQUEST
WILL BE USED FOR THE FOLLOWING.
REPLACEMENT OF OUTDATED BIO
MEDICAL EQUIPMENT.
IT IS A PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT FOR MEDICAL DEPLOYMENT
TEAMS AND CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE SUCH AS LIGHTING
AND SECURITY FOR THE BASE OF
OPERATIONS. TO PURCHASE VEHICLES
TO ENHANCE FLEET CAPABILITIES.
AND THE PURCHASE OF INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY AND COMMUNICATION
EQUIPMENT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBER PALLY
ABOUT THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES THE REQUESTED WE HAVE
IN THE BUDGET IS ROUGHLY TWO
POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS -- TO
ADD TWENTY STAFF TOWARD DISASTER
SERVICES BUREAU.
SINCE ABOUT TWENTY FIFTEEN THE
NATURE OF DISASTER IN CALIFORNIA
PARTICULARLY FIRES OUSTER HAS
REALLY CHANGED -- WE'RE SEEING
EACH YEAR ON PRESIDENTE TOPPING
THE LAST YEAR'S UNPRECEDENTED --
FIRES THAT HAVE BEEN OCCURRING
FIRES FLOODS MUD SLIDES -- OFTEN
NOW OCCURRING SIMULTANEOUSLY IN
TWO AREAS OF THE STATE AT THE
SAME TIME -- EACH ONE OF THOSE
HAS GIVEN US THE OPPORTUNITY TO
LEARN HOW WE CAN DO THINGS
BETTER AND IN EACH AND EVERYONE
THERE THERE HAVE BEEN LOTS OF
OPPORTUNITIES FOR US TO LEARN
HOW TO BETTER SERVE THE PUBLIC.
WHEN TEY ARE FLEEING FOR THEIR
LIVES DURING AN EMERGENCY WE
HAVE TO BUT WE ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE STATE'S EMERGENCY PLAN
FOR PROVIDING FOR MASS CARE AND
SHELTER SO THAT MEANS PARTNERING
WITH THE RED CROSS?
IMPORTANTLY IT MEANS PARTNERING
WITH COUNTIES BECAUSE COUNTIES
ARE ACTUALLY THE FIRST
RESPONDERS THEY'RE THE ONES ON
THE GROUND ASKING FOR HELP IN
LOOKING FOR US TO COME IN.
AN IMPORTANT LESSON THAT WE
LEARNED DURING ALL OF THESE IS
THE IS THAN NEED ABSOLUTE
CRITICAL NEED TO ESTABLISH
RELATIONSHIPS DO DRILLS AND
EXERCISES.
REGULAR MEETINGS AND PLANNING
WITH THOSE LOCAL RESPONDERS AND
OTHER AND OTHER RESPOND HERS AND
DEVELOP THOSE RELATIONSHIPS LONG
AHEAD OF A FIRE -- DURING SOME
OF THE RECENT FIRES THE VENTRO
FIRE THE NAPA AND SONOMA FIRES
IN PARTICULAR AND ALSO IN BUTTE
COUNTY WE HAVE THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS PEOPLE KNEW WHO
ARE DISASTER SERVICES MANAGERS
WERE.
VAIN KNEW WHO PEOPLE WERE ON THE
GROUND EVERYBODY HAD EACH OTHER
CELL PHONE NUMBERS AND THEY KNEW
THAT OUR STAFF WERE THERE TO
SUPPORT THEM IN WHATEVER THEIR
REQUESTS WERE.
THEY HAD CONFIDENCE THAT THEY
WERE GOING TO BE ABLE TO TO
PROVIDE THAT ROLE BUT AS WE SAW
THESE TO THESE CONFLAGRATIONS
HAPPENING AT SUCH A LARGE LEVEL
AND AT THE SAME TIME.
OUR STAFF IS ABSOLUTELY PULLED
IN MULTIPLE DIRECTIONS -- OUR
STOP PUT IN OVER THREE HUNDRED
OF HOURS OF OVERTIME IN A SINGLE
MONTH -- IT WAS IT'S A TWENTY
FOUR SEVEN OPERATION AND ONE
CAN'T BE IN TWO PLACES AT THE
SAME TIME SO WE REALLY NEED TO
CREATE.
THOSE WERE PLANNING AND
PREPAREDNESS WHICH ACTUALLY
HELPS WHEN THE DISASTER IS
ACTUALLY OCCURRING.
THE THE NEED TO HAVE MULTIPLE
PEOPLE ON SITE ALL OF OUR STAFF
NOT ONLY STATE THAT IS MANY OF
THE STAFF TO FROM FROM THE OTHER
DEPARTMENTS.
WE HAVE TO STAFF THE STATE
OPERATIONS CENTER TWENTY FOUR
HOURS SEVEN DAYS A WEEK WE STAFF
OUR OWN DEPARTMENT OPERATIONS
CENTER.
THE RED CROSS AND COUNTIES THE
THREE TYPES OF SHELTERS ARE
OVERRUN OPEN UP RED CROSS
OPERATED SHELTERS COUNTY
OPERATED SHELTERS AND AND OTHER
TYPES OF COMMUNITIES NEIGHBOR
HELPING NEIGHBOR TYPE SHELTERS
THAT WILL POP UP IN CHURCHES ARE
PARKING LOTS.
AND THEY ALL NEED STAFF ON THE
GROUND TO HELP THEM RUN THAT
SHELTER AS BEST AS POSSIBLE THEY
ALSO NEED STAFF TO RUN OUT
SHELTER WHICH FREQUENTLY ARE
STOPPER CALLED UPON TO VOLUNTEER.
AS BOMB WE CALL THEM BEST
MEMBERS BUT IT'S BASICALLY
ESSENTIALLY SERVING A SHELTER
STOP DOING WHATEVER IS REQUIRED
AT THE SHIP AT THE SHELTER.
THAT REQUIRES A DEPARTMENT
OPERATIONS CENTER TO BE CALLING
OUR STAFF WHO VOLUNTEERED AHEAD
OF TIME AND SAY CAN YOU SHOW UP
IN BUTTE COUNTY IN TWO HOURS --
SO DOING ALL OF THAT THAT
LOGISTICAL WORK UP FRONT AND
DISASTERS DON'T AND WHEN THE
WHEN THE FIRE IS OUT.
THE DISASTER CONTINUES FOR MOUNT
MULTIPLE MONTHS AFTER THAT FOR
DISASTER CAL FRONTAGE.
WITH STATE SUPPLEMENTAL GRANT
PROGRAMS WITH HELPING TO WORK
WITH FEMA TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S ACTUALLY GOING TO BE
HOUSING FOR INDIVIDUALS HAVE
BEEN DISPLACED.
AND OUR STAFF DOES ALL OF THE
PAPERWORK AND EVERYTHING THAT
SUPPORTS THAT AND THE PAPERWORK
IS UNIMAGINABLE -- FOR HOW MUCH
HAS TO GO INTO TO DOING ALL OF
THAT TO MAKE SURE THAT IT THAT'S
COMMUNITY CAN ACTUALLY GET ON
THE ROAD TO RECOVERY.
AND THAT WERE PROVIDING SUPPORT
TO THE LOCALS SO WE KNOW THAT
IT'S THAT IT'S A LARGE HOUSE FOR
STAFF BUT WE THINK IT'S
ABSOLUTELY CRITICALLY NECESSARY.
FOR THE STATE TO BE BETTER
PREPARED NOT ONLY FOR FAR
UPCOMING FIRE SEASON BUT FOR THE
EARTHQUAKE THAT WE ALL KNOW THAT
IS GOING TO OCCUR [inaudible]
SOON.
THANK YOU.
ALEJO FUNNY PARTICULARLY -- OUR
OFFICES REVIEW THESE PROPOSALS
AND DO NOT HAVE CONCERNS DOES
NOT HAVE CONCERNS AT THIS TIME
OKAY FINANCE. THREE MEMBERS.
OF PUBLIC COMMENT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FRANK MAC
WITH THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION ON BEHALF
OF THE FIRST RESPONDERS THAT
MISLI REACHES TALK TO YOU ABOUT --
WE'RE HERE TO SUPPORT -- THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
REQUESTED TO COMMEND THE
GOVERNOR FOR THAT FOR THE REST
OF IS.
MORE THAN A HALF A BILLION
DOLLAR GENERAL FUND DISASTER --
SUPPORT PACKAGE.
WE WERE SURPRISED AND INCREDIBLY
DISAPPOINTED THAT THE PACKAGE
DID NOT INCLUDE THE FUNDING THAT
WE REQUESTED. TO AUTOMATE THE
PROVISION OF DISASTER CAL FRESH
WHICH IS CURRENTLY PROVIDED BY
COUNTY WELFARE DEPARTMENTS.
IN A MANUAL CUMBERSOME TIME
CONSUMING.
PROCESS AND GIVEN THE THE SAD
STATE THAT -- DISASTERS ARE THE
NEW NORMAL WE WERE ASKING FOR
NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
ONE TIME TO BE ABLE TO AUTOMATE --
THE EXPEDITION -- AND PROVISION
OF LIFESAVING BENEFITS TO PEOPLE
WHO'VE LOST EVERYTHING ELSE.
AND FOR THE MAY REVISION TO HAVE
FOUND I NEED FOR NEW RESOURCES.
IN EXCESS OF A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND FOR THE MAY
REVISION TO TELL ALL THE
DEPARTMENTS AT THE TABLE AND THE
OTHERS AND OTHER SUBCOMMITTEES.
THAT WE AGREE THAT YOU CAN'T
ABSORB THIS WORKLOAD WE NEED TO
DO MORE. TO TO THEN TURN AROUND
AND TELL.
WHAT FOR DEPARTMENTS YOU SHOULD
ABSORB THAT IF THIS IS IMPORTANT
TO YOU YOU SHOULD ABSORB THAT
OUT OF EXISTING RESOURCES?
IN CONGRESS WITH THE REST OF THE
MAY REVISION AT BEST AND FRANKLY
OFFENSIVE AT WORST WHEN THE NAPA
CINEMA FIRE OCCURRED THE BUFFER
DIRECTOR THERE KAREN FEES.
BARELY ESCAPED HER HOUSE WITH
HER LIFE.
SHE HER HUSBAND LEFT THAT HOUSE.
WE DROVE TO OUR OFFICE.
AND IMMEDIATELY SET UP A COMMAND
POST.
AND SPENT THE NEXT SEVERAL
MONTHS TAKING CARE OF EVERYBODY
ELSE IN THE COUNTY AFFECTED BY
THAT FIRE INCLUDING THE ROUGHLY
25% OF OUR OWN STAFF OF LOST
THEIR HOMES.
AND TO TELL HER THAT THIS IS NOT
A STATE PRIORITY IN FITS OF
PRIORITY FOR YOU YOU SHOULD PAY
FOR IT IS INAPPROPRIATE AND SO
WE'D ASK THE ADMINISTRATION TO
RECONSIDER THEIR DECISION.
AND THAT'S THE LEGISLATURE TO
SUPPORT A REQUEST [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO OVER A MINUTE BUT STATION
YES.
YES SINGER CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES -- WERE
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THE INCREASE
STATE STAFFING RESOURCES TO
RESPOND TO DISASTERS AND
APPRECIATE THE PARTNERSHIP --
WITH STATE DEPARTMENT SAYS
COUNTIES OF BURNS FUNDING TO
THESE INCREASING DISASTERS -- IN
ADDITION WE DO SUPPORT THE
REQUEST TO AUTOMATE A DISASTER
CAL FOR ACTUALLY COUNTIES CAN
PARTNER WITH THE STATE.
ADMINISTERED IS VITAL BENEFITS
IN THE MOST EFFICIENT QUICK
MANNER AS POSSIBLE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
RIGHT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
BOB LET ME POSE THE QUESTION.
THE THOSE PRODUCTS -- THE NIGHT
TRAIN AND I KNOW WE'VE HEARD
THAT BEFORE -- SO WHAT WAS IN
TERMS OF IN SOME SENSES FOR
DISASTER PREPAREDNESS THE CASE
IS BEING MADE THAT THIS WOULD.
REALLY EXPEDITE -- I REALIZE
THAT WE HAVE.
WE NEED PEOPLE DO ALL THE OTHER
TASKS SO ROB FOR US BUT THIS
WOULD ALSO GREATLY EXPEDITE
PEOPLE BE ABLE TO GET THEIR HELP
SO.
MAYBE CAN SPEAK TO THAT.
HER WORDS DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
I THINK WE WOULD NOTE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S AN ALIGNMENT ON
AUTOMATING DISASTER CAL FRESH
WOULD BE A GOOD THING.
HOWEVER WERE IN DISAGREEMENT
WITH THE COUNTY IS AT THIS POINT
OVER WHETHER OR NOT THAT FINDING --
IS ACTUALLY AVAILABLE IN THEIR
EXISTING MAINTENANCE OPERATIONS
BUDGET.
SO THERE IS A DISAGREEMENT ABOUT.
WHERE THE FUNDING SHOULD COME
FROM WE BELIEVE THAT THEY'RE
SUFFICIENT FUNDING IN THE
MAINTENANCE OPERATIONS BUDGET
FOR THE SAUCE SYSTEM CURRENTLY
THAT CAN ABSORB THOSE CHANGES?
IF THE COUNTIES PRIORITIZE THOSE
CHANGES OKAY SO JUST TO CLARIFY
THE ADMINISTRATION'S POSITION IS
IS THAT -- THE CURRENT
ALLOCATION TO THE COUNTIES.
CONTAINS THE FUNDING FOR DOING
THE AUTOMATION THAT.
THERE IS A MAINTENANCE
OPERATIONS BUDGET THAT'S PROVIDE
IT'S ABOUT THREE HUNDRED MILLION
ANNUALLY FOR THE SAUCE SYSTEM
THAT ALLOWS COUNTIES TO MAKE
CHANGES FOR ADMINISTRATIVE
EFFICIENCIES OR CLAN
EFFICIENCIES SUCH AS THESE.
WE BELIEVE THAT CAN BE
PRIORITIZED WITHIN THAT BUDGET.
OKAY SO WITH AND SALAS.
OKAY ALL RIGHT THIS RICHARD LIKE
THAT WITH THAT AMOUNT HASN'T
CHANGED IN IT OVER A DECADE THE
MAINTENANCE AND OPERATIONS
BUDGET FOR SAUCES BEEN.
FLAT FOR OVER A DECADE OKAY AND
SO THAT THAT SUGGESTION THAT
THEY'RE SUFFICIENT RESOURCES
WITHIN THE EXISTING BUDGET IS
NOT TRUE.
WELL THE THANK YOU GIVE ME THE
PRIVILEGE OF FOR THE LA.
RIGHT WILL WORK -- THE INCOMES
ART SO WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THIS
ITEM OPEN AND APPRECIATE -- THE
GOVERNOR'S -- LEADERSHIP AND
BEING SURE WERE BETTER PREPARED
FOR EXAMPLE WE KNOW THAT --
KILEY GETTING A BUNCH OF PEOPLE
TOGETHER AND SHELTERS IS -- IS
RIGHT FOR HAVE POTENTIAL
OUTBREAK -- SO PUBLIC HEALTH --
WE KNOW WE NEED EVER HOSPITALS
WHERE SOME THEIR MOST VULNERABLE
PEOPLE -- WE ALSO NEED PEOPLES --
NEEDS FOR SOCIAL ERVICES DON'T
END JUST BECAUSE OF THE ASTOR
HAPPENS SO -- AND HOPING THAT
SOME AND HOPEFULLY OF ME THAT
THIS WAS I APPRECIATED ONE EVERY
IRAQI NICE IS THE AUTOMATION IS
SOMETHING THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT AND IS THEN WOULD BE
PART OF A PREPARATION FOR A
DISASTER AS WELL AS JUST GOOD ON
AN ONGOING BASIS SO HOPEFULLY WE
CAN.
WORK SOMETHING OUT.
OKAY ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT I THINK THIS CONCLUDES
OUR PART A HOWEVER A GENDER SO
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO PART
BE AND I SEE AROUND HERE SO
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH OUR
VOTE ONLY CALENDAR.
NINE IS THAT -- OF THE ITEMS
THERE ARE TWO ITEMS THAT WERE
REQUESTED TO BE -- REMOVED FROM
THE CONSENT CALENDAR AND THOSE
ARE -- A NUMBER -- FIVE ONE
EIGHT DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES
COMMUNICATOR LICENSE ISSUE
NUMBER TWO CORRECT.
AND THEN ALSO -- FIVE ONE EIGHT
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES
IMMIGRATION SERVICES BRANCH AND
ISSUE NUMBER ONE CORRECT.
SO WE WILL PUT SET THOSE ITEMS --
SEPARATE AND SO WE WILL NOW HAVE
THE REMAINING ITEMS.
OKAY SO THERE'S A MOTION BY
SENATOR STONE FOR THE MANY ITEMS
WHICH ARE IN THE AGENDA I WON'T
READ ALL OF THEM -- OKAY SO --
WE WERE CENTER SO SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SEC CALENDAR CENTER PAN HI THEN
HER TITLE [inaudible]
THUNDERSTONE.
OKAY SO THOSE ARE OUT THREE ZERO
SO WILL NEXT TAKE UP ITEM --
FIVE ONE EIGHT DEPARTMENT SOCIAL%
SERVICES COMMUNICATE A LICENSING
ISSUE NUMBER TWO WHICH IS
COMMUNITY SERVICES TECHNICAL
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSALS
REGARDING IMPLEMENTATION AB.
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY FIVE IS THERE
A MOTION -- FOR ADOPTION OF THIS
ITEM.
OKAY IT'S BEEN MOVED BY CENTER
TADO SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
HI INTERTITLES CENTER STONE.
OKAY SO THAT IS OUT.
TO ONE AND THEN FINALLY WE HAVE
ITEM NUMBER FIVE ONE EIGHT OF
DEPART SOCIAL SERVICES
IMMIGRATION SERVICES BRANCH
ISSUE NUMBER ONE TIME IN
SERVICES TECHNICAL BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL FOR IMMIGRATION ISSUES-A LEGAL.
SERVICES STATE SUPPORT SIR
MOTION.
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY CENTER TADO
SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR PAN HI THE TITLE.
CENTER STONE.
OKAY THAT IS OUT.
TO ONE OKAY SO THAT COMPLETES
THE VOTE ONLY CALENDAR -- WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO OUR ITEMS
FOR DISCUSSION SO WITH A FIRST
START [inaudible]
DEPARTMENT AGING.
WE HAVE A PRESENTATION ON THE
LONG TERM AND BUT CARE LONG TERM
CARE OMBUDSMAN AUGMENTATION MAY
REVISE.
SO WE CAN HAVE EVERYONE
INTRODUCE THEMSELVES FIRST FOR
THE RECORD.
WELL ACTUALLY YOU KNOW WHAT DID
I CALL FOR CORN [inaudible]
THOUGH.
ALL RIGHT SORRY OKAY HAVE YOU
PAUSE HERE I APOLOGIZE WE ARE
GETTING INTO THAT PHASE OKAY SO
SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL TO
STYLISTIC FORUM. HUNDRED HAND
HERE AND HER DAUGHTER.
THURSTONE.
OKAY SO TECHNICALLY I GUESS WE
JUST GOT TO DO ALL THE VOTES
BECAUSE WE HANDS APPS CORUM SO
FIRST OF ALL THE CONSENT
CALENDARS Và NEW PLACER STONE.
HAS ACTUALLY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
SENATOR BAM I'VE BEEN -- DONALD.
THUNDERSTONE OKAY SO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR EXCEPT THOSE TWO ITEMS
AN OUNCE EARLIER ARE IS -- PAST
THREE ZERO THEN I ISSUE NUMBER
TWO HUMAN SERVICES TECHNICAL PCP
PROVISION AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY
FIVE SB VISOR TADO SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL YOUR PAN I'VE.
HEARD DATA CENTERS THEM.
OKAY SO THAT'S OUT TO ONE AND
THEN FINALLY ISSUE NUMBER --
FIVE ONE EIGHT THE FARMS OR
SERVICES IMMIGRATION SERVICES
BRANCH ISSUE NUMBER ONE THE VICE
CENTER TADO.
AS A GROUP THESE CALL THE ROLL
CENTER PAN HI CENTER HER
DAUGHTER.
CENTER STONE.
OKAY SO THAT'S OUT TO ONE OKAY
SO.
Q. I APOLOGIZE.
YOU WILL GET THIS RIGHT.
JULIE OKAY SO WE'LL MOVE ON NOW
THE PART AGE IF IF WE COULD
PLEASE INTRODUCE THEMSELVES FOR
THE RECORD FIRST.
IS THERE A DEPARTING YES GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR CAME
COMMITTEE MEMBERS JOE RODRIGUEZ
THE CALIFORNIA STATE LONG TERM
CARE OMBUDSMAN GIVE.
HI THOMAS CAMERON DEPUTY
DIRECTOR ADMINISTRATION FOR THE
DEPARTMENT MEETING THANK YOU EL
AL.
CHECCHI BRASSIERE ELIA.
JANIE BELL LA -- BY ITS WHICH
WAS WHAT APARTMENT FINANCE THANK
YOU THANKS VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT
LET'S GO AND BEGIN -- SO DO IT --
WE REQUESTING NE MILLION
DOLLARS IN ADDITIONAL ONE TIME
FUNDING TO LOCAL LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN PROGRAMS FROM THE
STATE HEALTH FACILITIES CITATION
PENALTIES ACCOUNT.
PURSUANT TO PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE
IN THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUDGET
ACT -- JUST FOR YOUR REFERENCE
WE PROJECT THE CURRENT YEAR
ENDING FUND BALANCE TO BE
APPROXIMATELY NINE POINT NINE
MILLION DOLLARS.
WHICH IS ABOUT THE SIX MILLION
DOLLAR THRESHOLD CONTAINING THE
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE HAPPY
ANSWER QUESTIONS OKAY THANK YOU --
COMES FROM ALEJO.
NO CONCERN SEE IT MORE AS A
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENT TO GIVEN
THAT IT WAS EXPECTED PER THE
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE.
OKAY ANY DELICIOUS FROM THE
AGENCY OKAY.
QUESTIONS COMMITTEE MEMBERS SAY
NONE OF PUBLIC COMMENT.
GOOD MORNING LISA COLEMAN WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION WE ARE
WE'RE GRATEFUL OF COURSE FOR
THIS MILLION WE JUST WISH TO
POINT OUT THAT.
IS A TECHNICAL WE RECEIVED THIS
MILLION FOR THREE YEARS IN A ROW
WE DID NOT RECEIVE IT LAST YEAR
AND WE ARE HAPPY TO HAVE IT BACK.
WE WOULD LIKE TO REMIND THE
COMMITTEE THAT THIS SHOULD WE
HOPE DOES NOT IMPACT THE FIVE
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET
REQUEST WE ARE STILL SEEKING.
AS THAT IS ONGOING AND THIS IS
ONE TIME ONLY AND CANNOT BE USED
FOR SALARY.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
OKAY CEILING -- SNOW THE COMMON
SO WE WILL HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT SO NOW WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO THE
SPRING FINANCE LETTER SS I CASH
OUT REVERSAL IMPLEMENTATION
[inaudible]
OF OBAMA.
BUT STATUS L. TIPS.
OKAY.
RIGHT HOMELESSNESS.
IN THE ROOM.
OF THIS TO WHAT SORRY.
THE PRIMARY ABILITY A SKIT THE
REAR OKAY.
YES -- HOMA THAT'S I THINK WE
HAVE DEPARTMENT REHABILITATION
COMING OFF.
ALL RIGHT YES SORRY TO FARM
REHABILITATION -- ISSUE ONE
SUPPORTER OF PLACEMENT SUPPORTED
EMPLOYMENT PROVIDER RATE
ADJUSTMENT MAY REVISION
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
SORT OF BACK AND FORTH.
CASE OF RECKON INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES FOR THE RECORD FIRST.
HI MY NAME IS MARK EHRLICH MEN
ON THE ASSISTANT DEPUTY DIRECTOR
AND EMPLOYMENT DIVISION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION
GIVE [inaudible]
I HI MY NAME'S ARNOLD THIS CARD
CHAU -- THE ASSISTANT HAD BEEN
DEPUTY DIRECTOR THANK YOU ALEJO
ANY PETTITTE KALLIO.
JEANNIE BELL LA -- BY ITS
WHISPERS WROTE APARTMENT A
FINANCE THANK YOU PLEASE BEGIN.
SO WE'RE REQUESTING ONE POINT
THREE MILLION GENERAL FUND TO
REFLECT A TWO YEAR LIMIT TERM
PROVIDER RATE INCREASE FOR
SUPPORTED EMPLOYMENT SERVICES
SPECIFICALLY JOB COACHING
SERVICES.
EFFECTIVE JANUARY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY THIS WILL ALIGN THE
VOCATIONAL REHABILITATION
SUPPORT EMPLOYMENT RATES WITH
THOSE OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES -- JUST
FOR MORE DETAILS THIS AMOUNT
WOULD DOUBLE THE TWO POINT SIX
MILLION IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND THEN DROP BACK
DOWN TO ONE POINT THREE MILLION
IN.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
TWO THOSE AMOUNTS ARE HALF YOUR
COSTS BECAUSE THE TWO YEAR TO
CALENDAR YEAR -- INCREASE AND
HAPPY ANSWERING QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
THE ACCOMPLISHMENT AGE THAT YEAH
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO ADD THAT
THESE SERVICES BY PROVIDE
SUPPORT TO PROXIMITY THOUSAND
JOB SEEKERS WITH DISABILITIES.
TO HELP THEM OBTAIN AND MAINTAIN
EMPLOYMENT AND HOPEFULLY I
BECOMING A PAIN IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU L. L..
SENATE HEADACHE LA -- GIVEN THAT
THE SUPPORTED EMPLOYMENT RATES
ON THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION SIDE -- REFLECT
THE RATES THAT ARE PROVIDED ON
THE DDS SIDE IF THE LEGISLATURE
AGREES WITH THE RATE INCREASE
PROPOSED ON THE DDS SIDE THAN
THIS PROPOSAL ON THE DEAL OUR
SIDE.
MAKES A LOT OF SENSE -- THE ONE
ISSUE THAT WE WOULD RAISE.
IS THAT THESE RATE INCREASES ARE
PROPOSED TO SUNSET AT THE END OF
CALENDAR.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND AS YOU'RE
LIKELY AWARE THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF PROPOSALS ACROSS HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES PRO PROGRAMS IN
THE MAY REVISION THAT WOULD
SUNSET AT THE END OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE OUR OFFICE DOES HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THESE -- WILL
LIKELY ADDRESS THESE IN THE
HEARING ON THE DDS ISSUES AS
WELL AS DH CS AND I HSS.
BUT ESSENTIALLY -- OUR OFFICE OF
FINES THAT THE THE MAYOR VISION
PROGRAMS THAT ARE FUNDAMENTALLY
ONGOING IN NATURE AS ONE TIME --
AND WE HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT.
YOU KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS IN A IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND AND
WHETHER THE ADMINISTRATION IS IS
BASICALLY UNDERSTATING THE FULL
COST OF THAT THE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS UNDERSTATING
THE FULL COST OF THOSE PROGRAMS.
HI QUESTION FOR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
A PUBLIC COMMENT [inaudible]
A SENIOR.
I GUESS -- SO I ACTUALLY SO ONE
QUESTION YOU SEE SAID THIS IS
THIS IS THIS LINING UP WITH --
YOU SAID WITH -- SO THE OPPOSITE
WE'RE JUST HEARING THE PAR REHAB
PIECE RIGHT NOW IS THAT LINING
UP WITH THE WAS IT DEPARTMENT
DEVELOPED TO SERVICES. TO THE
RIGHT INTENTION AS INTENTION
CORRECT BECAUSE ACTUALLY OKAY.
AND IS ON THE IS SO I KNOW THE
THAN WAS MENTIONED THIS IS.
WELL IT'S TEMPORARY IS THAT ALSO
THE CASE ON THE DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES TO RE TALKING ABOUT
TEMPORARY INCREASE YEAH IT'S A
TWO YEAR LIMITED TERM OF PRIDE
RATE INCREASES ON THE EIGHTY S.
SIDE AND WE'RE JUST ALIGNING.
LOCATION REHABILITATION RATES K..
OKAY.
OKAY SO -- AND I AM THE AGE I DO
STE.
AND I WILL BE TALKING ABOUT IT
MORE LINKS LATER BUT I'M SURE
THAT THE PEOPLE WOULD APPRECIATE
HAVING SOME RATE INCREASE VERSES
NINE HER RIGHT EVEN IF IT'S
CALLED TEMPORARY BUT I I DO
SHIRLEY IS CONCERNED ABOUT.
I MEAN BUILDING IN AN EXPIRATION
DATE -- FOR FOR A FIGHTER EIGHT
ENTRY ERROR -- THE PLANET I MEAN
BASICALLY THE PROVIDER RATES IN
A WAY THAT.
I GUESS PEOPLE KNOW THAT THE
COMING IN SOME WAYS ALTHOUGH
AGAIN WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
ECONOMIC CIRCUMSTANCES ARE BUT
TO SORT OF BUILD AND I THINK.
I GUESS THE QUESTION IS IS THAT
ARE WE HONESTLY SAYING THAT WE
REALLY DO WANT TO CUT ALL THE
RATES IN TWO YEARS ARE WE JUST
AS AS OF NOW MECHANISM TO THAT
AND REDUCE THE COST OF THE OUT
YEARS RIGHT -- THAT -- AND WHAT
WHAT REALLY ARE TENSIONS
OBVIOUSLY -- YEAH WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT ECONOMIC CIRCUMSTANCES WILL
BE IN TWO YEARS OF OTHER WAYS TO
MAKE A KILLING ON THE STOCK
MARKET -- BUT I YOU KNOW I A BUT
WONDER WHAT KIND OF MESSAGE IT
SENDS AND I APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION ALSO TRYING TO
FIGURE THIS OUT -- WHEN WE TELL
PEOPLE WELL WE'LL GIVE YOU A
RATE INCREASE THAT SORELY NEEDED
BUT THAT'S GONNA AND IN TWO
YEARS AND?
IT AND AN AUTO PILOT LESS.
DON'T GOVERNOR IN THE LIST AND
THE LEGISLATURE SAY WE'RE GOING
TO AT LEAST KEEP IT LEVEL OR
WHATEVER WHEN DO IN AT THAT TIME
SO -- SO WHAT HIS WILL HAVE A
BIGGER DISCUSSION IN.
FULL BUDGET ABOUT THAT OKAY.
ALL RIGHT ANYTHING ELSE ON THIS
THAN.
OKAY CENA OKAY SO I GUESS WE'LL
THAT COMMENT WILL BE REPEATED ON
MULTIPLE OCCASIONS.
UNDERSTAND.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT -- THANK YOU THANKS
FOR MUCH ALL RIGHT THE PURPOSE
OF CHILD SUPPORT SERVICES MAY
REVISION ESTIMATE [inaudible]
OKAY.
REGIS THEMSELVES TO THE RECORD
AGAIN.
GOOD MORNING MARC BECKLEY CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES OKAY ALEJO KEEPERS HERE
ONLY A JANIE BELL ELIA.
LANCE WHISPERED WHAT APARTMENT
FINANCE THANK YOU THANKS PLEASE
PRESENT -- THE DEPARTMENT IS
REQUESTING A AUTHORITY --
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY ADJUSTMENT
TREE BALANCE LEVELS AND IT'S
CHARLES FOR RECOVERY FUND AND
IT'S FEDERAL TRUST FUNDS.
PERCENT FEDERAL REGULATIONS THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT REQUIRES THAT
CHILD SUPPORT FULLY EXPAND ITS
FEDERAL SHARE OF CHILD SUPPORT
COLLECTIONS.
WHICH IS IN COULD CONTAIN WITHIN
ITS TRIALS FOR A REFUND BEFORE
TRYING DOWN ADDITIONAL TRUST
FUND.
THE MAJOR REVISION -- LEVEL
PROJECTIONS ARE SLIGHTLY LOWER
THAN THE PROJECTION LEVELS WE
ESTIMATE IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET BY TWO POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS.
THEREFORE WE ASK FOR A REDUCTION
IN OUR CHILD SUPPORT RECOVERY
FUND -- FORTY MATT BY TWO POINT
SIX MILLION.
AN INCREASE IN OUR FEDERAL TRUST
FUND ABOUT BLACKMUN'S ARE ABOUT.
THANK YOU L. L. ONCE NO CONTENT
OKAY FINANCE RATE PUBLIC COMMENT.
A SINGLE -- ACTUALLY PUSHES
COMMITTEE MEMBERS NO RIGHT OKAY
THANKS FOR MUCH I WILL HOLD ITS
ITEM OPEN WERE ALSO WE'RE HOPING
I'D OPEN THE PREVIOUS ITEMS AS
WELL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT THE PHARMACEUTICAL
SERVICES AUTOMATION PROJECTS.
IF TWO ISSUES HERE SO AGAIN WE
CAN AFTER ONE INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES FOR THE RECORD.
FEATURED IN GOOD SHAPE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT THANK
YOU L. L..
JEANNIE BELL LA -- TURKEY
BRASILIA FINANCE.
JUST GREATEST BERMAN FINANCE.
TIGER WOODS PERMIT FINANCE LIKE
YOU ALL RIGHT PLEASE BE IN.
ISSUE NUMBER ONE A B. BRIEFING
PLEASE AS WE GO THROUGH THE
ITEMS THERE'S QUITE A FEW SO
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO ADD IN AND
ASK US QUESTIONS.
AS HE W. S. CARES IS OUR IT
PROJECT EFFORT TO REPLACE THE
LEGACY SYSTEM THAT WE'VE HAD FOR
QUITE SOME TIME AT THIS POINT --
WE'RE REQUESTING A CONTINUATION
OF EIGHT EXISTING POSITIONS TO
CONTINUE WORK ON NOT -- THAT
PROJECT -- ON THE SECOND ITEM
OKAY SO I WILL YEAH AN ITEM LARA
LA -- COMMENT JEANNIE BELL LA --
WE HAVE NO CONCERNS OKAY FINANCE.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HI PUBLIC
COMMENT OKAY ALL THAT ITEM OPEN
NOW IT'S ISSUE NUMBER TWO BUT
YOU BILL LANGUAGE.
ISSUE NUMBER -- TWO THE THIS
PROJECT -- TO CREATE CAL SALAS
FROM THE EXISTING -- THREE
STATEWIDE AUTOMATED WELFARE
SYSTEMS -- IS UNDER WAY IT'S
UNDERGOING FEDERAL REVIEW AS
WELL AS THE STATE LEVEL REVIEWS
AND SO RATHER THAN PUT SPECIFIC
MONEY IN THE BUDGET WE'VE WE'VE
ASKED THAT.
CONSISTENT WITH THOSE APPROVALS
IN JAIL BC NOTIFICATION SORRY
JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE WITH NOTIFICATION --
THAT WE WOULD HAVE THE ABILITY
TO ADJUST THE THE BUDGET IN
DURING THE YEAR NEXT YEAR TO
REFLECT THOSE APPROVALS AND AND
FINAL APPROVED PROJECT COST.
THANK YOU ALEJO.
THE LANGUAGE EX FIND US TO OKAY
FINANCE.
OKAY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
PUBLIC COMMENTS OKAY WE'LL HOLD
THAT I AM OPEN THANK YOU.
ARE IS MOVE ON TO DEPARTMENT
SOCIALIST ARIOUS PROGRAMS ISSUE
NUMBER ONE MAYBE VISION KEESLER
DESPOTS -- OBVIOUSLY IN MAY IT'S
OUR OPPORTUNITY -- TO BLEW A
DATE THE BUDGET FOR ALL THE
CASELOAD FLUCTUATIONS IN
PRESENTATIONS -- THAT THAT WOULD
THAT WE HAVE ON ON CURRENT DATA
PAGE TWELVE A PROVIDES A SUMMARY
OF THE FISCAL ADJUSTMENTS.
I WILL READ THE TABLE TO YOU BUT
I'LL JUST CALL OUT SOME GENERAL
COMMENTS IN THE CAL WORKS
PROGRAM WE'RE SEEING A
HISTORICALLY LOW CASELOAD OF
PROJECTED IN THE BUDGET YEAR FOR
THAT PROGRAM.
AS THE SCIENCES P. WERE IN
ROUGHLY THE THIRD YEAR OF WHAT
WE SEE AS A 1% ANNUAL DECLINE IN-THAT POPULATION THAT MIRRORS A
NATIONAL TREND -- THAT WE SEE IN
THAT PROGRAM IN HOME SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES -- YOU'VE HEARD IN
OTHER HEARINGS AROUND AGING
ISSUES THE GRAYSON ARMY IS HERE
AND PROGRAM UTILIZATION
CONTINUES TO GROW.
AND THEN I'LL DROP ALL THE WAY
DOWN TO THE SECOND THE LAST ITEM
I JUST WANT TO CALL OUT SEVEN OF
CALIFORNIA'S COUNTIES ARE
CURRENTLY IN A TITLE FOR U.
WAIVER THIS IS THE CHILD WELFARE.
SERVICES FINDING WAIVER -- THAT
WE'VE HAD FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS
BY CURRENT FEDERAL LAW THAT
EXPIRES SEPTEMBER -- THIRTY
TWENTY NINETEEN COVERS -- THOSE
SEVEN COUNTIES REPRESENT ALMOST
EXACTLY HALF OF OUR FOSTER CARE
CASELOAD.
AND DO SO BABY BECAUSE WE BUDGET
BASED ON CURRENT LAW WE WE
EXPECT THAT WAIVER TO EXPIRE AND
THAT'S REFLECTED IN THE BUDGET
HOWEVER WE'RE PROPOSING BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE THAT WOULD ALLOW
ADJUSTMENTS TO THE BUDGET IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE YEAR SHOULD AT
SOME POINT -- FEDERAL ACTION BE
TAKEN EITHER TO EXPAND WAIVERS
OR PROVIDE OTHER FINANCIAL
SUPPORT -- THERE'S A VARIETY OF
DISCUSSIONS HAPPENING IN DC SO I
WANTED TO CALL THOSE THOSE FEW
ITEMS OUT FOR YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU L. L..
WE'VE REVIEWED THE UPDATED
ESTIMATES IN LIGHT OF MORE
RECENT DATA AN ACTUAL THAT WE
HAVE FOR THE MAJOR PROGRAMS AND
WE AGREE WITH THE ADJUSTMENTS
BEING PROPOSED BY THE DEPARTMENT.
I THANK YOU FINANCE.
THE MEMBERS PUBLIC COMMENT.
RIGHT WILL HOLD THE SIGNS OPEN
THANK YOU -- ISSUE NUMBER TWO
SPECIAL EPICS RIGHT -- APARTMENT --
AMONG OTHER THINGS IS PROUD TO
ADMINISTER THE TAX CHECKOFF FUND
OF FOR THE SPECIAL OLYMPICS AND
THE MAY REVISION INCLUDES BE ON
THOSE FUNDS AN ADDITIONAL TWO
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IS
A PASSED THROUGH. TO THE SPECIAL
OLYMPICS A IN THE BUDGET YEAR.
OKAY THANK YOU L. L..
GEN FINANCE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PUBLIC COMMENT.
OKAY CINEMA HOLE THAT I AM OPEN --
ISSUE NUMBER THREE BUDGET THE
LANGUAGE CASH DISBURSEMENT
AUTHORITY -- AND THIS IS REALLY
AS TECHNICAL AS IT SOUNDS ON
OCCASION -- THOSE EITHER
REALIGNMENT REVENUE CASH FLOW OR
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CASH FLOW
ISN'T WHAT WE EXPECT AND WE'RE
SIMPLY ASKING FOR THE AUTHORITY
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE PROGRAMS
CONTINUE TO SERVE PEOPLE AS
THOSE DISRUPTIONS DO OR DON'T
OCCUR.
THANK YOU EL AL.
FINANCE.
REMEMBERS THAT.
PUBLIC COMMENT OKAY WE'LL HOLD
THAT I'M OPEN THANK YOU.
MOVING ON TO OUR SOCIAL SERVICES
IMMIGRATION BRANCH ISSUE NUMBER
ONE RAPID RESPONSE FUNDING.
RIGHT AND WITH THE PERMISSION OF
THE CHAIR ALL COLLAPSE THE TWO
BECAUSE THE TOPIC IS THE SAME
YOU MAY RECALL THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET THERE WAS A FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR CURRENT YOUR PROPOSAL AND
A TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET
YOUR PROPOSAL.
IN REFLECTION OF THE EVOLVING
NATURE OF OUR COMMITMENTS HERE
THE MAY REVISION PROPOSES TO
TAKE SOME OF THAT TWENTY MILLION
AND PUT IT DIRECTLY IN THE
SOCIAL SERVICES BUDGET WITH THE
BALLOT STILL REMAINING AS OF THE
JANUARY.
PROPOSAL THAT DAY WOULD BE
AVAILABLE FOR DISBURSEMENT BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
OF FOR THESE PURPOSES SO THAT
THAT'S LAST IS ISSUE TO THE
SUMMIT STILL TWENTY MILLION BUT
IT'S NOW IN TWO DIFFERENT PLACES
OKAY SO WE'RE DOING WITH ISSUE
NUMBER ONE IN ISSUE NUMBER --
TWO LA -- COMMENTS.
PLEASE NEW PERSON YOU INTRODUCE
YOURSELF. FOR THE RECORD.
SENATE HAMMER DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THANK YOU OKAY NO
COMMENTS FOR FINANCE OR A
QUESTION COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
PUBLIC COMMENT SEE SOMEONE
COMING TO MICROPHONE.
HI GOOD MORNING -- MADELINE
COOPER AND A HALF OF THE COUNTY
OF SAN DIEGO.
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
IMMIGRATION OPERATIVE SPONSORED.
IN IMMIGRATION RAPID RESPONSE --
FIND AS WELL AND WE DO SUPPORT --
ISSUE NUMBER FOR THIS PERSON AS
WELL.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT SO WILL HOLD
OPEN ISSUES ONE AND TWO AND
LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
THREE WHICH IS THE BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE ON EXPANSION OF
IMMIGRATION RELATED SERVICES.
A AND BECAUSE WE WANT TO
LANGUAGE I WAS REMISS TO MENTION
I OBVIOUSLY WITH ITEMS ONE INTO
THERE'S A PIECE OF TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE ASSOCIATED WITH THAT
ITEM.
ON ISSUE NUMBER -- THREE BAY
BASED ON SPENDING THAT WE'VE
EXPERIENCED IN THE LEGAL
SERVICES PROGRAM PARTICULARLY
BETWEEN THE UNDOCUMENTED
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS PROGRAM AND
THE TEMPORARY PROTECTED STATUS --
PROGRAM-- THAT WE BELIEVE THERE
THERE'S THE ABILITY AND BUDGET
YEAR. TO TO MOVE FIVE MILLION --
AT AT OUT OF THAT -- TEMPORARY
PROTECTIVE SUITS STATUS -- POT
THAT WE HAD PROPOSED AT TEN
MILLION AND TO TAKE FIVE MILLION
OTHER TO DO THE TWO THINGS
LISTED IN YOUR AGENDA.
PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH SCREENINGS
AND EVALUATION AND DEVELOPING A
FAMILY RE REUNIFICATION
NAVIGATOR PILOT TO IT TO MAKE
THOSE CONNECTIONS FOR PEOPLE
IT'S BEEN OUR EXPERIENCE AND IN
DISCUSSIONS WITH LEGAL SERVICES
OF PROVIDERS THAT THAT WE'RE
CONTRACTED WITH.
THAT -- VERY OFTEN IT'S
NECESSARY TO DOCUMENT EVIDENCE
OF TRAUMA AND AND THE ADVERSE
IMPACTS -- IN SUPPORT OF A SITE
LEAVE PETITIONS AND ANOTHER --
IMMIGRATION RELIEF AND SO THAT
THIS WOULD PROVIDE THROUGH THOSE
LEGAL SERVICES PROVIDERS ACCESS
TO THE SCREENINGS NECESSARY.
TO PROVIDE PROPER REPRESENTATION
OF THE CASE.
I THANK YOU -- COMES MILIEU
FINANCE REMEMBERS PUBLIC COMMENT
XENON WILL HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN
LET'S MOVE ON ISSUE NUMBER FOUR
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE ON
MINISTRATION REFUGEE SERVICES
WISHIN.
WILSON FISH PROGRAM.
SHE AT THE THE DETAILED
DISCUSSION HERE IN THE AGENDA
NOT SHELL THE FADS -- GOOD
PROVIDE FUNDING TO STATES.
A TO OPERATE REFUGEE
RESETTLEMENT PROGRAMS -- IN.
HERE ROUGHLY TWENTY YEARS AGO
THAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT NO
WITH HELD SOME OF THAT MONEY AND
CONTRACTED ITSELF DIRECTLY WITH
AN ORGANIZATION IN THE SAN DIEGO
AREA. TO RUN WHAT THEY CALL THE
WILSON FISH DEMONSTRATION
PROGRAM THEY INDICATED TO US.
THAT AS OF THE END OF SEPTEMBER
THIS YEAR THEIR INTENT TO STOP
DIRECTLY FUNDING THAT
ORGANIZATION THEMSELVES AND THEY
ASKED THE STATE TO PICK IT UP --
ALONG WITH WITH THE THE PROPOSAL
FOR THE THE PASSING THROUGH THE
FUNDING TO THAT ORGANIZATION
THERE'S A PIECE OF TRAILER BILL
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS ITEM AS
WELL.
THAT WOULD ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT
THE IT WOULD PROVIDE THE
AUTHORITY FOR THE DEPARTMENT A
CONTRACT DIRECTLY WITH A NON
PROFIT RATHER THAN THE COUNTY.
IN THIS CASE TO CONTINUE THAT
OKAY THANK YOU L. L..
TURNS FINANCE.
PUBLIC COMMON NAMES ANY CITY
WORSE FOR IN THE MORNING I'LL
SAY ABOUT THAT.
OKAY ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OKAY.
YEAH WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THIS
ITEM OPENED THANK YOU SO WE'LL
MOVE ON TO THE PURPOSE SOCIAL
SERVICES CHILD WELFARE SERVICES
ISSUE NUMBER ONE RESOURCE FAMILY
APPROVAL ADMINISTRATION A
BACKLOG -- THE NEXT FEW ITEMS
THAT WE GO THROUGH -- RELATE TO
THE CONTINUOUS CARE REFORM AND
ALL ALL THINGS CHILD WELFARE
THIS ONE BEING A REALLY
IMPORTANT ONE TO US THE RESOURCE
FAMILY APPROVAL WE'VE
HISTORICALLY TALKED ABOUT THESE
AS FOSTER FAMILY HOMES -- WE'VE
CHANGED THE EXPECTATIONS FOR
THEM AND THERE'S A NEW APPROVAL
PROCESS COUNTIES HAVE BEEN GREAT
PARTNERS AND DOING A LOT OF WORK
TO GET THROUGH THAT -- THE THIS
BUDGET REFLECTS -- ON ON GOING
FUNDING FOR RESOURCE FAMILY
APPROVAL IN THE CURRENT FISCAL
YEAR THAT WERE NOW IN THERE WAS
ALSO A ONE TIME AUGMENTATION TO
ADDRESS WHAT WE CALL THE RFA
BACKLOG.
NOT ONLY ARE WE CONTINUING TO
RECRUIT NEW FAMILIES BUT WE'RE
CONVERTING THE EXISTING FAMILIES
TO THIS NEW MODEL THAT'S CREATED --
A BUBBLE IN THE PIPELINE -- AND
AND SO TO BRING THAT BACKLG
DOWN AN INCREASE TIME TO
APPROVAL WERE ALSO APPROVED --
INCLUDING IN THE MAY REVISION --
A ONE TIME FINDING AGAIN -- TO
ADDRESS THAT BACKLOG AS WELL.
Q. L. L..
WE AGREE WITH THE AUGMENTATION
HERE IN JANUARY WE POINTED OUT
THAT THAT RESOURCE FAMILY
APPROVAL PROCESS WAS STILL
TAKING LONGER THAN WE EXPECTED --
WE DO HAVE SOME QUESTIONS OUT TO
THE ADMINISTRATION WE JUST SENT
THEM ABOUT SORT OF THE ACTUAL
NUMBER IN THE METHODOLOGY SO BE
WORKING THROUGH THAT AND RAISE
ANY ISSUES OF AS THEY COME U.
OKAY THANK YOU FINANCE.
JUST FINISHED A BERMAN FINANCES
WERE CLARIFIED THAT THE THE ITS
ONGOING FUNDING THAT IS OUR ONE
TIME THERE IS SOMEONE GOING ARE
OF A FUNDING. FOR PROBATION
RELATED WORK BUT THE FUNDING
INCLUDED IN THE MAYOR VISION IS
ONE TIME FOR ABOUT YEAR OKAY
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT COMMITTEE MEMBER
MISSIONS ARE A PUBLIC COMMENT IF
YOU MISTER CHAIR FRANK MAKE WITH
CWD A WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THE ADDITION TO THE MAYOR VISION.
ON IN OUR MEMBERS OPINION
THERE'S ON GOING WORK ASSOCIATED
WITH OUR FAA AND SO -- THOUGH
THAT BUDGET AUGMENTATION THE MAY
REVISION IS ONE TIME WE LOOK
FORWARD TO SPEAKING WITH THE NEW
SECRETARY IN THE NEW
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT CC ARE
GENERALLY BECAUSE WE BELIEVE
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT ONGOING
COST.
THAT ARE ACCURATELY REFLECTED
BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN WE DON'T
APPRECIATE WHAT'S IN THERE NOW
MY LOOK FOR TO KEEP TALKING.
YOU THANKS BOBBIE SANTOS ON
BEHALF OF SEIU CALIFORNIA -- WE
ALSO ARE VERY APPRECIATIVE OF
THE PARTIAL RESTORATION WOULD BE
EVEN MORE APPRECIATIVE IF THE
FULL TWENTY FOUR POINT FOUR
MILLION WERE -- WERE RESTORED --
THERE CONTINUES TO BE SIX
MILLION DOLLAR DELTA THAT WERE
LOOKING FOR BUT WE'RE VERY VERY
APPRECIATED APPRECIATIVE BECAUSE
THE WORK CONTINUES AND THE ONLY
WAY WE ARE ABLE TO ADEQUATELY
AND APPROPRIATELY ADDRESSED THE
BACKLOG.
IS IF THEY'RE SUFFICIENT FUNDING
TO DO SO I WON ALSO ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF MISTER MECCA THAT WE
LOOK FORWARD TO ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS REGARDING OUT YOUR
FUNDING.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
TESTING A CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION F COUNTIES WE ALSO.
ARE THANKFUL FOR THE INCREASE
FUNDING HERE AND WOOD ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF THE PARTY SPEAKERS
TO LOOKING FORWARD ON BUYING
CONVERSATIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME TO DEEPLY AGAIN CHECK
OFTEN IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER
SUPPORT OF THAT MAY REVISED ONE
CALIFORNIA PROPOSAL TO EXTEND
THAT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS THE
TWO PILOT PROGRAMS.
AND SUPPORT OF THE SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION OVERALL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT SO -- WE'RE GOING TO
HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN LET'S MOVE
ON TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO PLACEMENT
PRIOR TO APPROVAL AND EMERGENCY
CARE GIVEN THE CARE GIVER
PLACEMENT TRAIL TROUBLING WHICH
THIS [inaudible]
OF I ON THIS ISSUE -- IN OUR
CONVERSATIONS AROUND CONTINUUM
OF CARE REFORM -- WANT ONE OF
THE ISSUES THAT WAS IDENTIFIED --
PARTICULARLY GIVEN THE LAG IN --
IN APPROVAL OF RESOURCE FAMILY
HOMES WAS THE FACT THAT WHEN WE
ASK.
OUR PARENTS AND OTHER PROVIDERS
TO STEP UP AND PROVIDE CARE --
IT HISTORICALLY WE HAVEN'T
PROVIDED FUNDING FOR IT TO
SUPPORT THAT CHILD IN THAT
PLACEMENT UNTIL THE HOME IS
ACTUALLY BEEN APPROVED.
A COUPLE YEARS AGO IN THE BUDGET
THAT WE BEGAN THE POLICY OF
FINDING OUT THAT THE DATE OF A A
PLACEMENT OF THE CHILD
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THE HOME
HAD YET BEEN APPROVED THEIR TIME
LIMITS ON THAT FUNDING.
IN THE CURRENT FISCAL YEAR --
STATE FINDINGS AVAILABLE FOR A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY DAYS --
BEFORE THE HOME IS APPROVED AND
THEN IF THERE'S GOOD BECAUSE
THIS BEYOND THE CONTROL OF THE
STATE FAMILY AND COUNTY TO TO
APPROVE THE HOME -- UP TO ONE
YEAR OF FINDING UNDER CURRENT
STATUTE IN BUDGET YEAR -- THAT
STATE FUNDING WOULD NOT BE
AVAILABLE AFTER NINETY DAYS SO
WE'RE PROPOSING -- TO DO TWO
THINGS -- ONE EXTEND THAT NINETY
DAYS TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY AND
BUDGET YEAR AND ALLOW GOOD CAUSE
FOR UP TO ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
DAYS AN OUTLINE LANGUAGE I
BELIEVE THIS GOING TO BE
FORTHCOMING LATER TODAY -- SO
THAT PEOPLE HAVE A CHANCE TO TO
READ THAT -- AND THEN FUNDING TO
MATCH.
OKAY THANK YOU ALEJO.
WE AGREE THAT THE AUGMENTATION
AND THAT THE CONCEPT IN THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE MAKES
SENSE WE ARE WAITING TO REVIEW
THE LANGUAGE AND WE LIKE TO LOOK
AT IT IN LIGHT OF UPDATED ACTUAL
IS ON HOW LONG IT IS TAKING TO
GET THROUGH THE PROCESS FOR
THESE FAMILIES.
THANK YOU FINANCE.
RIGHT A PUBLIC COMMENT.
IT IS SHORT FOR THE ALLIANCE FOR
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS AND WE
APPRECIATE THE EXTENSION OF THE
EMERGENCY CARE GIVER FUNDING.
TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY DAYS BUT
WE THINK IT'S CRITICAL THAT THE
GOOD CAUSE EXCEPTION CONTINUE TO
BE FO THE FULL THREE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY FIVE DAYS AND NOT BE
CUT TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY DAYS
AS PROPOSED -- THE PRIOR ISSUE
SPEAKS TO THE FACT THAT RESOURCE
FAMILY APPROVAL STILL HAS A
BACKLOG WE KNOW THAT IT'S STILL
TAKING ON AVERAGE A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY DAYS TO GET THREE
RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL WHICH
MEANS MANY FAMILIES ARE TAKING.
MORE THAN A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
DAYS TO GET THROUGH THE PROCESS
SO IF YOU CUT OFF FUNDING AT A
HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS WITH NO GOOD
BECAUSE WE'RE ONLY PUNISHING
THOSE FAMILIES GOOD BECAUSE
MEANS THERE WAS A FINDING THAT
IT'S NOT THE CARE GIVERS FAULT.
AND IT'S NOT THE COUNTY'S FAULT
THAT THE DELAY IS TAKING SO LONG
I DON'T KNOW WHY WE WOULD
DEPRIVE THOSE CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES OF ON GOING CRITICAL
FUNDING THAT STABILIZES
PLACEMENTS WHEN IT'S BEEN
DETERMINED THAT IT'S NO FAULT OF
ANYONE THAT THE DELAYS TAKEN SO
LONG SO WEEKS.
WE ASK THAT IT BE EXTENDED THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE DAYS THANK
YOU.
OKAY FRANK MCCOURT CWD A LINING
OUR COMMENTS WITH THE THAT VERY --
A PROFOUND -- AND SENSIBLE
ARGUMENTS MADE BY MY COLLEAGUE
THE SHORTS I THANK YOU WELCOME.
TO BE SANCHEZ A CA YOU
CALIFORNIA WHAT INDIAN FRANK
SAID.
THANK YOU.
OKAY.
DOESN'T GET CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT APPRECIATE INCREASE
INVESTMENT HERE WOULD ALLOW MY
COMMENTS WITH THE PRICE BECAUSE
AS WELL.
THANK YOU.
QUESTION COMMITTEE MEMBERS OKAY
SO I GUESS I'LL JUST THAT I'VE
HEARD SIMILAR QUESTION NAY
RIDLEY ALL ELIA SAID NO WE'RE
WAITING FOR TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE CHAU LOOKING AT DATA
BUT I MEAN OVERSIGHT HEARING
FROM PEOPLE -- ANYTHING FOR IT'S
TAKING A LOT MORE TO HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY DAYS SO WAS THERE A
REASON.
FOR MOVING IT FROM.
THREE SIXTY FIVE TO ONE EIGHTY
ONE SOUNDS LIKE WE HAVE A LOT OF
FAMILIES WHO ARE TAKING MORE
THAN A HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS --
AND AGAIN THIS IS FOR GOOD COST
SO IT'S NOT.
YEAH.
JUST RATE IS FOR FANS SO WITH
THE PERSON WE'VE TAKEN LARA THAT
WHEN WE LOOK AT THIS LAST YEAR
AND THE GOAL IS TO LOOK AT YEAR
BY YEAR TO SEE WHERE THINGS ARE
GOING.
OF THE DEPARTMENT AND COUNTIES
OF WORKS -- VERY WELL TOGETHER
MAKING SIGNIFICANT STRIDES ON
REDUCING THAT BACK LONG TIME --
TO APPROVE AN APPLICATION -- SO
CONSIDERING THAT AS WELL AS THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING THAT WAS
INCLUDED IN.
THE ME REVISION FOR THAT ARE ARE
IF THEY ADMINISTRATION IN THE
BACKLOG -- WE WE FEEL CONFIDENT
THAT THE THE TIME IS GONNA
CONTINUE TO REDUCE AND BEST
PRACTICES LEARN FROM THE
CHALLENGES LEAVE THOSE THAT.
ARE POTENTIALLY NONCE -- RELATED
TO THE THE CARE GIVER OR THE
COUNTY THAT WE SHOULD SEE
REDUCTION AND THAT -- SO THAT'S
WHY WE WE LOOKED AT EXTENDING
THE POOL TIME TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
DAYS FROM HER NINETEEN TO GIFT
WHERE THE STATE COVERS A COUNTY
SHARE BUT ALSO REDUCING THAT
GOOD KONSTANTIN.
JUST AGAINST IT TO SEE HOW
THINGS WORK AS WE ARE SEEN GOOD
STRIDES AND EVERYTHING WE'RE
SAYING IS THE INTENT OF OF ALL
OF THIS LEGISLATION AND IS. TO
GET THE APPROVAL DONE WITHIN
NINETY DAYS TO GET THE CARE
GIVERS THE FUNDING AND ALSO GET
THEM MOVING FORWARD TO THE NEXT
LEVEL OF CARE THAT THEY MAY BE
RECEIVING.
OKAY WELL I MEAN I APPRECIATE
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING AND I THINK
THE OBVIOUSLY THE GOAL IS I MEAN
WE DON'T WANT PEOPLE TO HAVE. TO
THREE AT THREE HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE DAYS.
SO I MEAN THE HOPE IS IS IN THE
GOAL IS TO SHRINK THAT TIME AND
THAT'S BEEN HAPPENING WERE
DESTROYED ALLOCATING THE MONEY
I'M I'M JUST CONCERNED THAT WHAT
HAPPENS IS UNTIL WE PROVE WE'VE
DONE THAT.
RIGHT I MEAN WE'RE PUTTING THE
RESOURCES MAKING DECISIONS A
DRIVE THAT BUT UNTIL WE PROVEN
WE'VE DONE THAT.
IF WE ALSO CHANGE THE LANGUAGE
TO SAY BECAUSE THEY HAS IS AGAIN
IT'S FOR GOOD COPS SO IT'S NOT A
SITUATION WHERE A PERSON DEL
THEY'RE SAYING ARMS GOING TO
STALL AND WAIT FOR THE UNDER
SIXTY FIVE AND DRAG THIS THING
OUT IF THEY'RE DRAGGING IT OUT
THEN THEY DON'T.
GET THE MONEY ANYWAY.
I I DON'T FAMILIES GETTING
CAUGHT BETWEEN SO IDEALLY WHAT
HAPPENS WE MADE INVESTMENT WITH
A SHRINK THOSE BACKLOGS SHRINK
THE TIME AND VERY FEW PEOPLE
ACTUALLY GOT AVAIL THEMSELVES OF
IT AT THAT OUTSIDE BUT IF.
WE HAPPEN TO BE A LITTLE WRONG.
AND THERE'S SOME FAMILIES WERE
CAUGHT THERE I HATE FOR THEM TO
GET FALL BETWEEN THE CRACKS SO I
GUESS THAT'S WHY I DON'T QUITE
UNDERSTAND BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO
SHOW BECAUSE IT'S NOT LIKE THE
STATE THEY THEMSELVES DRAG IT
OUT THEY'RE NOT GETTING THE
MONEY ANYWAY.
RIGHT. EIGHT THREE WITH
RECOGNIZING THIS CONCERNS AND
THAT'S WHERE THE WE TAKE AN
APPROACH IN THERE THIS ISN'T
WITH US IN THIS TO BE A FINAL
SOLUTION THE ANIMAL -- IN
SOLUTION FOR EVERYTHING -- AND
YOU WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WTH
THE DEPARTMENT OF COUNTY TO SEE
HOW THINGS ARE GOING AND WORK
WITH THEM ON ON THE BEST WAY TO
GO FORWARD ON EVERYTHING.
I APPRECIATE THAT OKAY WELL YOU
SEE THAT YES IF I MAY TO I I
JUST WANT TO CLARIFY ALTHOUGH
TECHNICALLY THE STATUE DOESN'T
REQUIRE PAYMENT BE ON THOSE TIME
FRAMES WE FIND IT HIGHLY
UNLIKELY THAT COUNTIES WOULD AT
THE END OF THE DAY.
NOT CONTINUE TO PROVIDE SUPPORT
BEYOND WHAT THE STATE PROVIDES
SHOULD THE PROCESS TAKE LONGER.
NOT NOT TO SUGGEST THAT THEY
WOULD BUT I THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION IS VIEWING THIS
AS A GRADUAL PHASE DOWN TOWARD
THE ULTIMATE GOAL.
OF GETTING WHERE WE ARE AND WHO
WE THINK OF MAINTAINING GOOD
BECAUSE THROUGH IS THREE SIXTY
FIVE PROBABLY MERITS FURTHER
DISCUSSION -- ME IN REGARDS OF
WHERE WE'RE TRYING TO GET TO
APPRECIATE JUST I JUST WANT
FAMILIES BEING PUNISHED FOR
SOMETHING THAT THEY'RE EIGHT AND
AGAIN THE GOAL IS WE DON'T WANT
PEOPLE AT THE IS THIS.
RIGHT YES YES OKAY AND I
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
LEADERSHIP AND INVESTING AND AND
MAKING THAT HAPPEN BY PUTTING
THE INVESTMENT I JUST DON'T.
FEEL DEPENDING ON THE
CIRCUMSTANCES I DON'T HAVE A
CREATE A SITUATION WHERE.
THE FAMILIES GET CAUGHT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
RIGHT ALL RIGHTS WILL HOLD THIS
ITEM OPEN -- ALL RIGHT IT IS --
ELEVEN FIFTY ONE I'VE BEEN TOLD
FOR MY CAUCUS WE WANT TO START
ON TIME SO AND I DON'T THINK WE
WERE GOING TO FILL FINISH ALL
THE REST OF THE ITEMS -- IN
ABOUT TEN MINUTES SO.
WE WILL GO AHEAD AND TAKE A
RECESS AND RECONVENE AT ONE
THIRTY AND SO I THINK EVERYONE
FOR BEING HERE AND WE WILL SEE
YOU BACK AT ONE THIRTY THANKS
VERY MUCH
FOR GIVE MY COLLEAGUES A CHANCE
TO BE HERE.
WELL SINCE FOR ON CAMERA.
SO I THINK -- APOLOGIZE THE
CAUCUSES RAN A LITTLE LONGER
ENOUGH SO.
BUT I WILL ASK MY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO PLEASE.
OF YOUR STAFF COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
PLEASE ASK THEM THEY CAN PLEASE
COME TO THE HEARING ROOM -- WE
ARE RESUMING -- AND I AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE [inaudible]
ALRIGHT.
OKAY SO I THINK [inaudible]
Q..
OKAY SO I THINK WE'RE GOING TO
GO AHEAD AND RESUME THIS HEARING --
SO WERE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH -- SO WE ARE
NOW -- AND PART BE -- A NUMBER
FIVE ONE NATO DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES CALIFORNIA WELFARE
SERVICES AND I BELIEVE WE HAD
CONCLUDED ON ISSUE TOO SO WE ARE
NOW ON ISSUE.
THREE AND SO -- THE FARM SOCIAL
SERVICES WHICH TO PRESENT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
PETER BRINK AGAIN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT -- AT THE MAY
REVISION IT INCLUDES --
CONTINUATION AND FOR ANOTHER
YEAR OF FUNDING FOR FOSTER
PARENT REACH.
TENSION RECRUITMENT AND SUPPORT --
THIS IS A KEY COMPONENT OF OUR
EFFORTS IN THE CONTINUUM OF CARE
REFORM TO FIND AND RETAIN.
HIGH QUALITY FAMILIES -- COUNTY
COUNTIES OF INDICATED THAT THIS
IS BEEN AN IMPORTANT PART OF IT
AND THEIR SUCCESS IN IN CHANGING
THE WAY THEY THINK ABOUT THAT
AND GOING AROUND THOSE
ACTIVITIES AND PROVIDING THOSE
SUPPORTS TO THOSE FAMILIES --
AND SO WE ARE PROPOSING ACT THAT
THAT CONTINUE FOR ANOTHER YEAR.
OKAY THANK YOU L. L..
JANIE BELL LA -- WE HAVE NO
CONCERNS AT THE PROPOSAL.
FINANCE.
ALL RIGHT COMMITTEE MEMBERS ALL
RIGHT PUBLIC COMMENT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FRANK MCCOURT
SEATED BDA WE SUPPORT THE MAYOR
VISION -- APROPOS TO MY COMMENTS
ON RSA WE LOOK FORWARD TO I'M
GOING CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE
ONGOING WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH
C. C. R. INSTANCES IS THE
CLOSEST AGENDA ITEM. TO AN
ADDITIONAL ITEM THAT WE BROUGHT
FORWARD WE HAD A DISCUSSION IN A
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING ABOUT THE
NEED FOR AN EXTENSION. FOR
GROUPON SO HAVING CONVERTED TO
S. T. R. T. PEACE AND SO WE HAVE
SUBMITTED LANGUAGE.
I TO THE COMMITTEE AND TO THE
ADMINISTRATION AND WE'RE HOPING
TO WORK THAT OUT BEFORE THE
BUDGETS RESOLVED.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
JUSTIN GET CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES -- IN
SUPPORT OF THIS PROPOSAL AND
APPRECIATE THE ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENT HERE AND LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS AS
WELL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
MY THE GRILL REPRESENTED LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND I AGO THE
COMMENTS OF CWD AND SUPPORT AS
WELL THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU.
CASINO THE COMMENTS WILL HOLD
THAT ITEM OPEN APPRECIATE -- THE
VERY IMPORTANT TO CONTINUED
INVESTMENTS AS WE MOVE -- THIS
CITY OUR FORD SO ARE ISSUE
NUMBER FOUR DEPEND SEE COUNCIL
TITLE FOR E. FUNDING.
A ROAD FOR A FOR A TITLE FOR IS
THE CHILD WELFARE FUNDING SOURCE --
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CHANGED
ITS INTERPRETATION OF ALLOWED
USES FOR THAT TO ALLOW FOR THE
FIRST TIME ITS USE -- FOR LEGAL
COUNSEL AND INDEPENDENCY
PROCEEDINGS -- BASED ON THE
ROUGHLY HUNDRED AND FIFTY NINE
HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION IN
JUDICIAL COUNCILS BUDGET THAT
WOULD BE THE MATCH FOR THIS.
WE PLAN TO PASS THIS THROUGH TO
THEM FOR ALLOCATION TO THEIR
EXISTING -- DEPENDENCY COUNCIL
PROVIDERS -- IT'S NO SURPRISE
THAT WHEN PEOPLE D REPRESENTED
IN THESE PROCEEDINGS THE
OUTCOMES ARE BETTER FOR FOR ALL
PARTIES INVOLVED.
EXCELLENT THANK YOU HELLO
[inaudible]
FINANCE.
THE MEMBERS PUBLIC COMMENT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ELIZABETH ESPINOSA HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF A COALITION
FOR QUALITY REPRESENTATION AND
DEPENDENCY COURTS VERY GRATIFIED
TO SEE THAT TITLE FORTY FUNDING
COMING THROUGH THE THE STATE
BUDGET WE THINK IT'S A WONDERFUL
OPPORTUNITY.
TO IMPROVE UPON THE CASO
STANDARDS THAT WE HAVE TODAY A
WE DO THINK THERE'S SOME WORK TO
BE DONE TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE AROUND
THIS PASS THROUGH -- IS ADEQUATE
TO TO GET THE MONEY MOVING IN A
EXPEDITIOUS MANNER MORE
INTERESTED IN PARTICIPATING IN
THOSE CONVERSATIONS -- AND
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU OKAY SEE NO COMMENTS
WILL HOLD THAT -- YES.
GLAD TO DIMENSION WE WE VIEW
THIS OF FUNDING SOURCES A RAMP
UP FUNDING SOURCE ULTIMATELY WE
THINK E CAN GET SIXTY TO SIXTY
FIVE MILLION IN FEDERAL FUNDS
BUT IN THE FIRST YEAR.
BECAUSE OF SOME OF THE TRAINING
IN THE CLEANING CLAIMING AND AND
OTHER STRUCTURES THAT NEED TO BE
IN PLACE -- IT'S A LOWER AMOUNT
AND THAT IN THE FIRST YEAR OKAY
BUT WE DO EXPECT MORE IN THE
FUTURE AND I WANTED TO BE ABLE
TO SAY THAT THING OKAY THANK YOU
AND WILL YOU WE APPRECIATE THE
HELP FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU THIS
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER FIVE THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE CAN DO
COTTON CONTINUUM OF CARE FROM
CONTRACTS.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF PARTICULAR
PLACES OUTLINED IN THE PROPOSED
TRAILER BILL -- THEY DEFINE FIVE
OR SIX DIFFERENT -- SPECIFIC
CATEGORIES OF CONTRACTS AND
THEY'RE SMALL AND VERY NARROWLY
TAILORED TO SPECIFIC PURPOSES.
THAT WILL ALLOW US TO EXPEDITE
GETTING THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND CERTAIN TRAINING ACTIVITIES
TO COUNTIES IN A IN A FASTER
MANNER.
THE COUNTIES AND OTHER PROVIDERS
AND SO WE'RE RESPECTFULLY
REQUESTING APPROVAL OF THAT
LANGUAGE IT'S OKAY THANK YOU
ALEJO.
ONCE FINANCE.
PUBLIC COMMENTS.
HE COMMENTS THAT.
RIGHT WELL WE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE EFFICIENCY SO HOLD
THAT ITEM OPEN -- THIS MOVE ON
THEN TO ISSUE NUMBER -- SIX BUT
THE BILL LANGUAGE BRINGING
FAMILIES HOME REAPPROPRIATION --
I BELIEVETHE LANGUAGE -- ALLOWS --
MONEY APPROPRIATED IN THE PRIOR
YEAR TWO FISCAL YEARS I THINK
SEVENTEEN AND THE EIGHTEEN
FISCAL YEARS -- TO TO BE --
ROLLED OVER INTO BUDGET YEAR
ANYTHING THAT'S NOT YET SPENT --
AND THAT'S REALLY ALL IT DOES
OKAY THANK YOU L. L.
[inaudible]
FINANCE.
IT IS FOR FRIENDS THIS IS JUST
TECH -- TECHNICAL CLEAN UP FROM
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THAT --
LANGUAGE WASN'T INCLUDED TO TO A
MISHAP SO WE THAT'S ABOUT IT
OKAY THANK YOU.
NUMBER COMMENTS US ARE STONE
JUST CURIOUS HOW MUCH MONEY IS
BEING HELD OVER.
I DON'T HAVE THE PRECISE FIGURE
IN FRONT OF ME BUT IT'S WELL
UNDER TEN MILLION. TEN MILLION
WELL UNDER THAT OKAY.
IF I HAD TO GUESS I WOULD TELL
YOU.
FOR COLLEGE EYES FOR NOT HAVING
THE EXACT NUMBER I BELIEVE IN
THE A LOCAL SYSTEM STABLES IT'S
ROUGHLY AROUND TWO POINT SEVEN A
THREE MILLION.
IT'S THE THE THE DOLLARS ARE
BEING SPENT BY COUNTY IS MOVING
FORWARD SO WE KNOW IT'S I
COULDN'T EVEN ACCURATE TO DAY
BUT I BELIEVE WITH ALL ITS.
BUDGET GEN THREE MILLION OKAY
THANK YOU THERE'S A CLAIMING
LIKE TO APOLOGIES WE DON'T HAVE
A SPECIFIC NUMBER.
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU PUBLIC
COMMENT PLEASE MAKE MAKE WITH CW
THANK YOU DOCTOR PAN AND SENATOR
STONE WE SUPPORT THE TECHNICAL
CHANGE BUT ONE UNDERSCORE THE
FACT THAT THIS PROGRAM WILL
EXPIRE -- SOMETIME EARLY IN THE
BUDGET YEAR BECAUSE IT WAS NOT --
RE AUTHORIZED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET IT'S A PROGRAM THAT
PROVIDES HOUSING ASSISTANCE TO
PARENTS.
WHO'VE MET ALL THE COURTS
OBLIGATIONS TO GET THEIR
CHILDREN BACK -- WHO THEY LOST A
FOSTER CARE BUT FOR THE FACT
THAT THEY DON'T HAVE STABLE
HOUSING?
AND SO THE INTENT OF THE PROGRAM
WAS TO DEMONSTRATE THAT BY
PROVIDING HOUSING ASSISTANCE TO
PEOPLE.
WE CAN SAFELY REUNIFY KIDS WITH
THEIR FAMILIES AND NOT HAVE THEM
GROWING UP IN FOSTER CARE.
IT'S BECAUSE OF THE HOUSING AND
FOR AFFORDABILITY CRISIS IT CAN
BE SIGNIFICANTLY MORE EXPENSIVE.
TO PROVIDE THAT TYPE OF HOUSING
ASSISTANCE THAN TO PAY A
STRANGER FOSTER PARENT.
AB SEVEN HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH
SO THAT THE DEMONSTRATION
PROJECT IS ONE WHERE THE
COUNTIES PUT UP A 50% MATCH THE
STATE PUTS UP THE OTHER MATCH.
AND THEY'RE TWELVE COUNTIES THAT
ARE PARTICIPATING IN THE RESULTS
HAVE BEEN TERRIFIC THERE BEEN A
THOUSAND KIDS HAVE BEEN HOT.
HOUSED SAFELY IN ANOTHER
THOUSAND FAMILIES ON THE WAIT
LIST WE ARE SURPRISED AND
CONCERNED.
THAT ABSENT AN ACTION OF THE
LEGISLATURE THE PROGRAM WILL AND
COUNT WE HAVE COUNTIES READYING.
THE PROCESS OF OF WHO'VE ALREADY
CLOSED ON INTAKE -- BUT
EVENTUALLY THE PROGRAM -- AND
COMPLETELY EARLY IN THE BUDGET
YEAR SO WE'RE ASKING FOR AT
LEAST ON A ONE TIME BASIS.
AT TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
TO BE ABLE TO CONTINUE THE
DEMONSTRATION PROJECT AND
DEMONSTRATE -- THE LONG TERM --
THE SORT OF VALUE OF THE PROGRAM
AND POINT OUT THAT THAT THAT
THAT THE SAVINGS IN THE BACK.
A CREW TO ALL SORTS OF SYSTEMS
THE COURTS.
THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM
MEDICAL SYSTEMS AND SO.
IT'S NOT EASY JUST TO SAY HEY
COUNTIES IF THIS IS A GOOD THING
YOU SHOULD DO IT BECAUSE LOTS OF
OTHER SYSTEMS THAT ARE COUNTY
SYSTEMS.
GET THE BENEFIT OF OF THE REFORM
SO WE WOULD REALLY ASK AS YOU
PUT THE FINAL BUDGET TOGETHER IF
THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION CAN COME TOGETHER
AND KEEP THIS REALLY VALUABLE
PROGRAM A LIFE.
OKAY THANK YOU.
ARE ANY INCOME SO I HEAR A FINE
WITHDOING THIS BUT WE REALLY
SHOULD BE FUNDING.
THE SHOULD NOT BE THE LAST BIT
OF MONEY.
YES THE DRY SEASON.
WAS IT A QUOTE SORRY PUT THEIR
RESCUE MISSION I GLOW I GUESS I
GUESS OF SORRY I MEAN I GUESS
THE ISSUE IS IS THAT CLOSELY MEL
GAME OBJECTS OF THIS PARTICULAR
PART ABOUT STANDING.
THE DELF CONSUMING TH ROLLING
OVER THE MONEY BUT THE REAL
ISSUE OBVIOUSLY BEING A SMALL
AMOUNT OF MONEY IS IS THAT.
THE PROGRAM OVERALLS NOT BEING
IS AT LEAST ALSO SAY.
WITHOUT BEING PROPOSED TO BE
FUNDED -- ANY FURTHER CORRECT
DISTRICTS TO THE THE THE PROGRAM
IS ORIGINALLY THREE OUR PILOTS
RIGHT -- AND THE IDEA WAS TO
COME BACK AND SEE WHAT COMES
FROM THE PILOT -- YOU WILL ALLOW
THE DEPARTMENT TO ANALYZE THE
DATA AND EVERYTHING GOING
FORWARD AT THE TIME -- GIVENS
BUDGET WE'RE PROPOSING -- THE
RECOGNITION REAR PREPARATION
THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
TEN MILLION DOLLARS HAD BEEN
SPENT YET.
NOW THERE'S BEEN OF OF THE TH
SINCE THE THREE YEARS AGAIN NOW
THAT I CAN IS BEEN VERY
SUCCESSFUL IN GETTING THOSE
DOLLARS OUT THIS LAST YEAR --
BUT WE LOOKED AT THE LET'S
FOLLOW UP WITH THAT THE GUNNERS
ALSO MADE -- ARE PROPOSING
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS ON
HOMELESSNESS -- THROUGHOUT THEIR
THE REST THE BUDGETS -- SO
THAT'S KIND OF WHERE THIS
PERSPECTIVES COMING AS TO LOOK
AND SEE HOW THE PROJECT IS IN
AND DOING BUT ALSO --
ACKNOWLEDGING ALL THE OTHER
INVESTMENTS THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSING AND HOMELESSNESS
THROUGHOUT HIS BUDGET.
SO I GET BECAUSE THE QUESTION I
HAVE THEN IS THE SO IS OUR
CONCERNS ABOUT THE SO WE HAVE A
THREE YEAR PILOT MIKE ANY PILOT
I ASSUME WE HAVE WE'RE LOOKING
AT THE DATA -- THE RESULTS WE
HER PREVIOUS TESTIMONY HERE
THAT'S BEEN SUCCESSFUL.
THE GOVERNOR'S ACTUALLY
LEADERSHIP ON HOMELESSNESS AND
TO INVESTING.
THE MONEY OF THAT -- YES THIS IS
THAT IS THERE A CONCERN THAT --
THAT THE PILOTS FOR NOT
SUCCESSFUL FROM ADMINISTRATION
TWENTY VIEW OR DO YOU FEEL THAT
THE OTHER INVESTMENTS N
HOMELESS THIS IS KENDALL
SUBSTITUTE FOR THIS PROGRAM I'M
JUST TRYING TO CELLS.
YEAH I PRE AGAIN I WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSING A SIGNIFICANT VESTED
IN DEALING WITH HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS I APPRECIATE THAT.
IS ONE KNOW HOW THAT INTERFACES
WITH THIS PROGRAM OR THE ENDING
OF THIS PROGRAM.
I THINK THAT THE SIMPLE RESPONSE.
ACKNOWLEDGING ONE THAT IT WAS A
PILOTS RIGHT YEAH I NEED TO TO
AT LEAST EVALUATE THE DATA RIGHT
HAVE TIME TO EVALUATE AND SEE
WITH -- HOW EVERYTHING WORKED
WITH THE CHALLENGES THIS
SUCCESSES OR WITH THAT BUT THEN
AGAIN JUST A COLLEGE IN THAT --
THE GOVERNOR'S PRIVATIZED A MUCH
BROADER HOMELESSNESS INVESTMENT
THERE IS IS BUDGET SO --
RECOGNIZING THAT THE THE THE
PILOT SENDING THERE ARE SUCCESS
IS GOING ON WITH THAT THAT'S WHY
WERE RECOMMEND OR REQUESTING THE
REVERBERATION OF ANY UNSPENT
FUNDS.
BUT THEN -- UTILIZING
POTENTIALLY UTILIZING ANY OF THE
ADDITIONAL HOMELESSNESS FUNDING
THAT'S INCLUDE IN THE GOVERNOR'S
MAY REVISE.
I I I GET THAT THAT MAY NOT
PROVIDE.
A EIGHT SO I GUESS ONE THAT
[inaudible]
AND SO.
I GUESS WHAT I WANT BY TRANTOR
STAND IS IS THAT -- AND DALY AYE
AYE YEAH ON BIG PROPONENT FOR
EVALUATION SO -- THAT THAT IS
KIND OF INTERESTING YOU KNOW WE
HAVE THIS PILOT AND THEN WE'RE
GONNA.
YEAH I'LL TAKE SOME TIME TO DO
EVALUATION SO WE'RE GONNA AND IT
ESSENTIALLY IN.
BENSALEM A LOOK AT THE DATA SO
WE THANK YOU HAVE A GAP -- BUT
ALSO ADDRESS THINGS LIKE WELL IT
OF I GUESS THE QUESTION HERE IS
IS THAT.
HOW DOES?
THIS PROGRAM WHICH WILL BE
ENDING WHICH IS A PILOT YOU'RE
RIGHT IT'S A THREE YEAR PILOT.
SO THE MONEY AND AND AND SO YOU
ARE SAYING THAT WHAT WE HAVE
SOME REMAINING MONEY THAT STILL
LEFT IN A WILL THAT BUT THEN
WHEN.
I CHECKED OUT HOW THE INTERFACE
WITH THE REST OF WITH WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S AGENDA ON ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS AND AGAIN I WANTED
KNOWLEDGE THE GOVERNOR'S PUTTING
A VERY SUBSTANTIAL AND AND
SERIOUS EFFORT AT DOING THIS.
I'M JUST THINKING LIKE WE HAVE A
PILOT THAT I'M HEARING IS BEEN
PRETTY SUCCESSFUL [inaudible]
SO.
WE'RE GONNA IT ENDED SO WHAT'S
THE PICK UP FROM THAT OR WE
SIMPLY SAYING WE'RE ENDING AT
THIS AND FOR DOING SOMETHING
ELSE SO I GUESS THAT'S THAT IS
THOSE ARE AN INTENTION TO TRY TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO FOLD.
THIS THAT THE WHAT WE LEARNED
FROM THIS PILOT IN THE SUCCESS
OF FROM THIS PILOT SOME SORT OF
FORM CONTINUITY BEYOND JUST
SIMPLY CONTINUING TO
REAPPROPRIATION BEYOND THAT LIKE
HOW HOW OF IT IS THERE'S GONNA
BE SOME.
OFF BRAND THE LEASE ON ON RAMP
AND HOMELESSNESS PROGRAM OR IS
THIS LIKE OKAY WELL THIS PILOT
AND IT'S DONE SO.
THIS WOULD JUST EVERYTHING IS
FINISHED AND NOW WILL WILL RUN
THE NUMBERS AND SEE HOW IT
TURNED OUT.
AND MAYBE WILL CONSIDER
RESTARTING IT IN A YEAR OF A
TERMS OF WEED SIZE SENSIBLE ARE
NOT ARE IT IS OR IS THERE A
SPECIFIC.
PLAN.
TO ON RAMP THIS INTO THE LARGER
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAM. TO THEIR I
WOULD SAY THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT
PLANS INCLUDE THIS INTO THE
HOMELESS PROGRAM -- IT'S A THAT
COUNTY SAN UTILIZE SHOULD BE A
KEY IF IF IF NEED BE THERE
THANKS TO SO THEY CAN UTILIZE
SOME OF THE INFORMATION.
OR SUCCESSES THAT THEY'VE
LEARNED FROM THAT AND ENGINE
LEVERAGE SOME OF THOSE OTHER
DOLLARS A RESUME A LOT OF THIS
IS RELATED TO LEARN TO REALIGN
PROGRAMS AND IT'S A DOLLAR FOR
DOLLAR MATCH THROUGH -- THROUGH
COUNTY AND STATE SO -- THERE'S
NOTHING PROHIBITING COUNTIES TO
CONTINUE ON WITH WITH A LOT OF
THE SUCCESSES -- WE CAN CONTINUE
ON THE PROGRAM THEMSELVES -- TO
THE EXTENT THAT MAYBE THE
LEGISLATURE DECIDES NOT TO
PROPOSE ANYTHING ON THINGS IN
THE GOVERNOR HASN'T PROPOSED
ANYTHING ANIME REVISION -- BUT
I'D AT THE SIDE THERE'S THERE'S
NO.
THERE THERE ISN'T A PROPOSAL TO
EXTEND -- THE PROGRAM SO CAN WE
TAKE SAM'S CAN WE CAN CAN
COUNTIES USE SOME OF THE MONIES
ARE BEING ALLOCATED BY THE
GOVERNOR TOWARD.
CONTINUING THE PROGRAM IN
ACCOUNTING HAVE TO LOOK INTO
THAT SPECIFIC IS AYE AYE I'M
NOTS I HAVE A COLLEAGUE HERE AT
THE MOMENT THAT.
INFORMATION OKAY IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT.
MIGHT CONSIDER THE COUNTY SAYS
HEY IT'S WE GOT SOME PRETTY GOOD
RESULTS THAT THERE'S A WAY THE
CHANNELS THAT YOU KNOW THERE
AGAIN AND ALLOCATION FOR HOWEVER.
IT'S OUR IT'S FINE NO THAT'S
BEING HEARD A DIFFERENT
SUBCOMMITTEE BUT THAT THAT WOULD
ALLOW THEM TO TAP SOME OF THAT
MONEY TO SAY WE WANT TO CONTINUE
TO RUN OUR COUNTY PROGRAM THIS.
THIS ACTIVITY IN THE THAT THE
OKAY TO USE THOSE FUNDS I I CAN
LOOK INTO OKAY MAYBE YOU CAN
LOOK AT OUR STAFF I DON'T KNOW
AND OKAY.
SELECT YOU CAN JUST ON ONE
MOMENT AND DON'T -- DID ANY
COMES FROM LA ON THAT.
WE WILL BE HAPPY TO HELP WITH
ANY OF THESE ISSUES I THINK ONE
THING THAT WE DID REYES AND OUR
ANALYSIS IN JANUARY WAS THAT
THERE IS A PROPOSAL.
TO AUGMENT THE HOUSING AND
DISABILITY THE H. DOT PROGRAM
FOR IT THE SSI RECIPIENT -- AND
THAT PROGRAM IS ACTUALLY NOT SET
TO EXPIRE IN THE BUDGET YEAR SO
THIS IS A FUNDING ON TOP OF THE
THREE YEAR FUNDING THAT WAS
ORIGINALLY -- PROVIDED SO WE DID
RAISE QUESTIONS ABOUT.
YOU KNOW HOW DO YOU HOW DO YOU
THINK ABOUT THAT COMPARED TO
THIS PROGRAM AND PERHAPS THERE
COULD BE SOME FUNDING IF IF YOU
WERE TO PRIORITIZE THE AND THE
BRINGING FAMILIES HOME.
PROJECT HOW WOULD THAT AFFECT
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL ON
H. STOP IN IS THERE SOME SOME
FLEXIBILITY THERE.
YES JOINT BACKED UP AND IF I
COULD I DECIDED TO GIVE YOU AN
IDEA IS FINANCE ALLEGHENY CHANCE.
THAT US I DID YOU I SAY
SOMETHING YEAH I AND I JUST I I
THINK SPECIFICALLY IF -- IF
THERE WAS A AND FUNDED THAT WE
NEED TO GO TO THE BRING FAMILIES
HOME.
PROGRAM I THINK THAT HAVE TO
SPECIFICALLY BE AUGMENTED BY THE
LEGISLATURE AT THIS POINT THAT
OKAY. TO SAY THAT THEY WANT X.
AMOUNT OF DOLLARS TO GO TOWARDS
OUR HOGAN FOR ANYTHING.
OKAY MR MECCA.
WE WOULD THAT WE KNOW THE
DEPARTMENT IS GATHERING DATA
FROM THE THE PILOT AND AND THERE
WAS A RAMP UP PERIOD BECAUSE IT
WAS A BRAND NEW PROGRAM AND SO.
OPERATIONALLY TO ASK THE
COUNTIES TO CLOSE THE PROGRAM
DOWN.
THEN HAVE DSS COMPLETE A PILOT
THEM PRESENTED TO THE
LEGISLATURE IF YOU DECIDED HEY
THIS IS GREAT WE REALLY LIKE TO
DO IT.
THEN WE'D HAVE TO RESTART
PROGRAMS THAT WE ADJUST.
RAMP DOWN AND OPERATIONALLY WE
CAN'T OPERATE THAT WAY THAT'S
NOT A VIABLE WAY TO OPERATE AND
FROM THE STANDPOINT OF USING.
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S HOMELESSNESS
RESOURCES WHICH WE ABSOLUTELY
SUPPORT SOME SIGNIFICANT CHUNK
OF THAT GOES TO CITIES WHO DON'T
HAVE RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE
FOSTER CARE PROGRAM.
I'M A FOSTER PARENTS NEED IS
IMMEDIATELY RENTAL ASSISTANCE
FIRST AND LAST MONTH THE ABILITY
TO MAKE OUR MODIFICATIONS TO
THEIR HOME.
THAT SOMETHING THEY NEED THEY
NEED RIGHT NOW AND TO SORT OF
SAY GO INTO THE LOCAL PLANNING
PROCESS FOR THE PORTION OF THE
FUNDS THAT MIGHT BE USABLE FOR
RENTAL ASSISTANCE.
IT'S A GAMBIT AND IT WILL TAKE
TIME AND I DON'T THINK IT WILL
KEEP THE PROGRAMS ALIVE.
OKAY ALL RIGHT -- CONCUR WITH
YOUR COMMONSENSE.
IT SEEMS LIKE WE'RE WE'RE
PULLING ALL THE INFRASTRUCTURE
WAVE AFTER WE'VE BEEN PUTTING
THESE FAMILIES TOGETHER SO THEY
CAN AFFORD -- DOLING UNIT.
TEN I DON'T SEE ANY RAMPING DOWN
AND AND THE WAY THIS CORNER NOT
CONTRIBUTE TO OUR EXISTING
PUBLICIST PROBLEMS SO -- IT
SEEMS LIKE TO ME WE WILL OF
COURSE WE'D LIKE TO SEE A REPORT
BACK BUT IT SEEMS TO ME THAT --
SEGREGATION OF FUNDS AND AND WE
ARE GOING TO BE EXACERBATING ARE
HOMELESS PROBLEM IN OUR OUR
DESIRE TO UNITE FOSTER USE WITH
THEIR FAMILIES IF WE JUST PULL
THE CARPET OUT FROM UNDERNEATH
THIS PROGRAM.
HE SAID THERE'S ROUGHLY MAYBE
THREE MILLION DOLLARS LEFT.
BUT WHAT'S BEEN A BURN RATE --
DURING THE CITY OR PER YEAR. TWO
AT THE TIME THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET THERE IS -- SIX ONE SEVEN
MILLION ON SPENDS IN JANUARY SO
THE THE PILOT BEGAN IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN SO THE BURN RATE BEEN
PRETTYLOW -- SO THAT'S WEEKEND
WHEN THE ORIGINAL PROPOSAL CAME
ACROSS FROM THE GOVERNOR AND THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
IT WAS THE INTENT THAT THE WAY
THINGS HAVE BEEN GOING THAT
THERE MIGHT BE WARM MORE FUNDING
THAN THERE IS NOW THE TIME TO
CARRY OVER OKAY THEN I MIGHT ASK
THE WITH THE WITH US IF AND IF
IT IS MY COME BACK UP TO THE
MICROPHONE.
HE MADE A REQUEST FOR TWENTY
FIVE MILLION IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE --
ESTIMATING THAT WE NEED IN A
YEAR WHEN HISTORICALLY WE
HAVEN'T SPENT THAT KIND OF MONEY
ARE YOU LOOKING.
FOR THIS IS A MULTI YEAR --
ALLOCATION SO THE SO TWO THINGS
FIRST THIS IS THE RAMP UP PERIOD
SO YOU CAN'T LOOK AT SORT OF YOU
CAN'T PROJECT FROM ONE CORNER TO
THE NEXT.
A PROGRAM LIKE THIS THAT WE'VE
RAISED IN THE PAST THE
TRAJECTORY IS.
EXPONENTIAL AND SO WE SHOULD
HAVE EXPECTED THAT BY THIS POINT
THERE WOULDN'T BE THAT MUCH
MONEY LEFT WE'RE WE'VE ASKED FOR
TWENTY FIVE MILLION WHICH IS AN
INCREASE OVER THAT THE ORIGINAL
AMOUNT.
THAT WOULD ALLOW US TO ADD MORE
COUNTIES BECAUSE ONLY TWELVE
COUNTIES KOMMER DISSIPATE ALLOW
EXISTING COUNTIES TO MEET THE
THOUSAND PERSON BACKLOG SO WE WE
HAVE ASKED THE LEGISLATURE. FOR
TWENTY FIVE MILLION WHICH WOULD
ALLOW US TO EXPAND THE PROGRAM.
IT'S THE SAME TRAJECTORY IT'S
VERY SIMILAR TO THE TRAJECTORY
THAT YOU GUYS.
PUT FORTH FOR THE CHARACTERS
HOUSING SUPPORT PROGRAM UPON
WHICH BE BRINGING FAMILIES HOME
WAS BASED.
YOU SAW THE ORIGINAL FOURTEEN
COUNTIES YOU LIKE THE RESULTS
AND YOU ADDED MONEY SO THAT MORE
COUNTIES COULD PARTICIPATE.
AND WE WERE HOPING THAT BRINGING
FAMILIES HOME WOULD FOLLOW THE
SAME PATTERN.
THANKS FOR THE DANCERS RESEARCH
HERE THIS IS -- A VERY WORTHY --
ENDEAVOR AND I DO IT ONE
THOUSAND FAMILY WAIT AND WE ONLY
HAVE TWELVE COUNTIES IN THE
STATE THAT ARE PARTICIPATING AND
WE WANT. TO TO AUGMENT OUR
FOSTER YOUTH PROGRAM AND REDUCE
HOMELESSNESS IS SEEMS LIKE
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
WHICH WE WE CALL BUDGET DOES
WOULD BE AN APPROPRIATE --
RECOMMENDATION TO PUT BACK INTO
THE BUDGET TO NINETY STARTED OUT
FOR YOU AND SENATOR D'AMATO TO
THE CONCERT I WAS CERTAINLY
SUPPORTED IF WE DECIDED.
TO PUT IT BACK.
YES PLEASE THANK YOU JUST WANNA
MAKE ONE CORRECTION IDEOLOGIES
THAT ARE SEVEN THAT -- FOR THE
TIME PERIOD TO BRING HIM HOME
CERTAIN TWENTY SIXTEEN TO TWENTY
SEVENTEEN SIR.
THANK YOU FOR CLARIFYING.
OKAY WELL -- I I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT -- FIRST OF ALL -- I
APPRECIATE AGAIN GOVERNOR'S
PRIORITIZATION OF HOUSING AND SO
AND INVESTMENT SEIZE PROPOSING
TO MAKE IN THE MAY REVISE SO I'D
I DON'T WANT TO DETRACT FROM
THAT AND ANYWAY -- I ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT -- IN SOME WAYS
THERE MAY BE A DESIRE TO TRY.
TO YOU KNOW NOT HAVE LOTS OF
LITTLE PROGRAMS BUT TRY TO
CONSOLIDATE.
IN SOMEWAY OR TRY TO DO EVEN
TOGETHER SO WE HAVE ACTUALLY A
STRATEGY RATE SO IT'S NOT JUST
LIKE WILLOW PROGRAM LOW PROGRAM
HERE CENTER -- BUT I WOULD ALSO
SAY THAT I THINK THAT IN THE
CONTEXT OF THE ACT AND
RECOGNIZING THE IMPORTANCE OF
FOSTER USEAND ALSO.
AT LEAST.
TENTATIVELY I REALIZE YOU'RE
STILL DOING SOME OF THE
VALUATION BUT SEEMS LIKE WE'RE
GETTING SOME VERY PROMISING
RESULTS -- I A HOPE THAT WE CAN.
IN THE FINAL BUDGET WE HAVE A
WAY OF YEAH WE COULD EITHER
SUPPORT IN THE FAMILY CERTAINLY
CAN PROPOSE ON THE LEGISLATURE --
BUT IF DESIRED Là WORK AT THE
MINISTRATION TO THINK ABOUT HOW
THIS WOULD FIT INTO THE LARGER
TEAM WITHOUT LOSING THE GAINS
THAT WE'VE MADE IN THIS PROGRAM --
AND ALSO SINCE AS A PILOT AND
AGAIN IF YOU COME BACK AND SAY
YOU KNOW WHAT THE RESULTS REALLY
ARE THAT THINK THAT GOOD THAT'S
ONE THING.
BUT I THINK THAT -- WE WE HAVE
YOU KNOW THAT WE HAVE FAMILIES
WE HAVE FOSTER KIDS SOME OF THE
MOST VULNERABLE PEOPLE -- SO THE
SAYS IT'S A MULTIPLE WHEN IT'S
NOT JUST ABOUT GETTING PEOPLE
HOUSE IT'S ALSO ABOUT GETTING
KIDS SEE WILL HOMES AND HELPING
FAMILIES.
THERE'S A WAY TO INCORPORATE HOW
HOW THIS FITS INTO THE GAL
GOVERNOR'S HOUSING STRATEGY BE
SURE WE TAKE CARE OF THIS
POPULAR AND INTO THE GOVERNOR
TENDS TO THIS IS NOT SEEN THE
GOVERNOR OF PLANNING.
TO BUT A TO BUILD ON WHAT WE
ALREADY LEARNED FOR THIS PILOT
AND WE'RE VERY SPENT THREE YEARS
INVESTING IN IT.
HOW WE CAN BUILD ON WHAT WE
LEARNED FROM THIS PILOT NOT
DISCONTINUE -- WHAT THAT JUST
SHUT DOWN THE WHOLE PROGRAM AND
THINK ABOUT HOW THAT CAN BE
INCORPORATED INTO WHETHER?
THAT'S A LARGER PROGRAM RIGHT
NOW OR WE HAVE TO SAY WILL KEEP
IT GOING SEPARATELY AND THEN BUT
FIGURE OUT HOW IT FITS INTO THIS
LARGER PICTURE CELL.
I HATE IT HATE TO LOSE WHAT
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO GAIN WITH
THIS PROGRAM AGAIN IF THE
VALUATION SHOWS DIFFERENTLY
PLEASE SHARE THAT WITH ME AS
WELL AND I WANT I DON'T IMGINE.
INVESTING IN UNSUCCESSFUL
PROGRAMS ARE INEFFECTIVE ONCE
BUT UNTIL THAT'S BEEN SHOWN A
FOR EFFORT A LOT OF TESTIMONY
THAT THIS IS BEEN VERY HELPFUL
SO I'M HOPING WE CAN.
FIGURE THAT OUT [inaudible]
SOUNDS GOOD.
I REALIZE THAT YOU MAY HAVE TO
RUN IT UP THE CHAIN SOMEWHERE.
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU AND AT
AN INDIAN PERSPECTIVE APARTMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES.
I THINK WE WOULD LARGELY AGREE I
WOULD SAY IT'S TWELVE HUNDRED
KIDS SERVE SO FAR AND REUNITED
NOT -- ONE THOUSAND YEP.
I'M HERE FOR YOU OKAY ALL RIGHT
OKAY NINE A AND A NEW YEAH YOU
PARTY MINISTRATION SO I DON'T
EXPECT YOU TO BUT I MEAN I THINK
AGAIN IT'S JUST IF THE RESULTS
ARE GOOD.
HE SHOULD.
ALONG WITH THEIR FAMILIES ON A
POLICY RIGHT ADMINISTRATION
UNDERSTANDS YES NOW AND AND AND
AND AND AND I APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S LEADERSHIP AROUND THE
CHILDREN FAMILY SO.
OKAY THANK YOU.
ANYTHING ELSE THAN ON THIS ITEM
NO OKAY LET'SMOVE ON THE ISSUE
SEVEN TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE CAN
GET BEGINNING DATE OF EID.
SO HOLDING THIS FEES ITEM OF AN
THANK YOU -- KUDOS TO STAFF FOR
MAKING IT SIMPLE IN THE AGENDA --
WE HAD AN AUDIT FINDING FRONT
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HERE
WHEN WE AND A DEPENDENCY CASE
AND A CAN GUARDIANSHIP AGREEMENT
IS ENTERED INTO.
GENERALLY THE FOSTER CARE
PAYMENT AND PAST PRACTICES RUN
THROUGH THE END OF THE MONTH AND
THEY CAN GAP PAYMENT DOESN'T
START UNTIL THE FIRST DAY OF THE
FOLLOWING MONTH.
AND CONSISTENT WITH OUR HEY
WHERE THE KID IS -- KIND OF WE
WERE ALIGNING OURSELVES WITH
FIXING THE AUDIT FINDINGS.
SO THAT WHEN YOU TAKE THE KID
AND HAVE RESPONSIBILITY FOR KID
THAT'S THE DATE THAT THE
PAYMENTS WHICH IS OVER.
OKAY THANK YOU ALEJO.
FINANCE.
QUESTION COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PUBLIC COMMENT.
SEEING NONE OKAY WELL HOLDS ITEM
OPEN.
ALL RIGHT NOW WE'RE GONNA MOVE
ON TO THE FORMER SOCIAL SERVICES
AS A SCIENCE S. P. WE HAVE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE ON THE
HOUSING AND DISABILITY ADVOCATE
PROGRAM STAFF.
WE HEARD SOME REFERENCE TO THAT
A LITTLE EARLIER ALTHOUGH FOR
DIFFERENT REASONS.
I A AND AND OTHERS CAN ADD AND
I'M SORRY.
OKAY SO I GUESS SAYS WE SEE SOME
NEW PEOPLE AT THE TABLE OR
PEOPLE RETURNING TO THE TABLE SO
MAYBE JUST.
ENTRIES ALEJO ACCURACY ELIO.
IF YOU FACE ANY ANTENNA
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT.
BEGIN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS.
HOUSING DISABILITY ADVOCACY
PROGRAM IS IS BEEN RUNNING FOR A
COUPLE YEARS IN CALIFORNIA. ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE'VE HEARD
COUNTIES IDENTIFIES A BERRIER.
IS THAT ONE OF THE EXISTING
REQUIREMENTS IN THE STATUTE IS
THAT -- WALTER -- DISABILITY
APPLICATION IS PENDING THEY
WOULD BE HOUSE PEOPLE SHOULD BE
HOUSED IN IN HOUSING THAT.
WOULD BE SUSTAINABLE ONCE THEY
RECEIVE THE DISABILITY BENEFITS --
IT'S NO SECRET THAT THE HIGH
COST OF HOUSING HAS IS MADE THAT
A LITTLE BIT DIFFICULT IN TERMS
OF IMPLEMENTATION -- SO WE'RE
WE'RE PROPOSING TO TO RELIEVE
THAT REQUIREMENT -- IN IN THE
TRAILER BILL ADDITIONALLY AS
MENTIONED IN YOUR AGENDA --
TRIBES WERE NOT INCLUDED IN THE
LANGUAGES ELIGIBLE GRANT
RECIPIENTS OR IN TERMS OF
CONSULTATION ABOUT THE PROGRAM
THE WAY THEY SHOULD HAVE BEEN --
IN THE BEGINNING -- SO ADDING
THEM -- INTO THE STATUTE IN ALL
THE PLACES THAT THEY NEEDTO BE --
IS ANOTHER AND THERE'S ALSO SOME
LANGUAGE THAT ALLOWS ASSISTANCE
WITH THE DISABILITY APPLICATION
TO BE SEPARATE FROM THE HOUSING
ASSISTANCE.
THEY DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE TO
PROVIDE BOTH ANYMORE UNDER THE
PROPOSED LANGUAGE.
THANK YOU EL AL.
RECEIVE THIS LANGUAGE YESTERDAY
SO -- WE'RE STILL REVIEWING IT
WE DO HAVE SOME QUESTIONS OUT TO
THE DEPARTMENT TRYING TO GET A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF BOTH THE
ANECDOTAL BUT ALSO THE DATA
BEHIND -- THE CHALLENGES THAT
COUNTIES ARE FACING BY WITH
PROVIDING HOUSING SERVICES THAT
WAS -- DATA COMPONENT THAT'S
REQUIRED FOR THAT DEPARTMENT TO
COLLECT STATUTORILY -- BUT ALSO
TRYING TO GET A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF PROGRAMMATIC
LEAD THE STATUE CHANGE -- BY
MAKING THE HOUSING SERVICES
OPTIONAL IS THAT ACTUALLY
CHANGING CURRENT OPERATIONS
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT PROPS
COUNTIES WERE PROVIDING THAT
CURRENTLY BECAUSE THERE WERE
CHALLENGES THERE [inaudible]
OKAY FINANCE.
WE'RE HAPPY TO ENGAGE IN THOSE
CONVERSATIONS HELP CLARIFY SO
THE ANSWER QUESTIONS.
OKAY A PUBLIC COMMENT
[inaudible]
COMMITTEE MEMBERS [inaudible]
SO -- I KNOW THAT TIME TICKS
AWAY SO WHEN DO YOU EXPECT TO
HAVE A RELIGIOUS RECEIVED
YESTERDAY.
WE HAVE A CALL SCHEDULED FOR
TOMORROW OKAY ALL RIGHT VERY
GOOD THEN OKAY SO WILL HOLD THE
SIDE OF OPEN AS WE WAIT -- THAT
CLARIFICATION.
ALL RIGHT SO NEXT UP IS -- OUR
SOCIAL SERVICES CAL FRESHER
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE EXPANDING
CAL FRESH TO RECIPIENTS OF AS A
SITE CLEANUP.
WHEN WE ENACTED THIS POLICY LAST
YEAR -- THE THE CASH OUT POLICY
ITSELF FOR THE EXPANSION OF
CALIFORNIA SHOULD THE SSI
POPULATION -- WAS -- DRAFTED
WITH LANGUAGE THAT THAT SAID IT
SUBJECT TO APPROPRIATION --
THAT'S NOT ACTUALLY POSSIBLE TO
GO BACK SEIZE ON AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL SO -- WE'VE MADE THAT
CHOICE IN CALIFORNIA AND WE WE
SHOULDN'T HAVE THAT BE SUBJECT
TO AN APPROPRIATION -- AND THEN --
WE'RE ASKING FOR LANGUAGE IN A
BILL A NUMBER TO THEIR TO
CONTINUE OUR AUTHORITY TO
IMPLEMENT THAT PROGRAM BY ALL
COUNTY LETTER SIMILAR WRITTEN
INSTRUCTION.
UNTIL WE HAVE SOME BENEFIT OF
EXPERIENCE ACTUALLY
OPERATIONALIZE SING -- THE
PROGRAM OVER THE SUMMER AND INTO
THE FALL THIS YEAR OF BEFORE WE
NEED TO DEVELOP REGULATIONS --
NAY AND ALIGNING THE CAPPY THAT
CALIFORNIA CASH ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM FOR IMMIGRANTS MONTHLY
BENEFIT AMOUNT WITH US ASIDE
WE'VE LONG DONE THAT IN
CALIFORNIA AND WANT TO MAINTAIN
THAT AND I CASH OUT POLICY
[inaudible]
VALUE.
WE'RE REVIEWING THE LANGUAGE --
PER THE JANUARY GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL THE GOVERNOR DID
INTENDED TO MAKE THREE THINGS
PERMANENT ONE THE REVERSAL OF
THE POLICY ITSELF TO THE S. AND
BEAT HIM BE PROGRAMS.
AND THREE THE CAP INCREASES
THESE LANGUAGES TO MAKE TWO OF
THOSE THREE PERMANENT THE CAP
INCREASES THE REVERSAL ITSELF
OVER THE LANGUAGE STILL
MAINTAINS THE ANNUAL
APPROPRIATION LANGUAGE AROUND AS
AND BE IN TEAM BE.
SO WE'RE JUST TRYING TO GET A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF THAT
PARTICULAR DIFFERENCE
[inaudible]
OKAY ENDS.
I WISH THE WORLD YES -- TAR
WORDS PER MINUTE FINANCING I
JUST NOTE ON THE LA OWES -- NO
SAID THEY JUST LAID OUT.
MAKING A PERMANENT EVEN THOUGH
IT'S STILL SUBJECT AN
APPROPRIATION OUR FIVE YEAR TIME
WINDOW WE BUDGET FULLY FOR THE
SMB INTO IN THE AND THAT'S WHAT
WE MEAN BY MAKING A PERMANENT
[inaudible]
OKAY.
QUESTION MANY MEMBERS OKAY OF
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS OKAY AND
LA DOES THAT ANSWER YOUR CONCERN
OR NOT FINANCES ANSWER.
IT'S CERTAINLY A CLARIFIES THAT
THEIR MULTI YEAR ASSUMES THE
COSTS IN THE OUT YEARS I THINK
WE STILL WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE COMFORTABLE LANGUAGE
REFLECTS THAT INTENT.
OKAY ALL RIGHT SO THE WEEK ON
GOING CONVERSATION OKAY.
OKAY NEXT ITEM THEN IS ISSUE
NUMBER TWO ONE TIME COUNTY
MYSTERY FUNDING FOR EXPANDED
COVERAGE POPULATION -- THIS NO
SECRET EVERYBODY'S COMMITTED TO
SEEING THIS POLICY CHANGE BE
IMPLEMENTED SUCCESSFULLY IN FACT --
I THINK IT TO THIRTY WE ENDED
pTHE SUBJECT -- TALKING
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT OUTREACH
OPPORTUNITIES -- BUT YOU MAY
RECALL WHEN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET WAS RELEASED COUNTIES
RAISE CONCERNS WITH THE ADEQUACY
OF THE THE COUNTY ADMINISTRATIVE
BUDGET FOR ACTUALLY DOING THE
WORK -- TO HELP THESE FAMILIES --
AND THEY ASKED FOR IS SOMETHING
IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS AT THAT TIME THE
THE BUDGET.
PROPOSAL AT MY REVISION INCLUDES
FORTY TWO POINT NINE MILLION
DOLLARS -- TO BE AVAILABLE FOR
COUNTY ADMINISTRATION -- AND NOW
THAT THE MONEY'S ON THE TABLE OF
THE CONCERNS OF BEEN REYES THAT
OF PERHAPS THE THE LANGUAGE AND
THEY ASSOCIATED BUDGET BILL A
LANGUAGE FOR THIS ITEM IS
POTENTIALLY TOO RESTRICTIVE.
IN TERMS OF REQUIRING
UNANTICIPATED EXPENDITURES AND
THE PRIOR APPROVAL OF DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE -- SO WE'VE HEARD
THAT CONCERN FROM COUNTIES AND
WILL WORK -- FOR TO IT TO MAKE
SURE THAT -- WE'RE NOT CREATING
MORE BARRIERS IN THE IN THE WAY
OF OF GETTING GETTING THE MONEY
OUT WHERE IT NEEDS TO BE FOR US
TO BE SUCCESSFUL SO.
WILL HAVE THAT CONVERSATION.
OKAY THANK YOU L. L..
WERE REVIEWING THE LANGUAGE AS
WELL HAVE HEARD SIMILAR CONCERNS
ABOUT THE DOCUMENTATION
REQUIREMENTS AND WILL REVIEW ANY
AND WILL KEEP TRACK OF
CONVERSATIONS A REVIEW ANY
REVISIONS TO THE LANGUAGE IF.
THEY DO COME OUT.
OKAY THANK YOU FINANCE.
I JUST WANNA ECHO THE SAME
COMMENTS THAT MR SHRINK I JUST
NOTED THAT WERE OPEN TO HAVING
THOSE DISCUSSIONS AND OF NOTED
THE CONCERNS THE COUNTIES OF
REYES.
OKAY GREAT COMMITTEE MEMBERS NO
OKAY PUBLIC COMMENT HE FRANK
MAKE WITH CW EVERYONE I THINK
THE ADMINISTRATION FOR THE FUNDS.
FOR THE AGREEMENT TO WORK OUT
THE CONCERNS THAT HAVE ALREADY
BEEN EXPRESSED WITH RESPECT TO
THE BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE AND FOR
THE COMMITMENT TO WORK WITH US
THIS FALL I'M LOOKING OVERALL AT
A NEW -- ADMINISTRATIVE
BUDGETING METHODOLOGY FOR THE
ENTIRE CAL FRESH PROGRAM THANK
YOU.
WELCOME HI MY THE GROUP IS ANY
LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS APPRECIATE THE
FUNDING AND BEING ABLE TO WORK
TOGETHER IT'S REALLY HARD FOR
COUNTIES TO PLAN -- YOU KNOW
BUDGET IN THIS IN THIS WE KNOW
FOR SURE -- THAT THE FUNDING IS
THERE SO HAVING TO GO THROUGH
THE ADMINISTRATOR PROCESS
THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE MAKES IT REALLY HARD FOR
US -- TO PREPARE EXPENDITURES
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
OKAY.
CASTING A CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES WHEN I
THINK THE ADMINISTRATION FOR THE
INCREASE FUNDING HERE AND
APPRECIATE THE OPENING OPENNESS
TO A LINE IN THE LANGUAGE THAT
COUNTIES CAN.
UTILIZE FUNDING AS EFFICIENTLY
AND EFFECTIVELY AS POSSIBLE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WELL WE'RE
GONNA HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN ORDERS
OUT OKAY FINALLY WITH ISSUE
NUMBER THREE COUNTING WORK
NUMBER A CONTRACT.
BUT THIS IT WE'VE YOU AS A A
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENT -- THERE'S
A LINE IN OUR BUDGET EVERY YEAR
THAT SAYS CAL WORKS CONTRACTS --
THIS THIS ONE IN PARTICULAR THE
WORK NUMBER CONTRACT -- THIS IS
THE THE PHONE NUMBER ON THE
INTERNET SERVICE THAT COUNTY
ELIGIBILITY WORKERS USED TO
VERIFY INCOME FROM EMPLOYERS --
FROM PEOPLE THAT ALSO RELIEVES
THE APPLICANT OR RECIPIENT ON AN
ONGOING BASIS OF HAVING TO BRING
IN THEIR PAY STUBS TO THE OFFICE.
AS A RESULT OF PEOPLE ENJOYING
IT SO MUCH -- FINDING IT USEFUL
SO MUCH UTILIZATION HAS GONE UP
AND SO THE COST OF THE CONTRACT
IS INCREASED AND THAT'S THE THE
REQUEST FOR THE FUNDING INCREASE
THAT YOU SEE HERE.
AND WE'VE PULLED IT OUT OF THE
COUNTY -- CAL WORKS CONTRACTS
LINES AND CREATED ITS OWN LINE
ITEM IN OUR BUDGET FOR FOR THIS-CONTRACT.
K. L. L. QUESTIONS FINANCE.
MEMBERS OF THE JUST SO.
SO THESE ARE REPRESENTING
INCREASES HOW SO HOW MUCH IS THE
CONTRACT -- FACSIMILE.
THIS PARTICULAR CONTRACT I
BELIEVE IS AROUND TWO POINT SIX
A YEAR -- IT WE TEND TO SIGN ON
A MULTI YEAR BASIS I WANT TO SAY
THE TOTAL CONTRACT IS SOMEWHERE
IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF FIVE AND
A HALF TO SIX OVER A MULTI YEAR
PERIOD.
OKAY ALL RIGHT THE OBSERVE I SEE
IS THAT YOU KNOW WE HAVE AN
INCREASE OF ABOUT TWO ONE POINT
NINE MILLION FOR ONE LINE ITEM
ANOTHER ONE FOR TWO POINT TWO
MILLION SO I MEAN THIS IS A SO
THIS WOULD BE WHAT IT LIKE A 30%.
INCREASE FEES THE USE I'M JUST
TRYING TO GET HOW MUCH HOW MUCH
OF AN INCREASE IS THIS.
WHAT WE ARE FULLY A DOUBLING OF
ROUGHLY DOUBLE OF WHAT THE
HISTORICAL CONTRACTED BUDGET FOR
IT HAS BEEN?
OKAY YES FINANCE THE JOIN.
CLARIFICATIONS ARE DISMAYED.
OKAY ALL RIGHT SO BASICALLY SO
IT'S IS THIS SAYS A DOUBLING OF
HOW MUCH BECAUSE OF THE VERY
HIGH UTILIZATION.
RIGHT SO IT'S JUST A CURIOSITY
WELL NOT -- SO.
THE IS THE HIGH UTILIZATION OF
THIS INFORMATION IS THAT GONNA
HELP RESULT I MEAN THIS DATABASE
PROVIDE MORE ACCURATE
INFORMATION IS IMPROVED
EFFICIENCY OF THE PEOPLE WHO ARE.
GOING THROUGH THE ELIGIBILITY IS
IT SELLERS ARE IS OUR INVESTMENT
IN IN THIS ACTUALLY ALSO MAKING
A WORKERS MORE EFFICIENT OR
RAINY SOMEWAY ITS THE REDUCING
COSTS ARE SAVING MONEY IN SOME
WAY.
WE DIDN'T MAKE AN ATTEMPT TO
SCORE ADMINISTRATIVE SAVINGS
ACHIEVED BY THIS BUT ESSENTIALLY
WHAT IT DOES IT PROVIDES MORE
REAL TIME DATA.
AND SO W'RE GETTING A MORE
TIMELY INFORMATION FOR FOR THE
ELIGIBILITY DETERMINATION
PROCESS AS WELL AS THE BENEFIT
CALCULATION PROCESS IS USED IN
BOTH CAL WORKS AND CAL FRESH
PROGRAM.
OKAY AND AND ACTUALLY FROM A
CLIENT PERSPECTIVE YOU KNOW NOT
HAVING TO REMEMBER TO BRING IN
PAY STUBS OR HAVE TO MAKE REPEAT
TRIPS BACK IN THE DOCUMENT
MANAGING SIDE OF IT WE WE VIEW
THIS AS AN EFFICIENCY DESPITE
AFFECT WE'VE ONLY BUDGET AT THE
COST OF THE CONTRACT.
OKAY SO HOPEFULLY THAN THIS THIS
WILL HELP.
MAKE THINGS MORE EFFICIENT FOR
THE ELIGIBILITY WORKERS AND
ACTION SO I GUESS ANOTHER
QUESTION IS IS THAT EARLIER WE
TALKED ABOUT HOW.
YOU KNOW WE'RE GONNA INVEST IN
THE COMPUTER HOW OF AND TRY TO
BRING ALL THE ELIGIBILITY STUFF
TOGETHER.
DO WE SEE INCORPORATING THE THE
DE SER DATABASES LIKE THIS IN TO
THAT KIND OF A SYSTEM SO THAT --
THE SAID THIS CANDIDATE IS MORE
READILY AVAILABLE TO ELIGIBILITY
WORKERS AND DETERMINING
ELIGIBILITY -- THIS PART OF THE
PROCESS OF DETERMINING
ELIGIBILITY.
ACROSS ALL THE PROGRAMS THAT WE
OPERATE OBVIOUSLY EMPLOYMENT
VERIFICATION IS IMPORTANT --
BOTH FOR YOU KNOW ELIGIBILITY
PURPOSES AS WELL AS MONITORING
COMPLIANCE WITH WELFARE TO WORK
PLANNED RIGHT HAVING THAT NO
MORE TIMELY THAT YOU HAVE THAT
INFORMATION.
ARE YES WHETHER IT'S IN THE
SPECIFIC SERVICE WITH THIS
COMPANY I COULDN'T TELL YOU BUT
EARNINGS INFORMATION AND
EMPLOYMENT STATUS IS VITAL.
OKAY.
YES WE OPERATE A SAID THE AND IT
COULD BE DUE TO THIS OR SOME BUT
THAT THAT'S THE SHORTHAND IS
DOWN CORPORATION YES SOME SOME
SIR SERVICE TO GET THAT
INFORMATION OKAY.
ALL RIGHT SO WE CAN'T SO BETWEEN
EDT AND OTHER FOLKS WE DON'T
HAVE THE ABILITY COLLECTED
OURSELVES OR WAIT THEY REALIZE
THEY ALL HAVE YOU SEE SOME
PRIVATE COMPANIES MORE EFFICIENT
BUT AND WE WE DO IN FACT USE EDT
DATA TODAY IN THE PROGRAM WE
JUST FIND THAT -- IT TENDS TO
HAVE A DATE A LACK OF OF OF
REPRESSION AT LEAST THREE MONTHS
INSTEAD OF TWO OKAY WEEKS OF
THIS THE SPONSOR A ACCURATE MORE
TODAY OKAY.
ALRIGHT.
OKAY ANY OTHER -- QUESTIONS
PUBLIC COMMENT OKAY SEEING NONE.
IT WILL HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN AS
WELL ALL RIGHT RESEARCHER FOCUS
TO THESE TO KIND OF SNIDE
COMMENTS NOT NECESSARILY RELATED
TO ITEMS YOU'VE HEARD TODAY BUT
OKAY WOULD APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY.
ON THE RECORD -- AS AS YOU
EXPERIENCE THROUGH THROUGH THE
HEARINGS WE'VE HAD THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF REQUESTS FOR THINGS
OUTSIDE OF THE CURRENT BUDGET
PROPOSALS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE --
AND WE SIMPLY WANT TO GO ON THE
RECORD THAT IT TAKES PEOPLE TO
GET THINGS DONE AND TO THE
EXTENT THAT THERE'S A FINAL
PACKAGE THAT INCLUDES SOME MORE
MANY OR VIRTUALLY NINE BUT
WHATEVER THAT FINAL PACKAGE
LOOKS LIKE.
A WE'D LIKE TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE TO TALK ABOUT THE
RESOURCES NECESSARY TO ACTUALLY
AFFECTION WAIT ANY OF THE
PROPOSALS AND ULTIMATELY GOT
FUNDED.
HEY ON A ON A SECOND NOTE IN AND
PERHAPS RELATED TO THE NINE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR ITEM --
BUT OTHERS AS WELL -- THAT THAT
WE TALKED ABOUT EARLIER -- IN
OUR EFFORTS TO CONSOLIDATE THE
THE SALAS SYSTEMS -- THAT'S A
MAJOR I. T. EFFORT AND SUCKED UP
A LOT OF THE I. T. PLANNING BAND
WITH.
AND SO IN ALL THE ADVOCATE
FEEDBACK THAT WE'RE PROVIDING TO
THEM ON A TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
BASIS ON ANY LEGISLATION THAT'S
MOVING IN THE LEGISLATURE -- WE
WERE MAKING THE GENERIC COMMENT --
THAT TO THE EXTENT THAT THINGS
CAN'T BE FIT INTO THE I. T. KIND
OF PIPELINE IF YOU WILL OR THE
THE KIND OF TO DO LIST.
IN A TIMELY MANNER CONSIDERATION
EITHER SHOULD BE TO ADJUSTING
IMPLEMENTATION DATES FOR THOSE
ITEMS TO ALIGN WITH WHAT CAN BE
AUTOMATED OR CONSIDER MANUAL --
WORK AROUNDS AND AND FINDING THE
ADMINISTRATIVE COST OF THOSE
ACTIVITIES AND OTHER SUCH THINGS
OR APPROPRIATING MONEY FOR THAT
PURPOSE AND PERHAPS GET MAKING
THAT MONEY AVAILABLE ON A MULTI
YEAR BASIS.
SO I JUST WANT TO GO ON RECORD
WITH SHARING SOME OF THOSE
CONCERNS SOME CHANGES IN THE
SYSTEM ARE EASIER A CHANGE TO A
CAL WORKS GRANT REPLACES NUMBERS
ON A TABLE AND DOESN'T REQUIRE
PROGRAMMING.
BUT NEW BENEFITS OR NEW NEW
PAYMENT METHODOLOGIES --
DIFFERENT THINGS REQUIRE
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF AUTOMATION
AND SO WE JUST WANT TO BE ON THE
ECORD.
WE DON'T WANT ANYBODY SURPRISED
IF WE SAY WE CAN'T DO IT FOR TWO
OR THREE YEARS.
IT MAY BE BECAUSE THE
PROGRAMMING IS REALLY COMPLEX
THAT DOESN'T NECESSARILY MEAN WE
DON'T THINK IT CAN OR SHOULD BE
DONE IT JUST MAY NOT BE ABLE TO
BE DONE IN THE YEAR IN WHICH
EVERYBODY WANTS IT TO BE DONE.
OKAY SO JUST TO CLARIFY THAT
STATEMENT -- AND I RECOGNIZE SO
WE HAVE WE TALKED ABOUT WE HAVE
THIS BIG SAWS INTEGRATION
PROJECT AS AN END TO WHAT.
TWENTY TWENTY THREE THANKS GOAL
SO.
BEYOND MY TIME HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE -- AND IT'S BEEN
GOING ON FOR A LONG TIME.
SO AND MAYBE I'M GAS MORE
SPECIFICALLY AROUND THE ISSUE
ABOUT.
THE CALIFORNIA I THINK IT'S THE
CAL FRESH AMERICAN ROMAN.
ARE YOU ARE YOU SAYING THAT ONE
OF THE ISSUES IN RELATION TO
THAT PARTICULAR PROPOSAL IS IS
THAT IT'S AN THAT THE I. T. WORK
THAT WOULD.
BE NECESSARY TO DO THAT ISN'T.
ISN'T FITTING IN WITH THE
CURRENT TIMELINE.
OUR VIEW AT A YOU MAY MORTGAGE
ANIL STATEMENTS I'M JUST
CHECKING IN WITH THAT WAS THAT
ALSO APPLY TO THEIR SPECIFIC
APPLICATION TO THAT.
RICK THAT -- REQUEST OUR
PROPOSAL THAT WAS BROUGHT UP
EARLIER AND I WAS SIMPLY USING
THAT ONE AS AN ANALOGY I I
COULDN'T SPEAK TO AND TELL YOU
TODAY IT CAN'T BE DONE AND
BUDGET YEAR THAT'S NOT WHAT I
INTENDED TO QUE QUE WITHOUT --
BUT IT WOULD DEPEND ON THE
PACKAGE OF THINGS AND EVERYTHING
THAT EVERYBODY WANTS TO GET DONE
WITHIN WITHIN A CAL WORKS
PROGRAM WE ALREADY KNOW WE HAVE
A PROBABLY SOME CHANGES AROUND
THAT THE CASH OUT POLICY IN SOME
AUTOMATION OF AT LEAST THE
REPORTING FUNCTIONS THERE -- YOU
KNOW WE'VE PROPOSED A CALLOUS
GRANT INCREASE THERE THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF OF THINGS THAT ARE IN
THE PIPELINE ALREADY THERE SALAS
CONSOLIDATION THE MIGRATION OF
THE LEADER REPLACEMENT SYSTEM TO
THE CLOUD.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF THINGS
THAT ARE PLANNED.
IN THE BUDGET YEAR AND SO WE
JUST WOULD SAY.
WHAT CAN BE DONE DEPENDS ON HOW
MUCH WANTS TO BE DONE AND WHAT
THE RELATIVE PRIORITY IS?
AND TO THE EXTENT WE DETERMINE.
TOGETHER AND WITH THE COUNTIES
IN THE CONSORTIUM WHAT THE
CAPABILITY AS WE MAY WANT TO
APPROPRIATE MONEY. FOR
PARTICULAR THINGS BUT MAKE THAT
MONEY AVAILABLE FOR TWO OR THREE
YEARS INSTEAD OF JUST ONE YEAR
SO SO I THE VISIT.
OKAY SO I GUESS ONE THING IN
RELATION TO WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
IS IS GONNA BE -- THE I
APPRECIATE.
THAT AND I APPRECIATE THE
CHALLENGES OF DOING A VERY LARGE
SYSTEM RIGHT AND EVERY TIME WE
MAKE A CHANGE HERE SOMEBODY HAS
TO PROGRAM SOMETHING THERE -- I
GUESS WHAT I WOULD JUST SAY SO
WELL WE WANT A KNOWLEDGE AND
KEEP THAT IN MIND AS HE SAID
PRIORITIES.
WE DON'T WANT THE COMPUTER
SYSTEM ENTIRELY DRIVING ALL OUR
PRIORITIES SO BUT WE CERTAINLY
WANT TO KNOW WHAT THAT INVOLVED
AYE IS THERE A COMMUNICATION.
BETWEEN THE DEPARTMENT AND LA --
ABOUT THE NATURE OF THE THE
COMPLEXITIES OF OF OF THESE
THINGS I MEAN THAT THAT SOME
SENSES.
AT FIRST I I A AND I AND I TRUST
EVERYONE HEARS ACTING AND
SHOULDN'T IN GOOD FAITH AND
EVERYONE THEN THIS IS AT AND I
KNOW EVERYONE'S VERY PASSIONATE
ABOUT BEING SURE WE SERVICE
SERVICES AT THE THEY'RE BEING
SERVED -- I JUST.
ALSO WANT TO BE VERY CAUTIOUS
THAT -- THAT WE DON'T MAKE THE
COMPUTER SYSTEM HAS INTEGRATION
AN EXCUSE NOT TO DO SOMETHING WE
SHOULD BE DOING -- SO SITES MY
COMMENT IN AN AND I ENDED UP I
WAS MERELY SUGGESTING THE NEED
FOR A CONVERSATION -- RIGHT SO
SO THE AUTOMATED MAYBE THERE'S
MENU RIGHT WORK AROUND SO SO
WHAT IT'S ALL IS I THINK WHAT WE
NEED TO DO IS AND FOR AND AND
AGAIN AMERICA AND I SAID I HATE
I TRUSTS THAT.
YOUR GOALS WE ARE SHARING THE
SAME GOALS.
WE WANT TO HELP PEOPLE RIGHT BUT
I THINK WHAT'S GOING TO BE
HELPFUL THEN IS THAT.
THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME YOU KNOW
BE SURE THERE'S THE LEVEL OF
TRANSPARENCY SO WE KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT WE SAY.
WELL THIS IS GONNA BE
CHALLENGING TO PROGRAM INTO OUR
COMPUTER SYSTEM.
THEN.
WE NEED ARE THEY WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND ALEJO NEEDS TO
KNOW LIKE OKAY WELL IF IT DOES
ABOUT PRIORITIES THEN WE NEED TO
KNOW LIKE WHAT'S CURRENTLY IN
THE BAND THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
PROGRAM.
AND WHERE AND AND SO THAT WE
HAVE A SAY IN TWO WHICH WHAT WE
THINK ARE THOSE PRIORITIES TOO
SO I'M SURE THE PROGRAMMERS AND
SO FORTH ALREADY HAVE A SET OUR
PRIORITIES BASED ON AND
STAKEHOLDERS BUT WERE ALSO A
VERY IMPORTANT STAKEHOLDER SO.
IF IT IF THAT'S GOING TO BE THE
REASON THAT WELL WE DON'T WANT
TO DO THIS NOW BECAUSE OF THE
HEART PROGRAM THE OF TO TELL US
LIKE OKAY WELL THESE ARE ALL THE
THINGS THAT WE HAVE TO AND IF WE
DID DO THIS NOW WHAT WE GET
BUMPED.
OFF A WHAT WE GET BUMPED LATER
SO WE NEED TO KNOW WHAT THE
ACTUAL TRADE OFFS ARE NOT SIMPLY
THAT.
WELL THIS IS GONNA BE KIND OF
HARD TO DO SO I THINK YOU KNOW
WE NEED THAT LEVEL TRANSPARENCY
TO UNDERSTAND THE I GUESS THE
CONSEQUENCES OF ANY DECISION WE
MAKE ME.
WE MAY CHOOSE TO DO THOUGH THERE
MAY BE A DIFFERENCE OF OPINION
BY THE ADMINISTRATION ABOUT THAT
PRIORITY THAT'S FINE THAT'S THE
NORMAL PROCESS WE ALWAYS HAVE.
BUT I THINK I AM AND IT AGAIN I
WANT TO THANK YOU SO MUCH
BECAUSE I REALLY APPRECIATE OUR
DIALOGUE -- AND DURING THESE
BUDGET HEARINGS -- I KNOW
THEY'RE NOT DONE YET AND FORGET
APPRECIATE ACTUALLY YOUR PASSION
AND OPENNESS TO THINKING ABOUT
WHAT CAN WE DO TO HELP THE
FAMILY SIDE NO QUESTION ABOUT
THAT.
I THINK THAT NOR FOR US TO BE
ABLE TO PRIORITIZE AND I
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
AND I YOU KNOW I'M I UNDERSTAND
THAT THE BIG COMPUTER SYSTEM
THERE'S A LOT OF MOVING PARTS WE
GOTTA KEEP THE THING GOING WE
KNOW WHAT THE THING BEING HELD
UP FOR YEARS.
AND DECADES IS AT ONCE LIKE
DOING STUFF BUT WE NEED TO BE
PART OF THAT IS WORTH
CONSIDERING POLICIES WHICH THEN
WILL HAVE AN IMPACT ON THE
COMPUTER SYSTEM.
WE NEED TO KNOW OKAY WE MAKE
THAT POLICY CHANGE WHAT IMPACT
DOES IT HAVE ON THE COMPUTER IF
THAT'S THE REASON WHY THERE'S
RELUCTANCE. TO DO IT BECAUSE
WELL IT'S GOING TO SLOW DOWN ITS --
THERE NEEDS TO BE THAT LEVELS
TRANSPARENCY BECAUSE THEN WHAT
CASE WERE PART OF THAT DECISION
MAKING RIGHT OKAY WE KNOW THE
TRADE OFF IS IS THAT MEANS WE
BOUGHT SOMETHING ELSE OFF THAT
WE THE PEOPLE WANT TO DO.
WE MAKE THAT DEAL YEAR LATER IF
WE DO THAT WE NEED TO SITE
THAT'S WHAT IS WHAT WE WANTED.
TO RIGHT THAT BUT WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE THAT DECISION BUT
WE WON'T KNOW THAT UNLESS YOU
TELL US.
HOW THAT WORKS THAT MAKES SENSE?
THE WAY WE MANAGE THE PROJECT WE
HAVE A ROAD MAP TO LIST OUT ALL
THE FORTHCOMING PLAN CHANGES IN
WHICH RELEASES AND SO FORTH AND
WE CAN BE TRANSPARENT WITH THAT
RIGHT SO I SAY AGAIN.
YEAH IT IT TO WHAT YOU'RE ASKING
FOR WE CAN PROVIDE THAT AND WE
JUST WANTED TO SUGGESTED
DIALOGUE.
I REALLY DIDN'T WANT THAT
INTERPRETED AS SO WE CAN'T DO IT
AND THEN AND THEN AND I'M THAT'S
NOT WHAT I KNOW THEY SAY AND I
KNOW THAT YOU GOT THAT.
RIGHT SO IN IT AND I THINK YOU
KNOW.
LA AS OUR TECHNICAL ARE ON THIS
IS SO IT'S IMORTANT AT THERE'S
TIME GOING COMMUNICATIONS ABOUT
THAT YOU KNOW AND BELIEVE ME I
AM.
AND AND IT ALSO AND AT IT AND I
REALLY YOU KNOW -- INVESTED IN
BEING SURE THAT WE HAVE THE BEST
QUALITY SERVICE AND DELIVERY AND
PART OF THAT'S HAVING A VERY
WELL WORKING COMPUTER SYSTEM
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY SYSTEM
THAT DOES THAT.
SO I RECOGNIZE THAT'S PART OF
THAT INFRASTRUCTURE LEAN AS SO
WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE THAT AND
WHAT KIND OF VESTMENTS WE NEED
TO MAKE -- SO BUT AT THE SAME
TIME I DON'T AND I KNOW YOU
WON'T DO THIS BUT WE WE WE DON'T
TO SIMPLY WANT TO BE TOLD WELL.
IT DOESN'T FIT OUR TIME LINE FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF SAAS SO
THEREFORE WE THAT'S WHY WE WANT
TO DO THAT.
RIGHT SOVIET TELL US LIKE OKAY
SO WHAT IS IT I QUITE -- AND IF
WE DID THIS THEN WHAT WOULD BE
THE RESULTS OF THAT.
RIGHT IN AN ACT IN AND AND A
TRANSPARENT ACCURATE WAY SO
EXACTLY APPRECIATE YOUR
INDULGENCE OF THE LAST TWO POINT
NO I I APPRECIATE YOU SHARING
THOSE WITH ME OKAY.
ANY OTHER ITEMS.
OKAY SO -- WE HAVE CONCLUDED
THIS AGENDA OF THE SENATE BUDGET
FISCAL REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE
NUMBER -- THREE WE WILL BE
RECONVENING TOMORROW AT TEN AM
AS WE HAVE MORE ITEMS COMING UP --
SO I WANT TO THANK EVERYONE FOR
THEIR PARTICIPATION HERE TODAY --
SO WE ARE ADJOURNED FOR TODAY
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU